Sachen die die Unionsfraktion ja
angekündigte berahmt hat sozusagen haben
wollte zum heizungsgesetz bzw zum
Entwurf des Gebäude Energiegesetzes
Katharina kühn das wird sicherlich eine
Hitze
im Kabinett zustimmen und hier hat die
aktuelle Stunde gerade begonnen wie
angekündigt von der
cdu/csu-fraktion hier in den Deutschen
Bundestag beantragt und wir hören gleich
rein was der erste Redner sagt Jens
Spahn
deswegen Service Opposition werden wir
diese 101 Fragen als kleine Anfrage
einreichen damit Sie auch tatsächlich
eine Antwort zugezogen hat
die Grünen schlagen zurück die
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen Werft
der
fdp-arbeitsverweigerung vor Kollege von
Notz nennt die FDP
verantwortungslos die FDP ist eine
unzuverlässige und destruktive Clique
Lindner ist ein König ohne Land so der
Kollege Marcel Emmerich man könnte
stundenlang so weitermachen Material
gibt es genug allein aus den letzten
zwei drei Tagen nur wie geht's den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern dabei
rekordinflation
Durchschnittsverdiener haben vier 500
Euro netto im Monat weniger zur
Verfügung viele wissen nicht wie sie
über die Runden kommen sollen und dann
ziehen Sie hier seit Tagen so ein
Schauspiel ab sie maximieren
Verunsicherung Frust und Wut durch die
Art und Weise wie sie miteinander
umgehen
sie sorgen sich um Zeitpläne und
Formalien streiten auf Twitter nur um
die existenziellen Ängste der Leute im
echten im realen Leben um die kümmert
sich gerade keiner liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel das ist macht
vergessen das ist selbstbezogen das ist
unwürdig beenden Sie diese Schauspiel
ziehen Sie den Gesetzentwurf zurückgehen
sie zurück auf Los und fangen sie im
Sinne der Sache das Thema Schutzes
und zwar mit einem Gebäude Energiegesetz
das Fristen hat die Planbarkeit und
Verlässlichkeit schaffen statt
Überforderung wirklich technologieoffen
und ohne diese Fixierung nur auf die
Wärmepumpe und mit der Förderung die
sicherstellt dass niemand überfordert
wird aber eigentlich liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen geht es um grundsätzliche
es geht um den Zustand dieser Regierung
und darum was das mit dem Land macht die
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie würde
kurzfristig als Tagesordnungspunkt für
den morgigen Vormittag abgesetzt Krieg
in Europa und diese Regierung hat keine
Sicherheitsstrategie die china-strategie
wird verschoben und vertagt der Haushalt
2024 lässt auf sich warten der Streit um
die Grundsicherung geht seit Monaten
planungsbeschleunigung bei der
Infrastruktur wird verzögert der
Wirtschaftsminister kündigt vorgestern
in einer Pressekonferenz ein
industriestrompreis an der
Finanzminister sagt gestern in
öffentlichen Rede ausdrücklich das wird
so niemals kommen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist
ja sie klatschen aber treten sie mal
einen Schritt zurück Deutschland ist die
viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt das
was der Wirtschafts- und der
Finanzminister zu diesen
industriepolitischen
wirtschaftspolitischen Fragen sagen das
wird auf der ganzen Welt verfolgt
gleichzeitig machen Unternehmen und
Gewerkschaften sich Gedanken darüber wie
dieser Standort gesichert werden kann
und wir erleben seit Tagen nicht nur in
dieser einen Frage sondern in allen
politischen Fragen dass sie sich nicht
einigen können und das ist mittlerweile
eine standortgefahr für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
Stress
Stress Selbstbeschäftigung Chaos
Blockade auf dem Weg in die
Regierungsunfähigkeit das ist der
Zustand der Koalition Krieg in Europa
rekordinflation
migrationskrise ein Land auf dem Weg in
die stadtflation und kollektiv schlechte
Stimmung das sind die Themen der Bürger
und er fragt man sich übrigens auch
heute wo ist eigentlich der Kanzler
politische Führung ist mehr gefragt denn
je aber vom Kanzler gibt es bestenfalls
durchhaltephrasen aller yo never walk
alone ansonsten Fehlanzeige und deswegen
bleiben statt 101 Fragen eigentlich nur
zwei Fragen übrig hat dieser Kanzler hat
diese Regierung nach die Kraft die
Führung den Willen in diesen multiplen
Krisen das zu tun was nötig ist um
Deutschland und die deutschen gut durch
diese Zeit zu führen
und die zweite Frage liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ist hat der Kanzler hat der
Vizekanzler hat der Finanzminister hat
diese Regierung haben die eigentlich für
das was sie tun noch die das Vertrauen
der Mehrheit dieses Parlamentes diese
Frage stellt sich mittlerweile
angesichts dessen was sie in den letzten
Tagen die aufführen
Entschuldigung
in Zeiten in Zeiten der Krise braucht es
politische Führung und Verlässlichkeit
die liefern sie nicht auch in dieser
Woche wieder nicht besinnen sie sich im
Interesse unseres Landes
Jens Spahn hier in der Aktuellen Stunde
die die cdu/csu-fraktion beantragt hat
weil eben es Probleme in der großen in
der Ampelkoalition gibt die Reform des
Gebäude Energiegesetzes wird nun wohl
nicht vor der Sommerpause verabschiedet
weil die FDP-Fraktion grundsätzliche
Bedenken hat das führt zu Verstimmungen
weil
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert habe
ich eben mit einer schnellen
Verabschiedung gerechnet hat er wirkte
FDP auch Wortbruch vor und auch die SPD
fordert eine schnelle Verabschiedung des
Gesetzes für die SPD nun mal Matthias
Mersch
also sie haben von Schauspiel gesprochen
was sie jetzt hier abgezogen haben
gleich ein Schauspiel und einen Überfall
Spiel im übrigen auch denn wenn Sie hier
Führungslosigkeit Mann wer hat denn die
Versorgungssicherheit mit Energie im
letzten Jahr gesichert wer hat die
Bezahlbarkeit in diesem Land von Energie
gesichert es war die Ampel sie haben
Vorschläge gemacht die genau in die
andere Richtung gegangen sind
und dann würde ich mir ja noch mal
vorstellen dass sie wenigstens eine
Aktuelle Stunde machen und wir in
irgendeiner Form von ihnen in der Sache
mal was hören wo sind denn bitte die
Vorschläge hier das Thema Wärme von der
CDU zu beantworten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wo ist ein Vorschlag stattdessen eine
üble populistische Kampagne wo sie den
Menschen etwas vormachen und übelst
übelst mit den engsten spielen lieber
Herr Spahn
ich sage Ihnen ja sie haben Recht Herr
Merz hören sie zu hören Sie einfach mal
zu Herr Spahn hat in einem Herr Spahn
hat in einem Punkt recht es geht um sehr
sehr grundsätzliche Fragen denn wir
haben denn wir haben zusammen
mittlerweile sind sie ja sogar Fan des
Gesetzes habe ich gehört wir haben
gemeinsam ein Klimaschutzgesetz hier
beschlossen dieses Klimaschutzgesetz
sieht vor dass wir im Jahre 2045
klimaneutral sind bis dato kann es keine
fossilen Heizsysteme mehr gehen wir
haben parallel dazu ein CO2-Preis
beschlossen sie plädieren für den
Emissionshandel das klingt im Moment
alles super wohin führt es wenn wir
jetzt nicht handeln und sensibilisieren
und den Menschen sagen dass sie
umsteigen müssen
für dazu dass wir spätestens 2028 29
Preise erleben wo die Leute plötzlich
wenn sie erweiter auf das fossile
Energie setzen entweder nicht mehr
heizen können oder sie Anlagen
auswechseln müssen aber dann ganz
plötzlich und das ist der Schock den wir
genau nicht wollen das ist unser
grundsätzlicher Unterschied
und deswegen wenn Sie hier sagen
Klimaschutz ohne Kostenschock sie
provozieren dass viele viele Millionen
von Haushalte irgendwann den Schock
haben das muss man den Leuten sagen wenn
es hier um diese Debatten geht
und dann flankieren sie das alles noch
und sagen und sagen beispielsweise
verheizt nicht meine Miete wer war in
dem letzten in der letzten
Legislaturperiode mit uns nicht in der
Lage die Mieterinnen und Mieter in
angemessen zu schützen vor einem hohen
CO2-Preis und eine Aufteilung
hinzubekommen das waren sie
und eine und eine besondere Stilblüte
Herr Kollege Merz ist dann noch die
Aussage verheizt nicht unsere Rente da
sagen sie mit 66 Jahren da fängt das
Leben an ich hoffe der Flugblatt wird
jetzt ganz schnell geändert denn ich
habe ja gestern genommen die CDU will
jetzt die Rente mit 72 also fangen sie
an das ist
das ist CDU
aber in der Tat ist ja nicht zu spät und
nach aktuelle Stunde kann ja auch anders
sein wir werden hier im Parlament die
Vorlage der Regierung in der Tat beraten
und jeder und jeder Vorschlag von ihnen
ist willkommen jeder Vorschlag von ihnen
ist Willkommen Wir haben im letzten Jahr
richtig viel geschafft im Bereich
erneuerbarer Energien und wir werden in
diesen in diesen in dieser in diesem
beratungsablauf den nächsten großen
Punkt das Heizen und vornehmen und wir
werden beweisen müssen und das ist nicht
einfach aber wir werden beweisen müssen
das Klimaschutz und sozialer
Zusammenhalt tatsächlich organisierbar
sind insofern werden wir über Förderung
reden
wir werden über die Frage von
Technologien reden wir werden die Frage
von Übergangsfristen etc behandeln ich
bin mir sehr sicher wir werden in dieser
Ampel jetzt auch dieses große Thema
angehen was wir leider mit Ihnen
zusammen nicht angehen konnten wir
werden das Thema Heizung und im übrigen
auch das Thema Mobilität angehen meine
Bitte an Sie ist dass Sie nicht den
Populismus nachgehen weil ansonsten
machen Sie eine Truppe stark und die
sitzt dort vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit die Erwiderung von Matthias
Miersch zuletzt hatte hier dann auch
noch mal auf die AFD verwiesen und die
kann nun hier als nächstes reden mag
Bernhard ist der baupolitische Sprecher
der afd-fraktion hat sich auch schon
klar gegen das neue heizungsgesetz
ausgesprochen
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir haben uns bei der Energiewende
geirrt
werden das schon bereits vor zehn Jahren
gesagt
kein klimaleugner kein
Verschwörungstheoretiker und auch kein
afd-politiker nein es war habecks
entlassener Staatssekretär reichen denn
der letzte Woche als denjenigen der die
Energiewende wieder zum Laufen gebracht
habe verabschiedet hat reichen vor zehn
Jahren zu wörtlich wir haben uns geirrt
bei der Energiewende nicht in ein paar
Details sondern in einem zentralen Punkt
die vielen Windräder und Solaranlagen
die Deutschland baut leisten nicht das
was wir uns von ihnen versprochen haben
wir hatten gehofft dass sie die
schmutzigen Kohlekraftwerke ersetzen
werden durch das tun sie eben nicht wenn
reichen also schon vor zehn Jahren
wusste dass die Energiewende nicht
funktioniert warum wird sie dann jetzt
mit aller Macht durchgedrückt warum
werden per Notverordnung landschafts-
obwohl er also genau wusste dass die
Energiewende überhaupt nicht
funktioniert wollte er in ihrem Auftrag
er Habeck mit dem heizungshammer mehr
als 60 Millionen Menschen dazu zwingen
zukünftig nur noch mit Strom zu heizen
dabei wusste doch ganz genau dass dafür
aufgrund der Abschaltung der kern- und
Kohlekraftwerke gar nicht genügend Strom
zur Verfügung steht so kann
beispielsweise Deutschlands größte
Wohnungsgesellschaft unzählige
elektrische Wärmepumpen nicht in Betrieb
nehmen weil der Strom fehlt trotzdem
hatte den Gesetzentwurf ganz bewusst so
geschrieben dass wir die meisten
Menschen nur noch der Einbau einer
Wärmepumpe möglich ist und das obwohl
das Heizen mit Strom auch noch um 30%
teurer als mit Gas ist gut dass so
jemand weg ist
und jetzt jetzt muss auch dieser
heizungshammer Weg und zwar komplett weg
denn ist doch völlig absurd dass den
Menschen verboten werden soll mit Gas zu
heizen während die Regierung
gleichzeitig 50
Gaskraftwerke bauen will wo man dann mit
dreckigem fracking-gas den Strom erzeugt
Zeugen will mit dem die Menschen
zukünftig heizen sollen was für ein
Aberwitz und als ich Ihnen als ich ihn
im April vorgerechnet habe dass dieser
heizungshammer die Menschen 2000
Milliarden Euro kosten würde haben sie
mich hier im Deutschen Bundestag
ungläubig angeschaut und mit dem Kopf
geschüttet und jetzt und jetzt haben
ganz offensichtlich sie ja selbst von
der FDP mal nachgerechnet und kommen
sogar auf 200 Milliarden Euro also
30.000 Euro pro Kopf der Bevölkerung
und Wissenschaftler bestätigen dass es
damit noch nicht einmal seine
CO2-Einsparung kommt ja der Schwachsinn
wurde doch von ihrer von ihren
fdp-kollegen bestätigt die haben doch
nachgerechnet 2500 Milliarden Euro
die Welt und eins ist doch klar die
wärmewende ist nicht machbar denn wir
haben nicht genügend Wärmepumpen wir
haben nicht genügend Handwerker wir
haben nicht genügend Strom und die
Menschen haben schon gar nicht genügend
Geld um diesen Wahnsinn zu bezahlen und
jetzt und jetzt kommen sie von der CDU
und spielen sich hier als Retter der
Nation auf und wollen die Wärme werden
die angeblich
sozialverträglich neu starten was sie
unter sozial versteht haben sie uns ja
mit ihrem Antrag in der letzten
Sitzungswoche klar und deutlich gezeigt
sie setzen darauf dass sie Brüsseler
CO2-Zertifikate Öl und Gas so teuer
machen dass sich die Menschen Öl und Gas
praktisch gar nicht mehr leisten können
ab 2027 gehen Experten davon aus dass es
zu einer Verzehnfachung des co2-preises
auf bis zu 300 Euro pro Tonne kommen
wird für den Liter Diesel bedeutet es
eine Preiserhöhung umfasst einen Euro
das verstehen sie von der CDU also unser
sozialverträglich
das einzige das einzige was wirklich
sozialverträglich ist und die Menschen
vor Altersarmut und faktischer
Enteignung schützt ist diese ganze
wärmewende auf dem Misthaufen der
Geschichte zu entsorgen
Marc Bernhard aus der afd-fraktion hat
sich hier gegen die Pläne von
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
ausgesprochen Robert Habeck war auch
schon länger hier im Plenum sasste
allerdings erst einmal in den Reihen
seiner Fraktion und für die Grünen
Fraktion spricht nun der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
Andreas
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
die Debatten der vergangenen Tage und
auch Wochen sind hart geführt worden und
es gibt Momente der sollte man auch ein
politischen Alltag auf grundsätzliches
zu bekommen das erste ist eine
Vereinbarung in der Politik aber auch
ehrlich gesagt eine Vereinbarung die man
unter Menschen trifft sollte etwas wert
sein
wir haben das Gebäude Energiegesetz in
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart im
Koalitionsausschuss wurde das Gesetz am
24 März 2022 unter der Leitung des
Bundeskanzlers und unter Beteiligung von
Ministerinnen Ministern
parteichefsfraktionschefs aller
ampelparteien bestätigt auch von
Christian Lindner auch von Christian
Dörr am 28 März 2023 wurde ebenfalls
unter der Leitung des Bundeskanzlers und
und und unter Beteiligung aller
beschlossen das Gesetz wird von der
Bundesregierung im April im Kabinett auf
den Weg gebracht um es vor der
Sommerpause im Bundestag zu beschließen
am 19 April 2023 hat das Bundeskabinett
den Gesetzentwurf verabschiedet und ja
es gab an der Stelle eine Protokolle
Erklärung aber auch in der
Protokollerklärung steht sehr sehr klar
die Fraktionen des Deutschen Bundestages
im Parlament werden im parlamentarischen
Verfahren diesen Gesetzentwurf intensiv
beraten und auch weitere notwendige
Änderungen vornehmen Zitat Ende genau
darum geht es wir sind ein Parlament mit
selbstbewussten Parlamentariern und
ParlamentarierInnen das Gesetz muss
beraten werden muss hier beraten werden
das ist das da wo es hingehört das ist
Aufgabe von uns parlamentarien lassen
Sie uns die Blockade an der Stelle
auflösen genau diese Beratungen müssen
jetzt beginnen
und selbstverständlich haben da alle
möglichen unterschiedliche Positionen
und Sichtweisen lassen Sie uns darüber
reden lassen Sie uns über Fristen reden
lassen Sie uns über Ausnahmen reden
lassen Sie uns darüber reden wie man
technologieoffenheit dia Grundlage
dieses Gesetzes ist noch deutlicher
heraus arbeitet wenn das nötig ist
lassen Sie uns darüber reden aber lassen
Sie uns den Job machen den wir hier im
Parlament haben und genau das Anschauen
das ist das was jetzt ansteht und was
wir tun sollten und ich sage Ihnen gerne
ich sage Ihnen gerne um einen Schritt
inhaltlicher zu machen das was sie nie
tun Liebe Union das was wir für richtig
erachten das was jetzt passieren sollten
wir wollen dass Menschen vor allem mit
kleinen Einkommen Sicherheit bekommen
und auch Unterstützung bekommen wir
wollen das grüne Bundestagsfraktion dass
die mit wenig Einkommen 80% der
Investitionen refinanziert kriegen sie
haben sie haben nicht einen Satz dazu
sie haben noch nicht mal eine Idee dazu
es gibt nichts von ihnen kein Konzept
gar nichts und sie blasen hier die
Backen auf während sie sich nicht darum
scheren was Menschen tatsächlich in
diesem Land brauchen
und gleichzeitig gilt Sicherheit und
Verlässlichkeit auch für Handwerker auch
für Heizungsbauer auch für Unternehmer
alle die da draußen sind die eigentlich
wissen wollen wie sie mitarbeiten können
an der Zukunft die
Milliardeninvestitionen auf den Weg
gebracht haben oder davor stehen sich zu
entscheiden von mir aus kriegt man da im
Detail unterschiedliche Antworten aber
es gibt eine Antwort die immer sehr sehr
klar sind wir brauchen Klarheit wir
brauchen die Verantwortung der
Abgeordneten jetzt deutlich zu machen wo
es hingeht weil sie investieren wollen
weil wir Zukunftstechnologien hochlaufen
lassen wollen weil wir sehen dass wir
ein verdammter Konkurrenz stehen mit
asiatischen Hersteller mit chinesischen
Hersteller mit amerikanischen
Herstellern und wir dieser
zukunftsindustrie eine Zukunft in
Deutschland geben müssen wir können uns
nicht leisten länger und Blockaden
festhalten das ist das was jetzt ansteht
und was wir gemeinsam machen müssen
und an der Stelle noch einmal zurück zu
Ihnen zur Union sie dürfen sie dürfen
dagegen sein das ist ihr Job als Union
geschenkt machen sie das aber ich habe
mal geguckt auf ihrer Homepage auf ihren
Kampagnen Homepage das wo sie viel Geld
für ausgeben ich habe in ihren Flyern
nachgeguckt die Suppe ist so dünn sie
könnte nicht dünner sein keine
Vorschläge nicht zum Thema soziale
Ausgleich und dann sagen sie in meinem
Halbsatz ja CO2-Preis es gibt keine
einzige Antwort was das bedeutet es gibt
keine Antwort wie hoch der Preis wäre es
gibt keine Antwort wir teuer dann Heizöl
wäre es gibt keine Antwort darauf wie
teuer dann Gas wäre sagen sie einmal was
Sache sagen sie einmal was die Menschen
zumuten würden wenn sie das machen was
sie vorschlagen wir wollen einmal sehen
wo es hingehen wir wollen einmal einen
konzeptieren von der Union und nicht
immer nur populistische Kampagnen ich
sage Ihnen was
Opposition entlarvt sich selber wenn es
offensichtlich nur noch darum geht mit
billiger Polemik Stimmung zu machen
ihnen ist völlig egal dass sie keinerlei
Rezepte haben weil sie Gefangene sind
eines alten fossilen Denkens einer alten
fossilen Lobby mit einem einzigen Ziel
den Weg ins erneuerbare Zeitalter zu
blockieren das ist das Einzige was Sie
vorhaben und das wird es nicht mehr
geben das kann es nicht mehr geben und
deswegen werden sie mit dieser Haltung
untergehen ich kann Ihnen versichern wir
gehen diesen Weg voran wir werden Ihre
alten fossilen Ideen beenden und wir
werden aufbrechen in ein zukünftiges
erneuerbares Zeitalter mit Wohlstand für
alle in Deutschland
wie die Menschen unterstützt werden
können wenn denn nun neue Gasheizungen
oder neue Heizungen eingebaut werden
können waren natürlich auch eine der
großen Folgen der Linksfraktion für die
Linke sprechen mit Ali
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Desaster
und das heizungsgesetz macht das Ganze
Unvermögen dieser Bundesregierung
sichtbar sie haben ihren Laden wirklich
nicht im Griff
kann einfach mal in den Rücken von
Minister Habeck die Pläne für sein
Gesetzesvorhaben an die Presse raus und
seitdem streiten sich hier auf offener
Bühne und das bei einem Vorhaben das
einschneidende Konsequenzen haben wird
für das Leben von praktisch jedem
Menschen in unserem Land ja wir brauchen
die wärmewende aber nicht auf dem Rücken
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht auf dem
Rücken der klaren Kommunen die jetzt
schon nicht mehr ein noch aus wissen und
vor allem brauchen wir realistische
Ziele Ziele die sozialverantwortbar sind
und kein grünes wünscht dir was auf der
wohlfühlblase sie sollten dieses Gesetz
komplett zurückziehen und erstmal ihre
Hausaufgaben machen so sieht's aus wie
kann es sein
dass diese Bundesregierung schon wieder
einfach ein einschneidendes
Gesetzesvorhaben raushaut und sich erst
im Nachgang und erst nach massiven
Widerstand der Bevölkerung überhaupt mal
Gedanken darüber macht welche Folgen
diese Pläne für unser Land haben wie
kann das sein ich mein bauministerin gay
wird und ihre Partei der SPD der fällt
allen Ernstes erst jetzt auf dass die
Mehrkosten für die teureren Wärmepumpen
und die notwendigen Umbauten in
Mehrfamilienhäuser dass das auf die
Mieterinnen und Mieter abgewälzt werden
wird dass dadurch die Mieten massiv
steigen ja guten Morgen sind sie noch
gleich auffallen müssen Sie doch gleich
verhindern sollen zum Beispiel indem man
endlich die Modernisierungsumlage
abschafft nein stattdessen navigieren
Sie auch hier nur wieder herum es ist
einfach beschimpft der deutsche Städte
und Gemeindebund spricht von 8
Milliarden Euro Zusatzkosten für die
Kommunen wer soll das bezahlen wie
stellen Sie sicher dass Ihre wärmewende
nicht auf Kosten der Schulgebäude der
öffentlichen Bibliotheken oder
Schwimmbäder geht sie müssen die
Kommunen mitnehmen und nicht in den Ruin
treiben Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wie stellen Sie sicher dass Menschen
nicht ihre Häuser verlieren weil sich
die Mehrkosten nicht leisten können ihre
halbgaren Förderpläne reichen da bei
weitem nicht aus selbst wenn man alle
bislangen redestehenden Förderungen und
klimaboni gegenrechnet bleibt eine
Familie mit einem durchschnittlichen
Haushaltseinkommen auf Mehrkosten von 5
bis 20.000 Euro sitzen für den Einbau
einer Wärmepumpe im Vergleich zur
Gasheizung und die eventuell erheblichen
Umbaukosten der Häuser sind noch nicht
mal eingerechnet und ja da rufen die
Grünen schon dazwischen moment mal da
wollen wir doch nachbessern bei den
Familien mit einem Jahreseinkommen von
bis zu 20.000 € sollen wir doch 80% der
Einbaukosten übernehmen
ich meine diejenigen die bei einem
solchen Einkommen überhaupt ein
Eigenheim haben den reichen die 80% doch
nicht aus wie sollen die Leute die
Umbaukosten bezahlen ist einfach
unverantwortlich was sie hier
vorschlagen
und die ersten negativen Folgen ihrer
Pläne die kann man jetzt schon bestaunen
die Preise für Wärmepumpen die gehen in
die Höhe weil nicht genug Wärmepumpen
und da sind und so ein Vorhaben war
umsetzen zu können in der von Ihnen
vorgesehenen frisst ganz zu schweigen
von den fehlenden Handwerkern wo ist da
eigentlich realitative für mehr
Fachkräfte die jetzt ausgebildet werden
müssen
außerdem werden zurzeit so viele
Gasheizungen eingebaut wie wohl noch nie
weil sie die sich leisten können noch
schnell neues Gerät anschaffen weil sie
nächsten Jahren nicht mit
unkalkulierbaren Mehrkosten belastet
werden wollen fakt ist sie beschleunigen
nicht die wärmewende sie beschleunigen
Politikverdrossenheit und das ist hoch
gefährlich unsere Demokratie mit diesem
Wort spielen Sie den rechten Klima und
Leuten direkt in die Hände und damit
meine ich übrigens die alle miteinander
auch die FDP die sich plötzlich als
Retterin des kleinen Mannes inszeniert
nur um sich öffentlich gegen ihren
Koalitionspartner besser inszenieren zu
können wie unseriös geht es eigentlich
und ja dann ist er noch die SPD die ein
Kanzler einfach alles laufen lässt
zwischendurch mal lapidar behaupte man
habe einfach alles im griffigen never
walk alone das glaubt ihn wirklich keine
mehr
und dann sind da noch die Grünen den
blinder Mission jede Kritik an
Arbeitsplänen als Majestätsbeleidigung
hinstellen und moralisch aufgeladene
Abwehr Debatten führen wer sie
kritisiert ist angeblich ich
fortschrittlich nehmen Sie die Zukunft
des Planeten das Leben unserer Kinder
egal und und und fast 80% der Menschen
in Deutschland lehnen ihr
Gesetzesvorhaben ab
diese Menschen sind doch nicht alle
rückwärts gewandt oder klimaleugner und
die sind auch nicht alle irgendeiner
Kampagne aufgesessen machen sie mal die
Augen auf nehmen Sie die Sorgen ernst
und machen Sie Ihre Arbeit ziehen Sie
das Gesetz zurück und legen Sie uns hier
einen abgestimmten realistischen und
sozial ausgewogenen Plan vor und jetzt
noch ein letztes Wort zur Union die er
heute diese aktuelle Stunde einberufen
hat nichts für Unmut Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die wärmewende und der soziale
Ausgleich hat sie in all den vielen
Jahren in den sie regiert haben
überhaupt nicht interessiert und ich
meine sie haben dieses Thema jetzt nicht
entdeckt weil Ihre Meinung geändert
haben sondern weil zum Schluss
profilieren können das leider die
Wahrheit danke
in der Koalition gibt es besonders
Streit zwischen FDP und Grüne die grüne
die Grünen haben der FDP hier Wort Bruch
vorgeworfen die FDP möchte mehr
Informationen haben über den
Gesetzentwurf für die FDP-Fraktion
spricht nun Lukas Köhler und der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzender
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lieber Kollege Spahn ich freue mich ich
habe was gelernt es riecht gut gelernt
ich habe gelernt dass die Union
eigentlich ziemlich froh ist in der
Opposition zu sein die Union freut sich
darüber die Antwort auf diese Debatte
nicht geben zu müssen weil warum Ringen
wir so denn darum wie das mit den
Heizungen in Deutschland weitergeht weil
es notwendig ist eine Antwort auf die
Frage zu geben was will ich was muss ich
als Bürger als Bürgerin tun um für den
Klimaschutz vorbereitet zu sein was muss
ich tun weil die CO2-Preise steigen
werden was muss ich tun damit ich mehr
Heizung in Zukunft anfangen nicht
anständig leisten kann das ist eine der
härtesten Debatten in Deutschland die
sie führen können warum war das jeden
Menschen in diesem Land betrifft und das
einzige was sie hier gemacht haben ist
zu sagen ja Mensch es gibt einen Ringen
in der Regierung darum was die beste
Lösung ist und das finden Sie
problematisch das sind irgendwie traurig
ich hätte mir erwartet dass sie sich
hier hinstellen und sagen mensch Leute
das sind unsere Antworten so soll die
Welt aussehen sie in der Opposition sie
können auch frei von der Leber weg sagen
was ist cdu-meinung ich hätte das
erwartet hier von ihnen weil das wäre
seriöse Politik gewesen das finde ich
eigentlich ziemlich traurig was sie
gemacht haben es ist doch klar es
braucht eine Novelle des
gebäudenergiegesetzes und es ist auch
klar so wie das aus der Regierung
gekommen ist wird das nicht durch dieses
Parlament gehen es braucht eine
Novellierung hier ist der richtige Ort
wo wir das diskutieren die Ampel ist die
richtige Regierung die das diskutieren
kann weil wir die Bandbreite innerhalb
Deutschlands abbilden wir sagen ganz
klar als Demokraten der Weg den auch mal
ebenhofer gerade aufgezeigt das ist doch
der richtige wir setzen auf eine starke
klare CO2 Bepreisung über den Emission
handelt den wir möglichst vorziehen
sollten und das ist auch richtig so aber
das hat natürlich Konsequenzen weil sie
einen Emissionshandel ja nicht alleine
stehen lassen können das hätten sie vor
20 Jahren machen können aber natürlich
brauchen Sie jetzt Maßnahmen drumherum
die sie bauen damit der Preis die Leute
nicht überfordert und deswegen ja wir
werden dafür sorgen dass dieses ein
gutes Gesetz wird das wird so kommen
meine Damen und Herren das ist doch der
klare Anspruch aber das heißt doch auch
dass wir jetzt darüber ringen müssen
weil es eben ein so breites so großes
Gesetz ist natürlich müssen wir dafür
sorgen dass es technologieoffen ist dass
die Leute selber entscheiden können aber
wir können doch technologieoffenheit
nicht damit verwechseln wie das gerne
hier mal getan wird zu sagen ja das
heißt die Leute müssen nichts machen
klar ist doch wir brauchen ein
Förderkonzept wir brauchen eine klare
Kopplung an die kommunale wärmeplanung
ich weiß dass der SPD sehr wichtig und
so richtig so es ist richtig so dass wir
den Leuten sagen wie sieht meine Heizung
die heizungsmöglichkeit bei mir in der
Zukunft aus und das ist doch völlig
richtig dafür zu sagen dass das so ist
und dann gibt es natürlich noch eine
Menge kleiner ordnungsrechtlicher
Details in diesem Gesetz und meiner
Meinung können die alle raus ist doch
ganz klar dass wir nicht ins
Mikromanagement gehen müssen bei den
Leuten zu Hause ist doch ganz klar dass
die Menschen sorgen dafür dass wir in
deren Eigentum Eingreifen natürlich
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass es ein
Gesetz ist dass die Leute mitnimmt das
Klimaschutz die Leute mitnimmt aber der
falsche Weg ist doch diese Debatte nicht
zu führen der falsche Weg ist doch das
was sie in den letzten vier Jahren vor
dieser Regierung gemacht haben den Kopf
in den Sand zu stecken und Angst davor
zu haben so eine Debatte auszuhalten es
ist richtig dass wir diese Debatte
führen und es ist auch gut so und ja
natürlich ich weiß das sorgt für
Universität auch in der Ampel auch bei
solchen Worten wie wortbrüchigkeit und
solchen Geschichten klar sorgt das von
niveausität verstehe ich das ist ein
hartes Gesetz das tut doch mal weh aber
wichtiger ist doch als ein schnelles
Gesetz zu machen ein gutes Gesetz zu
machen weil das ist das was die Menschen
von uns erwartet die Menschen erwarten
von uns dass wir dafür sorgen am Ende
des Tages die Antworten die wir gerade
benannt haben jetzt das umzusetzen und
klar ist doch dass so ein Gesetz jede
Menge Fragen darf aber auch wir sehen
was auf europäischer Ebene passiert und
da hätte ich mir jetzt auch noch mal
eine Antwort von Ihnen Herr Spahn
erwartet wie Sie Ursula von der Leyen
davon überzeugen wollen dass das was die
Kommission da gerade vorschlägt mit 2027
gasheizungsverbot mit dem dämmen von
Gebäuden die sich in Deutschland schon
keiner mehr leisten kann das sein dass
sie da mal macht wird spricht und sagt
nee Leute so geht das auf europäischer
Ebene nicht da hätte ich mir mal
erwartet dass da mal ein paar Antworten
kommen so ein Trauerspiel was da gerade
passiert sie stellen sich hier hin und
halten große Reden und dann haben sie
ihre Leute nicht im Griff na das sind
Trauerspiel da würde ich sagen auf
europäischer Ebene wird da mal ein paar
ein paar Hausaufgaben zu machen Liebe
Junioren
am Ende des Tages werden wir ein gutes
Gesetz beschließen das ist noch nicht so
das ist noch ein gutes Gesetz aus
unserer Sicht das heißt aber das ist das
normalste der Welt dass wir das im
parlamentarischen Verfahren machen
und ich glaube auch es tut uns gut diese
Debatte hier zu führen weil es ist ein
redeparlament und die Debatte
beschäftigt sich nicht nur uns hier
sondern beschäftigt auch die Menschen in
Deutschland und deswegen vielen Dank
Lukas Körner war das am 7 juli beginnt
die Sommerpause die parlamentarische bis
dahin gibt es noch drei Sitzungswoche
und das wird knapp dieses Gesetz vorher
zu verabschieden und Kollegen Herr Dr
Köhler mit Verlaub das Trauerspiel das
ist der
Dauerstreit in der ampelregierung über
das heizungsgesetz es ist das was sie
hier aufführen seit Monaten das ist das
was zu Verunsicherung für bei den
Menschen sie stellen immer neue
Pflichten in den Raum sie beantworten
nicht die Frage wie findet der soziale
Ausgleich statt wie geht's mit den
Förderung weiter was kommt auf die
Menschen zu und statt hier eine Antwort
zu geben statt ein Gesetz vorzulegen
über das man debattieren kann
stattdessen haben sie es gerade ihre
Fraktionen ja nach Monaten jetzt
abgesagt sie haben dafür gesorgt dass es
Parlament im nicht über ein Gesetz
diskutieren kann mir ist egal ob sie
sind oder sie sind oder ob sie sind die
Ampel insgesamt hat nichts vorgelegt und
das unterscheidet uns von ihnen wir
haben vor Monaten
wir haben vor Monaten
unsere Vorschläge hier vorgelegt mit
einem Antrag eingebracht für eine
wärmewende technologieoffen und
sozialverträglich mit dem Grundsatz
fördern und fördern statt verbieten und
verordnen wie es bei ihnen ist unsere
Vorschläge eingebracht wir haben dazu
angehörungen durchgeführt wir haben es
zur Abstimmung gebracht sie haben es
abgelehnt ist ihr Recht als mehr als
Mehrheit aber warum sagen Sie Ihre
eigenen Dinge ab warum müssen wir die
Sachverständigen wieder ausladen die sie
am Freitag morgen anhören müssen das ist
ampelversagen und ich sage Ihnen weil
sie sagen es ist ein völlig das ist ein
völlig normaler ein völlig normaler
parlamentarischer Vorgang wo ist denn
der parlamentarische Vorgang der ist
hier bei mir eine Aktuelle Stunde
beantragt haben aber sie haben doch gar
kein Gesetz das ist nicht das türkische
Gesetz das ist der
offenbarungserklärung der Ampel in der
Klimapolitik
und wenn wenn Matthias Mirsch für die
SPD sich über eine Kampagne Beklagten
frage ich wer ist denn der gemeint es
ist die spd-kollegin Limbacher die
erklärt habecks heizgesetz verbreitet
Angst bei den Menschen im Saarland ist
gemeint die Ministerpräsident Rehlinger
die sagt statt diesen vielfachen
Umstellung sollte man doch besser mal
die Kommunen unterstützen wer ist denn
da gemeint ist es der Ministerpräsident
Wolke der sagt es gibt keine Antworten
auf die soziale Fragen sei so viel
ungeklärt dass man es um drei Jahre
verschieben müsste was ist da gemeint
und dann fällt mir ein Olaf Scholz war
hier bei der regierungsbefragung nach 30
Stunden Koalitionsausschuss und wir
haben ihn gefragt warum steht er so
wenig drin zu dem heizungsgesetz und ich
erinnere mich gut an die Antwort die
Antwort war weil da sind wir uns total
einig mehr mussten wir nicht
reinschreiben und er sagt jetzt und er
sagt jetzt ist es braucht noch ein paar
kosmetische Korrekturen man fragt sich
in welcher Welt lebt dieser
Bundeskanzler er hat die eigenen
Forderungen die eigenen Forderungen aus
seiner eigenen Fraktion nicht dir
grundsätzliche Dinge in diesem Gesetz in
Frage stellen nicht kosmetische
Korrektur grundsätzliche Fragen werden
dort gestellt deshalb ist schon die
Erwartungen an den Bundeskanzler er hat
sich plaketieren lassen als klimakanzler
hier geht es um eine wichtige
klimapolitische Weichenstellung wo ist
dieser klimakanze wir haben hier im
Parlament in der Bundesregierung nicht
gesehen seit gestern Abend angetreten
ist seine Aufgabe hier mit Koordinierung
und Führung zu einem Ergebnis zu kommen
weil wir Klarheit brauchen weil die
Menschen Klarheit brauchen und ich will
ihnen sagen dass unsere Linie dabei ist
ich will Ihnen auch sagen dass wir
beschlossen haben wir haben übrigens von
1990 bis
2021/45% CO2 bei den Gebäuden
eingesperrt und wer mit dem Klimapaket
2019 gesagt wir müssen es beschleunigen
und wir haben und wir haben
vorangebracht wir haben mit dem
Klimapaket gesagt man muss beschleunigen
wir haben im Vermittlungsausschuss dafür
offengestellt wir haben die co2-preisung
eingeführt moderate Einstieg und Schritt
für Schritt aufwuchs Matthias nur
schweres gemeinsam beschlossen man kann
nachlesen wie steigt die Ampel hat sie
im letzten Jahr ausgesetzt aber das ist
der schrittweise aus aufwuchs und das
ist der Gegenteil zwischen dem was mit
diesen mit diesem Weg den wir
vorgeschlagen kommt dass die uns von der
Ampel unterscheidet hier weiß man genau
moderate Einstieg es wird Jahr für Jahr
teurer die Botschaft war eben nicht es
kann alles so bleiben wie es ist sondern
die Botschaft die Botschaft ist die
fossilen werden Schritt für Schritt
teurer aber jeder kann sich darauf
einstellen werden sie in einer Förderung
verbunden wer in eine neue Heizung
investiert für sich für eine öko-heizung
entscheidet der bekommt eine Förderung
was hat die Ampel bisher gemacht die
Förderung die kürzt bei uns gab es 50%
50% ist es für die Wärmepumpe 40 %. es
gibt es soll jetzt nach habe ich 30%
geben dass er eine neue kürzen statt
eine zusätzliche Förderung damit man
damit schafft man für Regierung und weil
die Grünen so rufen schauen Sie mal was
der Ministerpräsident Kretschmann
gestern gesagt hat der sagte man kann
von den Menschen nichts verlangen was
sie nicht machen können ein wahrer Satz
und der wirft ein schlaglich darauf dass
dieses Gesetz eben nicht
technologieoffen ist sie schreiben alle
haben Sie bitte zum Schluss sie
schreiben alle Optionen ein Wärmenetze
Heizen mit Holz Biomethan Wasserstoff
Herr Kollege
komme ich zu dem Schluss dass das was
Ministerpräsident Kretschmann einfach in
diesem Gesetz nicht drin steht
nächste Rednerin ist für die
SPD-Fraktion Verena Hubert
[Applaus]
Herr Merz sie können auch gerne reden
haben sie ja nicht von daher fange ich
dann jetzt mal an sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen gestern haben wir ein Jubiläum
gefeiert 160 Jahre SPD viele große
Politikerinnen und Politiker viele
historische Errungenschaften einer der
prägenden Persönlichkeiten unserer
Partei war kurt-schumacher und der hat
einmal was sehr schlaues gesagt das
Wesen der Opposition ist der permanente
Versuch an konkreten Tatbeständen mit
konkreten Vorschlägen der Regierung den
positiven Gestaltungswillen der
Opposition aufzuzwingen
das war seine Antwort
im September
1949 auf die erste Regierungserklärung
von Konrad Adenauer was man so früh
verstanden hat daran sollten Sie sich
mal ein Beispiel nehmen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Opposition wo ist denn
verwaltungswille und wo sind denn bitte
Ihre Ideen ich kenne keine hier in
diesem Haus
konstruktiver Vorschläge gießen Sie Öl
ins Feuer sie machen hier irgendwelche
perfiden unterschriftskampagnen so geht
keine konstruktive Mitarbeit
[Applaus]
keine Option nichts zu tun nicht zu
handeln eine aktuelle Studie sagt 900
Milliarden Euro sind die Kosten wenn wir
jetzt nicht beim Klimawandel Handeln
allein in Deutschland allein über die
nächsten Jahrzehnte wir verspielen
Vielfalt wir verstehen wirtschaftlichen
stark starke wirtschaftliche Leistung
und vor allen Dingen haben wir das
Problem von Hitze Starkregen und anderen
Ereignissen also wir müssen handeln wir
wollen zwei und 2045 klimaneutral sein
und deswegen haben wir jetzt keine Zeit
mehr für Verweigerung und es ist Zeit
für große Lösungen und das überfordert
sie anscheinend
und ja es stimmt der Weg der ist
ruckelig in die Transformation und
deswegen bauen wir auch ein Gerüst damit
kein runterfällt und das ist das Gebäude
Energiegesetz und uns als SPD sind in
diesem Verfahren drei Punkte ganz
wichtig erstens Finanzierbarkeit wir
wollen dass niemand überfordert wird
zweitens
wir wollen wir sind eine Mieterinnen und
mieternationen wir wollen die
Mieterinnen und Mieter in diesem Land
schützen und ja liebe linke da können
sie uns dann auch dran messen dass wir
die Modernisierungsumlage nicht einfach
nur überwälzen und die Menschen aus
ihren Wohnungen raus sanieren das wird
nicht passieren
und ein dritter Punkt da bin ich dem
Kollegen Köhler dankbar sie du hast auf
die kommunale wärmeplanung wir sind ja
jetzt hier unter uns mit ein paar Gästen
und auch im Hohen Hause darauf
hingewiesen dass wir eine kommunale
wärmeplanung als zweites Gesetz in petto
haben aber was bedeutet das denn das
eine ist die individuelle Lösung und wir
wollen ja gar nicht dass ich jetzt hier
deine Wärmepumpe Kauf baut und macht
sondern wir sagen es muss ja eben auch
eine staatliche Daseinsvorsorge geben
indem wir die Abwärme nutzen indem wir
die Fernwärme nutzen indem wir Quartiere
vernetzen Biogas und all das was ist
jetzt braucht in dieser historischen
Transformation damit uns eben diese
wärmewende gelegt und jetzt
kann man ja bei Kampagnen der Union
immer schöne neue Worte auch lernen ich
habe jetzt gelesen das ist jetzt habex
neuer heizhammer also ich finde
eigentlich ganz gut die kommunale
wärmeplanung und außerdem ist auch da
Clara geibels mit dran beteiligt aber
mein Gott was soll's in diesen Zeiten
lieber Kampagne lieber Worte wir
arbeiten an Lösungen für dieses Land
dazu sind Sie herzlich eingeladen
und es ist schon ein bisschen
verwunderlich Liebe Union dass sie jetzt
viel von sozialer Kälte sprechen ich
sage Ihnen mal was soziale Kälte ist
nichts Tunes soziale Kälte denn dann
kommt der CO2-Preis dann werden sich die
Leute das irgendwann nicht mehr leisten
können und Sie haben doch vor 22 Jahren
mit beschlossen dass ihr Heizungen
klimaneutral das Heizungen in 22 Jahren
klimaneutral sein müssen und sie kennen
auch die Prognosen was das alles
bedeutet und deswegen sage ich hören Sie
doch mal bitte auf die Bevölkerung zu
verunsichern sondern machen sie doch
jetzt einfach mal mit wenn wir
so setzen verabschieden wann das dann
und wie das dann mit welchen Fristen in
Kraft tritt das machen wir hier
gemeinsam im parlamentarischen Verfahren
und da sind wir auch schon dran in guten
Gesprächen in guten Verhandlungen und
die Menschen in diesem Land können sich
auf diese Regierung auf diese
Ampelkoalition verlassen herzlichen Dank
Verena Huberts war das für die
SPD-Fraktion und möchte hier natürlich
darauf dringend dass auch die Regierung
Verlass sei auch wenn es dort immer
wieder zu Streitigkeiten kommt in einer
Koalition auch nicht ungewöhnlich
Bernhard Hermann spricht nun für Bündnis
90 die Grünen er sitzt unter anderem im
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja sie
verunsichern und sie trauen sich einst
den Menschen nicht zu sagen die einfache
mathematische Aufgabe
2045 bis minus 2024 sind 21 Jahre sagen
sie die Menschen jede Gasheizung wird
nicht älter als 21 Jahre oder sie lügen
betriebliches Klimaschutz dass 2045
seien Sie so ehrlich
liebe Kolleginnen der Union die Sie
diese aktuelle Stunde verlangt haben
dass es Dir gutes Recht abgesehen davon
dass sie selbst lange Regierungszeit
gehabt hätten die wärmewende auf dem Weg
zu bringen konnte es ihnen erst gar
nicht schnell genug gehen jetzt wollen
sie wieder ganz von vorne anfangen
morgen bedanken sie wahrscheinlich
wieder es würde alles zu lange dauern
dieses Hunde ihre Unsicherheit ebenso
wie ihr neues denn unsäglichen Stasi
Vergleiche in dieser Sache aber das
beabsichtigen Sie vielleicht
Verunsicherung sollte es Ihnen entgangen
sein wir führen parallel
berichterstattergespräche wir verhandeln
das Energieeffizienzgesetz wir bereiten
die kommunale wärmeplanung vor und wir
bereiten nicht zuletzt das
Klimaschutzgesetz vor glauben Sie mir
das tun wir nicht erst seitdem sie immer
und immer wieder mit Anträgen und
aktuellen Stunden zum heizungsgesetz
kommen Sie Herr Spahn haben wir in der
Debatte letztens vorgeworfen ich würde
den Klimaschutz zur Glaubensfrage machen
statt vernünftig diese anzugehen und
mich gegen den bösen Rest der Welt
einigeln ich weiß nicht wie sie sich das
mit dem einigeln vorstellen
aber ich für meinen Teil und ich weiß
dass es meinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ähnlich geht werde jeden Tag von
BürgerInnen
von Unternehmen von Verbänden von
Stadtwerken mit den Fragen zu Wärme wenn
der konfrontiert und das sage ich Ihnen
mit aller Klarheit deutlich deutlich
konstruktiver als Sie das hier tun
daher stelle ich mich diesen sehr gern
ja ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass das
Gebäude in der gegengesetzt dieses Haus
schon längst passiert hätte und wir in
diesem Sinne echte Planungssicherheit
geschaffen hätten
danach vor allem werde ich nämlich immer
wieder gefragt Klarheit das interessiert
vor allem wie es dazu steht dass ehrlich
zu sagen da gerade nur auf den immer
noch laufenden Prozess verweisen zu
müssen ist natürlich ernüchternd
umso wichtiger ist es daher
konstruktives herangehen statt
geschürter Verunsicherung
Verlässlichkeit statt Nichteinhaltung
getroffener Vereinbarungen das muss uns
jetzt hier im Haus alle leiten
derweil machen wir Grünen was
Parlamentarier tun sollten die Anmerkung
der bürgerinnenverbände Unternehmen
aufzunehmen ernst zu nehmen und in die
Verbesserung der Gesetzgebung einfließen
lassen ich habe aber noch mal einen
Blick in ihre Forderung geworfen sie
wollten fordern und fördern beides aber
nicht konsequent da ist kein Mut man
könnte auch sagen nicht die Ehrlichkeit
nicht das Rückgrat kenne ich aus Sachsen
von ihrer CDU dem BürgerInnen zuzutrauen
die Herausforderung auch meistern zu
können und ihre Wohnung tatsächlich
nachhaltig auszurüsten
aber wo wir bei Glaubensfragen waren sie
kennen wahrscheinlich als Union als
christlich-demokratische Union das
biblische Gleichnis von den Talenten ein
kleiner Tipp das Silber zu vergraben und
aus Angst etwas falsch zu machen nichts
damit anzufangen nie eine hilfreiche
Option fördern um zu befähigen Menschen
in ihrem Willen ernst zu nehmen die er
zur Veränderung beitragen wollen das
sagen die alle im Unterschied zu ihnen
die sie verunsichern wollen auch etwas
zu fordern das ist ein für alle in
manche patorischer Umgang und das stärkt
auch in dem Bürgerwillen Ernst die
wissen das was zu tun ist damit wären
wir bei einer zweiten zentralen
Forderung der Planungssicherheit denn
die hatten wir muss man zugeben unter
ihre Regierung in gewisser Weise
durchaus leider aber meist nur unter dem
Motto wer nichts macht macht auch nichts
verkehrt und das in einer sich
verändernden Welt das kann nicht gut
gehen oder nur bis die Folgen der
Klimakatastrophe stichwortetal Elbe
Hochwasser Baum sterben mal wieder mit
voller Wucht zuschlagen oder Autokraten
von denen sie uns unabhängig und von
denen sie uns abhängig gemacht haben auf
die Idee kommen Kriege anzuzetteln oder
aus welchen Gründen auch immer Lieferung
fossiler Rohstoffe einstellen machen wir
uns und die Menschen hier doch nichts
vor heizen mit fossilen könnte binnen
kurzer Zeit wieder absurd und für viele
nicht leistbar teuer werden
das müssen wir unbedingt verhindern
indem wir konzentriert geordnet und für
alle leistbar auf erneuerbares heizen
umstellen die wärmewende ist ebenso eine
soziale Frage wie eine des Klimaschutzes
wir haben so viel gutes Potenzial
Industrie der Innovationskraft der
Ingenieure der Handwerkerschaft und auch
wenn es um gerade erwähnten biblischen
Gleichnis um verwalten ging was auch
eher der Ansatz ihrer Regierungsperioden
war dann geht es uns doch ums gestalten
denn das ist jetzt nötig die Wählerinnen
und Wähler erwarten Gestaltung von uns
und ja auch von ihnen falls Sie noch als
konstruktive Opposition überhaupt
auftreten wollen
definieren Sie doch mal was sie mit
technologieoffenheit in ihrem Sinne
meinen reden wir darüber was meinen Sie
damit und mein letzter Punkt im Sinne
auch ihrer wähler:innen vielleicht
finden Sie ja auch eines Tages zu
konstruktiven Vorgehen als Opposition so
Handwerker vor Ort mehr und mehr ist tun
ich bin gespannt vielen Dank
Bernhard Herrmann war das hier in dieser
aktuellen Stunde der nächste Redner
spricht für die FDP-Fraktion Christoph
Meier ist der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzender
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren uns eint in dieser
Koalition das Ziel Klimaneutralität 2045
wir werden diesen Weg in allen
relevanten Bereichen zusammengehen und
gestalten und das trifft auch auf die
wärmewende zu oder nennen sie es
heizungswände die Reduzierung des
co2-bedarfs im Gebäude bestand und bei
allen Aufgeregtheiten die wir in den
letzten Wochen hatten glaube ich dazu
gehört denn auch das ein oder andere
was Wortbruch angeht und andere
Formulierung da sollten wir uns alle ein
wenig beruhigen wir werden hier im
Parlament ein gutes Gesetz zusammen
diskutieren und beschließen und wenn die
Debatte hier von der Union geführt wird
und wieder darüber reden dass wir hier
mit unterschiedlichen Positionen im
Parlament dieses Gesetz verbessern
werden
und denn hier die Aufregung kommt denn
frage ich mich doch welche
selbstverzwergung haben sie als
Parlamentarier in den letzten Jahren
eigentlich durchlitten wir sind das
Parlament wir sind die erste Kraft im
Staat und wir werden entsprechende
Korrekturen vornehmen wir werden ein
Kompromiss finden meine Damen und Herren
und zu den Prämissen der Kollege Köhler
hat schon einiges gesagt der
Rechnungshof hat vor drei Jahren
formuliert dass die Umsetzung der
Energiewende in Deutschland der teuerste
und ineffizienteste Weg ist den man hier
bestreiten kann und das darf uns bei
diesem Gesetz nicht noch einmal
passieren und wenn der Rechnungshof das
vor drei Jahren feststellt dann ist das
auch genau das Armutszeugnis für
Kollegen wie Sie Herr Jung die das
maßgeblich mitgestaltet haben der
Rechnungshof hat gesagt dass in den
letzten 16 Jahren sie den Weg der
Energiewende falsch beschrieben haben
und wir werden diesen Fehler hier nicht
nochmal machen beim Gebäude Energie
gesetzt Klimaneutralität
Bedarf breiter Akzeptanz und dann muss
man die Problemlagen auch offen
diskutieren und das tun wir
die wärmewende muss wirtschaftlich
umsetzbar sein und zwar für den
Einzelnen das haben wir schon gehört
aber auch für den Staat insgesamt
und es muss klar sein sage ich als
Haushälter dass der Staat nicht alle
Kosten übernehmen kann die Anforderungen
an dem Gesetz oder andersgesetz sind
auch daran zu messen wir haben
vereinbart
dass die Finanzierung über den KTF läuft
und wir müssen uns und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir die fördersystematik
parallel zur Beratung dieses Gesetzes
hinbekommen darüber im Klaren sein dass
mehr Geld nicht da sein wird und wir
können es uns an diesem zentralen Thema
nicht erlauben dass nach einem halben
Jahr gegebenenfalls der KTF leer ist und
dann heißt wir müssen irgendwo anders
mehr Geld herbekommen was wir nicht
schaffen deswegen gilt auch hier
Gründlichkeit vor Schnelligkeit
und wir sollten auch nicht den Versuch
nehmen einzelne Gruppen in der
Bevölkerung hier mit einer Art
Sonderopfer heranzuziehen Stichwort
Vermieter die Klimapolitik und die
Anforderungen betreffen alle Gruppen in
der Gesellschaft und deswegen müssen
auch alle Gruppen meinen Beitrag leisten
wir können nicht einzelne Gruppen
gegeneinander ausspielen Härtefälle
müssen natürlich entsprechend geschützt
werden aber wir können nicht die Debatte
führen guter guter Mieter böser
Vermieter gleiche Regel für alle
und das gilt auch für öffentliche
Gebäude es darf keine Privilegierung
durch Staates oder von Krankenhäusern
oder sozialen Einrichtungen geben
gegenüber den Menschen und wir müssen
das GEG zusammen denken mit der
kommunalen wärmeplanung auch das haben
wir schon gehört und wenn man diese
Punkte zusammenzieht denn wird sehr
deutlich dass wir andere Vorstellungen
haben wie wir zum Thema oder wie wir zum
Ziel der Klimaneutralität kommen uns
eint das Ziel aber mit den Weg streiten
wir und dies werden wir jetzt in aller
Ruhe mit der notwendigen Zeit die wir
brauchen zusammenführen und am Ende
werden wir dann ein gutes Gesetz haben
meine Damen und Herren
ich hatte gehofft dass der jung
zumindest was Substanzielles sagt nach
Herrn Spahn aber am Ende war es genau so
wie die letzten 16 Jahre unionsgeführte
Bundesregierung wieder kein Inhalt
wieder nichts auf das man sich einer
Debatte einlassen kann und deswegen ist
es so ein bisschen so wie bei all den
anderen Themen die sie ja auch
aufgeführt haben mehr sparen und
teilweise auch der jung sie schlagen
sich in die Büsche sie wollen die
Verantwortung für die Fehler in der
Gesellschaft hier in Deutschland in den
letzten Jahren die sie in der
Bundesregierung maßgeblich mitgestaltet
haben nicht übernehmen dass sie
legitimes Recht als Opposition aber ist
das legitime Recht von uns dass wir
darauf nicht eingehen wir werden ein
gutes Gesetz machen und dieses Gesetz
wird am Ende die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
dieses Landes weiterbringen ich freue
mich auf die parlamentarische Beratung
die sicherlich bald beginnen werden
herzlichen Dank
Christoph Meyer war das wir haben noch
zwei Redner in dieser aktuellen Stunde
jetzt spricht Michael Kiesling für die
CDU CSU er sitzt unter anderem und
Ausschuss für Wohnen statt Entwicklung
bauen und Kommunen sehr geehrte frau
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren sehr geehrter Hartmann sehr
geehrter Frau Huberts die einzigen die
für Verunsicherung beitragen sind sie
mit ihrem rumgeeire mit diesem Gesetz
meine Damen und Herren
sie sprechen heute dass dieses Gesetz
beraten werden soll im Parlament warum
bringen sie es nicht ein warum wurde es
diese Woche nicht aufgesetzt
ist es so gut ist es so schlecht haben
sie mit dem oppositionspartner in der
Koalition gesprochen mit der FDP warum
kommen Sie nicht zum Punkt meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
sie verunsichert die Eigentümer Sie von
unseren Gewitter sie fühlen sich auch
die Wirtschaft die Bauwirtschaft sie
haben Gesetz wo sie fordern wo sie
Anforderungen stellen wo Strafen
festgelegt sind sie haben aber keine
Antwort darauf wie das Ganze finanziert
werden soll das Ganze gefördert werden
soll und da reden sie von sozialer ja
ausgeglichen soziale berücksichtigen das
kommt in diesem Gesetz viel zu kurz
dieses Lippenbekenntnis
von Herrn Finanzminister dem Gesetz erst
zuzustimmen Kabinett zu sagen ist
Parlaments richten ja dann bringen sie
doch Parlament dass man es richten kann
warum kommt es nicht wenn man die Kritik
hört Frau Robert sie haben gesagt wir
haben keine Vorschläge gebracht haben
Sie unsere Vorschläge nicht gegeben
haben es einen Antrag nicht gelesen
haben sie das habeck-syndrom gehen Sie
nicht auf die Kritik ein hören Sie keine
Kritik hören Sie keine Vorschläge meine
Damen und Herren das ist doch der Punkt
wir sind bei den Menschen wir wissen was
fortgesprochen werden sie wollen
Gasheizungen verbieten Habeck baut
Gaskraftwerke
meine sehr geehrten sie verbieten
Holzheizungen waren sie schon mal im
ländlichen Raum wo jeder seinen Wald hat
wo jeder das Holz nutzen will das
Abfallholz nutzen will warum soll das
nicht thermisch verwertet werden sie
doch nachwachsende Rohstoffe da sage ich
liebe Ampel sie springen viel zu kurz
die Kritik klickt doch daran die FDP
sagt sie auch
technologieoffenheit wo ist denn die
Technologie sie reden von Wärmepumpen
sie reden nicht von nachwachsenden
Rohstoffwert gesagt Holz fließen sie aus
denken wir an die Wärmepumpe wenn sie an
Wärmepumpe denken müssen sie auch
erneuerbare Energien denken
wenn es ja wenn sie Wärmepumpen haben
müssten sie eigentlich die
photovoltaikpflicht auf den Deckel auch
herbeiführen weil ohne Wärmepumpe ohne
Photovoltaik sie brauchen Strom 50% der
Stroms ist fossilen momentan
das heißt auch die Wärmepumpe wird in
Zukunft teurer wenn da fossile Anteil
entsprechend das sagen sie den Menschen
nicht sie setzt auf firmenpumpen sie
setzen nicht auf technologieoffenheit
besseren sie das Gesetz nach und bringen
sie es endlich auch mal ein
zweitens unser Ansatz ist fördern und
fördern das haben wir in der letzten
Regierung mit der SPD auf den Weg
gebracht was machen sie
sie sagen sie fördern aber fördern nicht
sie verordnen sie verbieten im Gesetz
finde ich trafen fest wie es unterstützt
werden sollen das umgesetzt werden soll
berücksichtigen gar nicht sie müssen
auch gemeinsam denken sie müssen sie
wärmeerzeugen und Denken im Gebäude und
die Wärmedämmung auch das kommt zu kurz
wer soll sich denn das leisten unter
denen Sie dass wir die Menschen unsicher
die Menschen können rechnen draußen wenn
sie sagen wo die Heizung tauschen und
ich muss mein Gebäude noch dämmen dass
die neue Heizung funktioniert dann kann
das jeder draußen nachvollziehen was das
letztendlich kostet die Ampel macht die
Menschen haben meine Damen und Herren
und drittens Planbarkeit machen sie
realistische Fristen machen sie
Anforderungen die auch erfüllbar sind
wenn ich lese KFW 55 Standard für den
Bestand haben Sie schon mal den
baukulturbereich gelesen da steht drin K
für 85 wer soll sich denn das leisten
sollen wir den Altbestand abreißen neu
bauen wo sind wir dann beim CO2 meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ja Herr
Hartmann sie müssen doch wissen die
meisten die meisten Gebäude sind im
Bestand die saniert werden müssen und
sie wissen auch dass die Heizungen dort
getauscht werden müssen Sie wissen auch
dass wir hohen Sanierungsbedarf haben
bei 16 Millionen Einfamilien heißen 9
Familien 9 Millionen Häuser sind vor der
ersten Energieverordnung gebaut worden
da wissen wir dass es nicht einfach ist
eine Wärmepumpe einzubauen das kostet
Geld meine sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
letztendlich sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
dieses Gesetz ist Murks machen sie es
neu bringen sie erst neues Gesetz dann
können wir darüber reden herzlichen Dank
Michael Kiesling fordert hier ein
komplett in neues Gesetz aus dem Hause
von Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck nun werden wir aber erst einmal
zur letzten Rednerin in dieser aktuellen
Stunde kommen das ist Nina Scheer die
Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und Energie
der SPD-Fraktion
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich wäre aus den Reihen der CSU etwas
vorsichtig von 50% Anteil fossiler
Energie im Stromsektor zu sprechen weil
wir müssen uns natürlich dann schnell
fragen warum sind wir bei noch 50%
gegenüber den 50% Erneuerbaren diese 50%
fossile Anteile liegen insbesondere an
der Verhinderungspolitik die mit
Schwerpunkt in Bayern zu verordnen ist
Schwerpunkt in Bayern
Abstandsregelung und dergleichen sie
wissen dass das der das Element der
Verhinderungspolitik der letzten Jahre
ist und leider haben sie das natürlich
auch weiterhin nicht aufgelöst auch wenn
Sie das manchmal glauben machen wollen
wir haben mit unserem Programm zur
wärmeplanung wir haben es ja heute
gehört es ist
greifbar dass wir es auch dann
parlamentarisch beraten und es wird auch
die parlamentarische Barsche natürlich
dann zügig durchzuführen sein das ist
uns allen klar weil wir schnell
Rechtssicherheit Klarheit brauchen die
Menschen sind maximal verunsichert durch
solche Aktionen wie die ihre heute
wieder und deswegen müssen wir natürlich
und das uns allen dran gelegt schnell
ein Gesetz bekommen was klar aufzeigt
wie der Pfad der Werbeplanung sein wird
der wärmewende sein wird und natürlich
dabei die Verzahnung der kommunalen
wärmeplanung mit dem Blick behalten
deswegen ist es uns auch wichtig aus der
SPD-Fraktion dass das Miteinander
gedacht wird dass der Mieterschutz
enthalten ist es wurde schon einfach
meiner Frau Kollegin Verena Hubert dass
wir natürlich darauf achten werden dass
in der Systematik das Gesetzes die
Steigerungen die Kostensteigerungen
abgefangen werden dass sie nicht bei dem
Mieterinnen und Mieter landen und das
ist natürlich eine ein Element geben
wird dass die Förderungen die wir
implementieren dass die auch genutzt
werden weil das ist leider heute auch
schon so dass viele Förderungen
ungenutzt sind wir müssen auch da den
gotischen Knoten durchschlagen dass die
Förderungen die wir auf den Weg bringen
dass die wirklich auch genutzt werden
wir brauchen ein ermöglichungsgesetz
darum muss es gehen
und in dieser Konsequenz muss es
natürlich auch um eine bessere soziale
Staffelung gehen wird es gibt viele
Menschen in unserem Land die in der
Situation sind dass sie nicht gefördert
werden müssen in den Maßnahmen und es
gibt aber sehr viele die dringend
Forderungen brauchen wenn wir die
wärmewende umsetzen wollen deswegen ist
diese Staffelung wichtig und in der Tat
ist es auch wichtig das ist auch schon
erwähnt worden dass wir schauen diese
ganze Ermöglichung muss ja auch eine
wirtschaftliche an technologische
Komponente haben die Menschen die daran
arbeiten die brauchen auch
Rechtssicherheit wir brauchen die
Firmenansiedlung wir brauchen die
Fachkräfte das alles braucht das Signal
des Gesetzgebers deswegen ist es uns
wichtig dass das schnell kommt und dass
wir schnell mit technologieoffenheit mit
allen erneuerbaren Energien die wir
brauchen diese Regelungen bekommen aber
ich möchte jetzt noch mal zurückkommen
auf das was hier an Anschuldigungen auch
im Raum stand weil ich bin auch der
Meinung dass es nicht besonders
verantwortlich ist wenn in diesen Zeiten
in denen es wirklich spitzauf Knopf
darum steht ob wir noch die
Klimaschutzziele erreichen können und
der Wärmebereich ein ganz großer Bereich
da ist wenn hier ständig der Eindruck
erweckt wird dass das alles nicht
funktioniert das hier verhindert würde
dabei liegt es mit an ihnen maßgeblich
an Ihnen dass wir noch nicht weiter sind
weil über viele Jahre immer wieder
blockiert wurde
und es ist ja so dass das was von ihrem
aus ihren Reihen an Vorschlägen kommt
letztendlich substanziell nur auf eine
Maßnahme wirklich verlässliche Maßnahmen
erkennbare Maßnahme konzentriert werden
kann das ist nämlich dass sie wirklich
das über den CO2-Preis regeln wollen das
ist wird immer wieder deutlich sie sagen
zwar auch erneuerbare Jahr aber richtig
konkret wird es da einmal beim CO2-Preis
da kämpfen sie wirklich für und da
möchte ich sie noch mal fragen in das in
Kombination mit dem Klimaschutzgesetz
was sie ja auch jetzt inzwischen stolz
demonstrieren ja gemeinsam verabschieden
das in Kombination wie diese Ziele die
dort verankert sind wenn sie das über
den CO2-Preis allein erreichen wollen
dann ist das verbunden mit der
Verunmöglichung von heizen in
Deutschland eine Verunmöglichung das
heißt sie machen ein Programm des
frierens in Deutschland das muss man
noch mal ganz deutlich sagen ein
Programm des Tieren aber nicht sie dann
noch mal daran erinnern darf das selbst
im in der größten Krise die wir hatten
seit langem Jahren in dem letzten Jahr
wo wir 300 Milliarden Euro in
Deutschland verabschiedet haben hier zur
Verfügung stelle um diese Überforderung
der Menschen abzuwenden das war eine
einmalige Aktion da waren wir alle
beisammen auch trotz
Meinungsverschiedenheiten die es hier
und da auch in der Ampel gibt das gehört
zur Koalition dazu aber da machen wir
ganz geschlossen diese 300 Milliarden
brauchen wir wer stimmt dagegen sie
haben dagegen bestimmt das gibt dir
einen Vorgeschmack das gibt ein
Vorgeschmack darauf wie sie die soziale
Abfederung dann ausgestalten würden beim
CO2-Preis ich denke er wird sehr gering
ausfallen ich bleibe dabei ein Programm
verfolgt nicht mit uns
das war hier die aktuelle Stunde wir
werden natürlich verfolgen wie sich die
Koalitionsparteien weiter darüber
austauschen wie es mit dem
heizungsgesetz voran gehen soll der Plan
ist ja von 2024 an das möglichst jede
neu eingeweiberte Heizung zu 65% mit
öko-Energie betrieben wird daran gibt es
viel Kritik in nicht nur aus der eigenen
Koalition sozusagen das haben wir hier
deutlich mitbekommen also wir werden
weiter schauen ob es denn noch zu einem
Gesetz vor der Sommerpause kommt wie von
SPD und Grüne gewünscht jetzt kommen wir
aber zu einem ganz anderen
Thema der Berufsbildungsbericht 2023 ist
jetzt hier auf der Tagesordnung und die
Zahlen dieses Berichts sind doch sehr
alarmierend denn die Zahl der jungen
ungelernten unter 35 ist mittlerweile
bei 2,64 Millionen wie man dagegen
ansteuern kann wird nun als erstes Jens
Brandenburg von der FDP sagen
Parlamentarischer Staatssekretär im
Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung
Wärmepumpen und viele andere Geräte
diskutiert
soweit gehört aber auch diese wärmewende
die wird uns natürlich nur gelingen wenn
es mehr qualifizierte Fachkräfte gibt
die all diese Geräte im installieren und
da wir heute auch Schülerinnen und
Schüler hier im Raum haben sich ja auch
zugeschaltet
an all diejenigen die vielleicht noch
überlegen wie denn ihr Beitrag konkret
aussehen könnte zum Gelingen dieser
wärmewende und wenn sie auch der
Überzeugung kommen wie ich dass die
Lösung nicht alleine in Klebstoff und
Asphalt liegt dann möchte ich Sie
herzlich einladen sich beispielsweise
mal den Ausbildungsberuf zur
anlagenmechanikerin für Sanitär
Heizungs- und Klimatechnik anzuschauen
ein langer Name aber eine tolle Sache
ein sehr anspruchsvoller
abwechslungsreicher Beruf und das sind
die wahren klimahelden unseres Landes
und der Berufsbildungsbericht den wir
als Bundesregierung vorstellen wie jedes
Jahr der zeigt ein Bild positive
Nachricht erst mal dass der starke
Abwärtstrend in den Ausbildungsverträgen
der letzten Jahre glücklicherweise
gestoppt ist zur negativen Nachricht
gehört aber auch dazu die wahre
Trendwende ist mit diesem leichten
Anstieg an sich noch nicht gelungen ganz
im Gegenteil wir erleben zwar eine
deutliche Zunahme noch mal der
angebotenen Ausbildungsplätze insgesamt
insbesondere im Handwerk aber Leiter
leider weiter eine einen Rückgang der
ausbildungsnachfrage und auch regional
übrigens sehr sehr starke Unterschiede
das sieht hier in Berlin-Mitte durchaus
noch mal anders aus als auf der
Schwäbischen Alb und gleichzeitig
stellen wir fest dass es über 2,6
Millionen junge Erwachsene gibt die eben
ganz ohne Bildungsabschluss ohne
ausbildungsberuflichen
Ausbildungsabschluss und auch ohne
akademischen Abschluss ins Berufsleben
starten da gehört soweit dazu da sind
natürlich viele geflüchtete
beispielsweise der Ukraine bei uns das
nützt aber nichts macht es nicht besser
denn am Ende ist jeder nicht
stattgefundene Ausbildung eine verpasste
Chance für die persönliche
Weiterentwicklung aber auch für die
Stabilität Wachstum und Wohlstand
unserer Volkswirtschaft insgesamt und
deshalb wollen wir das ändern das tun
wir als Bundesregierung beispielsweise
seitens des Bundesministeriums für
Bildung und Forschung mit der
Exzellenzinitiative berufliche Bildung
die wir im Dezember letzten Jahres
gestartet haben und das sind etliche
Maßnahmen schon umgesetzt wir wollen die
berufliche Bildung individuell stärken
mit einer stärkeren Berufsorientierung
die inzwischen erstmals das
Berufsorientierungsprogramm unseres
Hauses auch für Schüler und Schülerinnen
ein Gymnasien geöffnet ist wir arbeiten
derzeit an einer Vorbereitung einer
Reform einer Verbesserung des Aufstiegs
erste Verbesserung haben wir im letzten
Jahr mit der bafögnovelle ja bereits
umgesetzt auch das Thema
Begabtenförderung in der beruflichen
Bildung die Anzahl der Stipendien wurden
Anfang dieses Jahres deutlich erhöht
auch die Innovationen stärken wir
innovet plus als Innovationswettbewerb
für berufliche Bildung die
Förderrichtlinie ist seit wenigen Wochen
veröffentlicht wir stärken auch das
ausbilderpersonal das prüfungspersonal
und wollen auch das Berufsbildungsgesetz
in die digitale Welt bringen wir machen
die berufliche Bildung internationaler
auch das wichtig sowohl für Fachkräfte
die zu uns kommen als auch diejenigen
die hier eine Ausbildung machen und
gerne ins Ausland schauen wollen die
berufliche Bildung gehört zu Exzellenz
dazu denn die Exzellenz die gibt es
nicht nur an den Hochschulen sondern
auch in der beruflichen Bildung und
deshalb bin ich froh dass wir das
gemeinsam als Koalition auf den Weg
bringen
und als Koalition arbeiten wir übrigens
auch zwischen den Ressorts an der
beruflichen Bildung eng zusammen nur als
Beispiele gemeinsam mit dem BMS bei
Fragen der Einstiegsqualifizierung eine
auch sehr betriebsnah ausgestalteten
Ausbildungsgarantie und der Frage wie
bringen wir insgesamt mehr junge
Menschen zum Beispiel mit starker
mobilitätsunterstützung erfolgreich in
die Ausbildung mit dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium zu fragen
Initiative klischeefrei in der
Berufsorientierung unabhängig von
Geschlechterrollen aber ganz aktuell
jetzt gerade ist auch die
Bundesbildungsministerin Bettina stark
Watzinger zu Unterzeichnung mit dabei
eine neue Phase der Allianz der
Spitzenorganisation zur für die aus- und
Weiterbildung wichtig dass wir damit
arbeitgeber und Gewerkschaften
zusammenarbeiten und auch das
Bundesbauministerium möchte ich erwähnen
mit dem Programm junges Wohnen 500
Millionen Euro die wir als
Bundesregierung alleine in diesem Jahr
auch für azubiwohnheime zur Verfügung
stellen das ist wichtig wir stehen als
Team zusammen und arbeiten für die
berufliche Bildung
im letzten Gedanken die ich noch
loswerden möchte wir fangen auch nicht
erst bei der Ausbildung an sondern um
mehr künftige Menschen Schüler und
Schülerinnen erfolgreich in die
Ausbildung zu bringen müssen wir früher
anfangen insbesondere mit dem
startchancen-programm gerade an den
Schulen die die größten Benachteiligung
haben die sozialen Benachteiligung die
absoluten vorzeige Schulen zu schaffen
wir sind gerade mit den Ländern im
intensiven Verhandlungen das Geld muss
natürlich dahin wo es am meisten
gebraucht wird auch darauf können Sie
sich freuen da liegt einiges vor uns und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die gute
Nachricht ich habe es eben erwähnt der
Abwärtstrend ist gestoppt die nicht so
gute Nachricht wir haben noch viele
Herausforderungen vor uns also lassen
Sie uns gemeinsam an der Stärkung der
beruflichen Bildung Arbeiten mehr junge
Menschen in die aus- und Weiterbildung
bringen denn gute Bildung das ist die
Zukunft sowohl für jeden Einzelnen als
auch für unser Land insgesamt vielen
Dank
Brandenburg sieht hier gut und nicht so
gute Nachrichten das Bundesinstitut für
Berufsbildung gewarnt allerdings vor
einem massiven Fachkräfte Problem
zweiter Redner und Stefan Albanien für
die CDU CSU Fraktion
der Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Berufsbildungsbericht 2023 ein wichtiges
Thema ohne Frage aber bevor ich dazu
komme muss ich dann doch lieber
Staatssekretär Brandenburg über Jens
meinem Verwunderung meiner Verwundung
etwas Ausdruck geben dass die Ministerin
die für heute angesagt war die sind
Termin hier heute kurzfristig abgesagt
hat ich finde dies ehrlich gesagt ein
Unding
seit Wochen seit Wochen lesen wir von
den zentralen Projekten dieser
Legislatur sei es da die Sprint
wissenschaftszeitvertragsgesetz aus der
Presse im Ausschuss diskutieren wir
darüber nicht ein weiteres undicht
und einige dieser Vorschläge werden dann
wenn sie offiziell verkündet werden auch
bin einen Tag über
wissenschaftszeitvertrag wieder kassiert
das heißt wir kommen nicht voran und
heute dann Absage noch nicht mal aus dem
BMWF sondern vom plenaldienste FDP
bekommen wir die Mitteilung die
Ministerin würde heute nicht hierher
kommen obwohl sie angekündigt war ihre
Debatte ist das hier und es wäre noch
mehr als sinnvoll gewesen hierher zu
kommen ihre Begründung ist noch schöner
eine 39 Minuten Debatte sie ist bei
Allianz für aus und Weiterbildung ich
bin mir relativ sicher ich kenne diese
Kollegen dass man es hätte so schieben
können dass sie hier wenigstens für 20
Minuten hätte erscheinen können ich
finde das unmöglich
und all dieses zusammen könnte ich jetzt
auch gerne verpacken in einer Äußerung
Missachtung des Parlaments das überlasse
ich aber parlamentarischen fein
schmecken nicht
ärgert das Bild was auf dieser Art und
Weise in die Szene gesendet wird denn
das sowohl in die Richtung der
Wissenschaft oder aber auch heute in
Sachen Handwerk und IHK ist ein dieser
ströses und das muss man an der Stelle
auch einmal so benennen
[Applaus]
der Berufsbildungsbericht zeigt nämlich
das Handlungsnotwendigkeiten mehr als
notwendig vorhanden sind wir treten auf
der Stelle kann man das gleich bleiben
auch sagen auch nennen wir kommen nicht
voran die Anzahl der Berufsanfänger
bleibt gleich nachdem sie aber in den
letzten Jahren deutlich zurückgegangen
ist hier bedarf es zum Beispiel eine
gezielten
Berufsorientierung wie wir sie
vorgestellt haben mehr Geld allein
reicht dort nicht hier braucht man auch
neue Mittel und Methoden wie wir sie zum
Beispiel in Kette erarbeitet haben
ehrlich gesagt diesbezüglich fehlanzeige
ein Überangebot dazu komme ich gleich
noch zur Exzellenzinitiative Übergang
Überangebot von 70.000 offenen Stellen
70.000 offene Stellen 70.000 Chancen die
nicht ergriffen werden können dagegen
über 23.000 Bewerber die unversorgt sind
das ist richtig das ist aber ein
passungsproblem von drei zu eins und die
Ausbildungsgarantie ist mit Sicherheit
eine der dümmsten Lösung dafür das muss
man ebenfalls an dieser Stelle mal
deutlich machen
eine vertragslösungsquote seit Jahren
stagnieren bei nun 26,7% unverändert
hoch auch hier eine Aufwertung der
beruflichen Bildung zum Beispiel durch
verächtlichung des Dekor oder eine
Berufsorientierung durchzuführen wäre
ein sinnvolle Maßnahme das findet aber
leider nicht statt
so komme ich zum Schluss ja
Exzellenzinitiative
Exzellenzinitiative ist man als Projekt
gestartet sollte etwas sein was etwas
bringt endete am Ende als Dachmarke für
ein Sammelsurium von Details die
weiterentwickelt werden das ist mehr als
man letzten Endes an dieser Stelle ein
Enttäuschung erwarten konnte
die überbetriebliche Ausbildungsstätten
die über betrieblichen
Ausbildungsstätten in der im letzten
Haushalt ähnlich wie die
Berufsorientierung zunächst gekürzt
wurde dann nach dem parlamentarischen
Verfahren aufgewertet ich hoffe dass das
nicht noch mal auftritt bisher haben wir
noch nicht einmal Entwurf für diese
Tatsache für diese Thematik die Grünen
sprechen gegenüber der FDP von
arbeitsverweigungen
so letzter Punkt ist diese Art von
Arbeitsverweigerung habe ich gestern
sehr romantisch bei einer Anhörung
umschrieben bekommen die Ministerin sei
wahrscheinlich auf einem zetticket ich
hoffe sie beendet wir brauchen ihre
Arbeit herzlichen Dank
Stefan Albani war das hier zum
Berufsbildungsbericht der natürlich auch
für viele junge Menschen interessant ist
Jessica Rosenthal leitet ja die
Jugendorganisation der SPD ist
Juso-Vorsitzende und MdB
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
insbesondere lieber Herr Kollege Albani
ich glaube wir werden an ganz anderen
Zahlen schon angekommen wenn wir unsere
gemeinsame Energie nicht in rumgepolster
investieren würden sondern in die jungen
Menschen die glaube ich die
Aufmerksamkeit verdient haben
und ich möchte genau über diese jungen
Menschen jetzt auch sprechen denn ich
will überhaupt nicht drumherum reden die
Trends die wir im aktuellen
Berufsbildungsbericht sehen und die sich
auch fortgesetzt haben wenn man das mal
vergleicht mit dem letzten Jahr die sind
alarmierend und die besorgen mich ich
glaube die besorgen uns alle und sollten
uns allen alle auch besorgen die Zahl
der Anfängerinnen in der dualen
Ausbildung ist leicht gestiegen aber man
muss auch sagen dass die im schulischen
Bereich gesunken sind und ein Trend der
mich ganz besonders besorgt das ist die
Frage wie viele junge Menschen
eigentlich ohne Berufsausbildung sind
und 2,6 Millionen das sagt sich so
einfach 2,6 Millionen aber was ist das
für eine riesige Anzahl von jungen
Menschen die ohne Fundament ohne
Berufsausbildung in diesem Land sind und
deshalb
ist es so wichtig dass wir uns diesen
Trends entgegenstellen und das tun wir
als Ampel anders als das jetzt gerade
dargestellt wurde einerseits geht es um
demografische Effekte und da machen wir
jetzt ein sehr gutes Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz eines was wir schon
längst hätten haben sollen lieber Union
und wenn ich noch mal über die 2,6
Millionen Menschen spreche und ich sage
das noch mal es sind 2,6 Millionen
Zukunft eine Zukunft von diesen 2,6
Millionen Menschen die sie eben nicht in
gesicherten Arbeitsverhältnissen haben
sondern immer wieder ganz besonders auch
Arbeitslosigkeit ausgesetzt sind dafür
schaffen wir die Ausbildungsplatz
Garantie und das ist ein echter
Meilenstein denn hier bekommen junge
Menschen das Recht auf eine
Berufsausbildung und gerade auch
diejenigen die es schwer haben in
Ausbildung zu kommen aber natürlich ist
das nicht der einzige Trend den wir
sehen es geht auch darum dass wir viele
unbesetzte Ausbildungsstellen haben und
das regional mein Kollege hat eben
gerade schon gesagt sehr
unterschiedlich und auch hier haben wir
Maßnahmen auf den Weg gebracht die
dagegen wirken sollen denn darum geht es
geht ja um Lösungen für das Problem wir
wollen mit der Mobilitätsförderung die
wir jetzt auf den Weg bringen dafür
sorgen dass junge Menschen Unterstützung
haben wenn sie woanders ihre Ausbildung
starten dass sie dann nach Hause fahren
können wir wollen auch und das wurde
auch schon erwähnt ich unterstreiches
noch mal endlich mit dem Programm jungen
wohnen auch azubi-wohnheime schaffen und
ich möchte an alle appellieren dass wir
das auch wirklich vor Ort tun vor Ort
voranbringen wir brauchen azubiwohnheime
in unserem Land und wir wollen natürlich
dafür sorgen und darum geht es geht
darum dass junge Menschen sagen eine
Ausbildung ist für mich die beste Option
das wollen wir schaffen und dafür müssen
wir natürlich auf die Berufsorientierung
Stärken ja auch an Gymnasien aber eben
nicht nur auch das tun wir ich bin mir
aber auch sicher und da geht es dann
wieder um die Frage wie breit ist
eigentlich das Commitment dass wir die
den die Schulterbreite noch viel stärker
machen müssen damit dass wir gleiche
Standards in der Berufsorientierung
machen es muss egal sein an welcher
Schule ein Kind ist es muss deutlich
werden dass Sie immer das die gleiche
Berufsorientierung die gleiche Qualität
von Berufsorientierung erfahren davon
sind wir viel zu weit entfernt es geht
auch um die Steigerung Attraktivität es
geht um gute Bezahlung in der Ausbildung
und das ist ein klarer Appell nicht nur
an die Politik sondern auch an die
Unternehmen wir müssen gute Löhne zahlen
auch für Menschen die in Ausbildung sind
wir brauchen eine gute Qualität auch in
der Schule und deshalb bleiben wir als
SPD dabei dass wir in den Park für
berufsbildende Schulen unbedingt
brauchen denn wir müssen die
Berufsorientierung an den Schulen
stärken aber eben auch die an den
berufsbildenden Schulen und ich sage
auch deutlich wir brauchen
die Möglichkeit dass junge Menschen
bezahlbar zu Ihrer Arbeitsstätte kommen
und deshalb bin ich der festen
Überzeugung dass wir auch für Azubis
einen 29 Euro Ticket brauchen das ist
dringend notwendig und trotzdem dürfen
den ländlichen Raum nicht vergessen es
ist nur nötig dass auch ein 16-Jähriger
im ländlichen Raum dahin kommt wo er
hinkommen muss und dafür glaube ich
brauchen wir noch viel weitere Lösungen
ich denke wir können uns gemeinsam
diesen alarmierenden Trends
entgegenstellen da ist noch viel zu tun
wir haben viel auf den Weg gebracht und
ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn wir auf
dieser Ebene konstruktiv für junge
Menschen in diesem Land arbeiten würden
danke schön
Jessica Rosenthal war das für die
SPD-Fraktion natürlich ist hier die
Frage wie man den Fachkräftemangel
verhindern kann nächste Rednerin Nicole
höchst auf die Fraktion meine Damen und
Herren wir haben schon die üblichen
Phrasen zu jährlichen Bildungsbericht
beruflichen Bildungsbericht gehört wir
teilen ihren Enthusiasmus für die
berufliche Bildung dazu haben wir
Initiativen vorgelegt deutschland
braucht Meister meine Damen und Herren
adressieren wir aber nun den Elefanten
im Raum das kann und will ich ihnen
nicht ersparen die absolute Zahl
Erwachsener zwischen 20 und 34 Jahren
ohne formalen Berufsabschluss steigt
seit dem grenzöffnungsjahr 2015
kontinuierlich an nach Angaben des Bib
anhand der Daten des Mikrozensus lag die
Quote der 20 bis 34-Jährigen ohne
formalen Berufsabschluss also die
ungelernten Quote im Jahr 2021 bei 17,8
Prozent 2020 lag sie bei
15,5%. die ungelernten Quote für
deutsche Staatsbürger ohne
Migrationshintergrund betrug im Jahr
2021 10,6 Prozent die Quote bei
Migranten mit eigener
Migrationserfahrung lag bei
38,1 Prozent bei solchen die in
Deutschland geboren und aufgewachsen
sind betrug sie immerhin noch 19,9
Prozent das sind bedeutsame Unterschiede
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
deutlicher Auffälligkeiten zeichnen sich
auch hier ab je niedriger der allgemeine
Schulabschluss der Auszubildenden desto
höher die vertragslösungsquote
Unterschiede gab es auch hier
hinsichtlich der Staatsangehörigkeiten
von Abbrechern von ausländischen
Auszubildenden wurden im Durchschnitt
35,3% der Verträge vorzeitig gelöst von
deutschen Staatsangehörigen
25,5% wobei hier der
Migrationshintergrund vielleicht
vorsichtshalber gar nicht erst
ausgewiesen ist das wiederum ist gar
nicht wirklich überraschend ein Zitat
des Direktors des Münchner Instituts für
bildungsökonomie prof Rüdiger wössmann
von 2015 in der Zeit erhält den
Zusammenhang wie folgt ich zitiere mit
Erlaubnis des Präsidiums in Syrien
schaffen 65 Prozent der Schüler nicht
den Sprung über das was die OECD als
Grundkompetenzen definiert das heißt
dass zwei Drittel der Schüler in Syrien
nur sehr eingeschränkt lesen und
schreiben können dass sie nur einfachste
Rechenaufgaben lösen können und das
bedeutet dass diese Schüler in
Deutschland setzt wenn sie Deutsch
gelernt haben kaum dem
Unterrichtsgeschehen Folgen können und
spätere Arbeitslosigkeit die Folge sein
wird
ivola zwei Drittel der
bürgergeldbezieher in Deutschland haben
heute ein Migrationshintergrund Liebe
Bürger die
realitätsverweigerungsfraktionen hier in
diesem Hohen Hause wollen das so
wie Pisa und andere Studien zeigen
betrifft dies allerdings nicht nur Syrer
Werte Kollegen nehmen sie endlich zur
Kenntnis dass sich die zuwandernden
Rohdiamanten allzu oft mit dem
Förderbereich lernen selbst nach dem
Genuss des deutschen Bildungssystems als
etwas völlig anderes erweisen als sie
hier anpreisen nämlich als Mühlsteine um
den Hals unserer ehemaligen
Leistungsgesellschaft und Hochkultur
diese Menschen
wären
wir können einen Großteil nicht bilden
oder ausbilden die Digitalisierung
eliminiert zusätzlich viele
unkomplizierte arbeiten in
mietrichlohnsektor und was sollen diese
Menschen denn dann hier arbeiten selbst
wenn sie das wollen bitte erklären Sie
das dem deutschen Steuerzahler und worin
liegt denn die Motivation für junge
Leute im Sinne der
Generationengerechtigkeit eine
Ausbildung überhaupt das zu Beginn
geschweige denn abzuschließen und
lebenslänglich zu arbeiten
Zukunftsängste Weltuntergangsstimmung
Welt höchste Steuern und Abgaben zahlen
drohende Enteignung von
familienimmobilien wohlstandsvernichtung
arbeiten bis 67 all dies sind keine
Anreize für junge Menschen für sich
selbst unsere Gesellschaft und für den
Rest der Welt Leistung zu erbringen
meine Damen und Herren
das christliche Pfingstfest steht bevor
der Geist Gottes mögen sie erreichen und
ihnen Erkenntnis bringen vielen Dank
das Wort dr Anja reinhalte für Bündnis
90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer ja wir
reden heute über den
Berufsbildungsbericht 2023 und ja ich
könnte jetzt versuchen diesen Bericht
schön zu reden aber ganz ehrlich es gibt
wirklich wenig Grund zur Freude denn im
Berufsbildungsbericht 2023 werden ernste
Probleme beschrieben die wir gar nicht
von heute auf morgen lösen können und
wissen Sie was darum spreche ich jetzt
über den Berufsbildungsbericht 2030
neugierig sie möchten wissen was wir
2030 alles erreicht haben
nun 2023 das haben wir jetzt gehört
hatten wir noch 70.000 umgesetzte
Ausbildungsstellen fast 23.000 junge
Leute die kein Ausbildungsplatz gefunden
haben und fast jede vierte Person hat es
Ausbildungsverhältnis wieder aufgelöst
und 2030
haben wir es endlich geschafft das
passende matching zwischen Angebot und
Nachfrage hinzubekommen und wie haben
wir das geschafft
mit Hilfe von KI würde das Matching
deutlich verbessert das war schon mal
ganz hilfreich aber noch lang nicht
alles viel viel wichtiger war unsere
berufsorientierungsoffensive wir haben
die Eltern viel stärker eingebunden denn
Berufsorientierung
funktioniert nicht ohne Eltern
wir haben schon in der Kita mit
Berufsorientierung angefangen denn die
Leidenschaft und das Interesse für ein
Beruf beginnt genau dann im frühen
Kindesalter wenn Kinder sagen ich will
Feuerwehrmann werden ich will Polizistin
werden
und wir haben viel mehr Praxis in die
Schule gebracht in einwöchiges Praktikum
in der Mittelstufe reicht einfach nicht
aus um eine reale Vorstellung von einem
Beruf zu bekommen
ja und 20 23 war auch immer noch die
Frage nach der Gleichwertigkeit von der
akademischen und beruflichen Bildung in
aller Munde
und 20 30 ist die Gleichwertigkeit
endlich in den Köpfen angekommen wir
haben das geschafft wir haben denn die
rechtlicht und dafür gesorgt dass
endlich eine echte Vergleichbarkeit von
Ausbildung und Studium gegeben ist
ja und sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
2023 hatten wir wirklich Sorge wir
hatten wirklich Sorge denn 2,6 Millionen
junge Menschen hatten kein
Berufsabschluss und ich freue mich sehr
dass wir 2030 diese Zahl signifikant
reduzieren konnten und wie haben wir das
geschafft wir haben mit der
Ausbildungsgarantie mit einem
zeitgemäßen aufstiegs-bafög mit dem
Ausbau von jugendberufsagenturen und
einem systematischen Übergangsmanagement
und wissen Sie was das haben wir alle
das haben wir alle wirklich nur
gemeinsam geschafft und wir werden es
auch in Zukunft nur alle gemeinsam
schaffen deswegen packen wir es an
vielen Dank
Anja rein Alter war das mit hier doch
ein positiven Bericht angesichts dieser
Problematik die hier doch schon häufiger
debattiert wurde nicoleken und für die
Linksfraktion ich finde den
Berufsbildungsbericht zu diskutieren
gehört oft eher zu den unangenehmen
Debatten im Bundestag einfach weil sich
hier so gar nichts tut und jedes Mal
aufs Neue wieder größtenteils
deprimierende Zahlen vorgetragen werden
und ich denke mir dann immer wie muss
ich das eigentlich erst für die jungen
Menschen anfühlen die es wirklich
betrifft die am Beginn eines
Ausbildungsjahres mit leeren Händen ohne
Ausbildungsplatz da stehen das betrifft
gerade mehr als
22.500 junge Menschen oder wie muss es
sich für die anfühlen die jahrelangen
irgendwelchen übergangssystemen
feststecken anstelle einer echten
Ausbildung das betrifft
239.000 junge Menschen oder für die die
schon lange ohne jede Berufsausbildung
und berufliche Perspektive sind das sind
wie wir schon gehört haben über 2,6
Millionen junge Menschen zwischen 20 und
35 Jahren 2,6 million en Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich finde diesen Zustand
absolut beschämt und es ist nicht
hinnehmbar dass die Politik ja für ja
keine Antworten auf diese Zukunftsfragen
findet
und ich finde es dann auch irgendwie
bezahlbar wenn in diesem
Berufsbildungsbericht auf 25 Seiten mehr
als 120 Maßnahmen der Bundesregierung
aufgeführt sind ohne dass daraus
irgendwelche Schlüsse gezogen werden ich
meine viele dieser Programme laufen seit
Jahren aber die meisten laufen ja ohne
die Situation spürbar zu verbessern denn
die Zahlen werden ja für ja schlechter
ich finde die ampelregierung muss die
Programme endlich mal auf ihre
Wirksamkeit hin überprüfen anstatt sie
einfach nur aufzulisten und sich an der
Zahl zu berauschen das wäre jetzt mal
die angemessene Reaktion
versteh
e erst nicht warum nicht auch die
Bundesregierung endlich mal auf die Idee
kommt das Instrument der assistierten
Ausbildung zum Beispiel flächendeckend
auszubauen da steht den auszubil
den so zur Seite für Fragen der
bürokratischen Abwicklung aber auch wenn
Probleme in der Ausbildung oder in der
Schule auftreten das hat sich doch
bewährt warum gibt es das nicht
flächendeckend sondern nach wie vor nur
stückweise
und ich sage Ihnen
wirklich wirksam wäre vor allem auch
eine Maßnahme der sich die
Bundesregierung bisher leider
systematisch verweigert nämlich dafür zu
sorgen dass endlich mehr betriebliche
betriebliche Ausbildungsplätze entstehen
und auch wenn das jetzt die
Konservativen und auch die FDP nicht so
gerne hören wollen ich sage Ihnen ich
glaube da kommt man um eine solidarische
Umlagefinanzierung nicht drumherum man
kann sich vor dieser Frage nicht weiter
drücken die Unternehmen und Betriebe die
ausbilden die gehören entlastet aber
diejenigen die es nicht tun und sich
weigern die gehören zur Kasse gebeten
das muss endlich mal passieren denn der
Markt der Regel ist eben nicht von
alleine es braucht jemand einen Funken
an solidarischen denken das ist doch
wirklich offensichtlich
kurz und gut drehen sie endlich mal die
großen Räder bevor sie in einem Mehr an
wirkungslosen Einzelmaßnahmen versinken
vielen Dank
nächster Redner ist Oliver für die
SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ja tatsächlich es geht darum berufliche
Bildung nicht wie so oft in manchen
Debatten hier nur zu beschwören sondern
die ja sich anbahnenden Strukturprobleme
gerade wenn man dann lange im Blick auf
dem Berufsbildungsbericht guckt in den
Griff zu bekommen denn Herr Albani ist
schon mutig sich nach den Jahren hier in
die mitzustellen und so eine Rede zu
halten denn viele Probleme sind einfach
auch lange ausgesetzt worden und diese
Strukturprobleme müssen wir in den Griff
bekommen denn es sind teilweise
bedenkliche Befunde wir haben viel zu
viele unbesetzte Ausbildungsplätze wir
haben eine singende Nachfrage nach
Ausbildungsplätzen kombiniert damit dass
wir eine diese weiterhin sinkende Zahl
von Schulabgängerinnen und
Schulabgängern haben mindestens noch bis
2026 und wir stellen fest dass der
Ausbildungsmarkt seit Corona sich nicht
erholt hat wir haben heute etwa 34.000
Ausbildungsplätze weniger als vor Beginn
der corona-pandemie und der erinnern uns
nach der Finanzmarktkrise war es ganz
ähnlich da ist das Niveau abgesagt und
das hat sich nie wieder erholt der
Ausbild wird es nie wieder auf das alte
Niveau zurückgekommen und das sind
Strukturprobleme und das führt mich dazu
dass wir insbesondere drei Strategien
glaube ich verfolgen müssen die wir ganz
konkret auch hinterlegen und dir der
Staatssekretär das gerade ausgeführt die
wir auch teilweise mit unseren Maßnahmen
der Ampelkoalition schon hinterlegt
haben wir müssen nämlich erstens dafür
sorgen dass der Ausbildungsmarkt
Präsident bleibt dass wir ein anhaltend
hohes Angebot an Ausbildungsplätzen
bekommen am liebsten natürlich
betriebliche Ausbildungsplätze dass wir
der Ausbildungsmarkt resilient gegen
Krisen machen deswegen Unternehmen
motivieren und dass wir auch dort wo es
notwendig ist in den Regionen außer
betrieblich Ausbildung und das ist ein
wesentlicher Fortschritt den die
Ausbildungsgarantie uns bringt dass wir
dort wo das Angebot nicht ausreichend
auch außer betrieblich ausbilden werden
zweite Strategie
wir müssen alle Potenziale für
Ausbildung heben und das ist ja richtig
wenn es ein Trend zu höherer
Schulbildung gibt dass wir auch die
Berufsorientierung an Gymnasien
verstärken für Abiturientinnen und
Abiturienten verstärken dafür sorgen
dass sich von denen auch mehr für eine
berufliche Ausbildung interessieren und
die Exzellenzinitiative ist ein
richtiger und wichtiger Baustein aber
wir dürfen eben auch nicht übersehen was
hier schon gesagt worden ist 2,6
Millionen junge Erwachsene ohne
Berufsabschluss
240.000 jugendliche die im letzten Jahr
nicht in die Ausbildung gestartet sind
sondern die Übergangssystem gelandet
sind die dort Zeit verbringen und wir
müssen endlich mit unseren reden darüber
auch zum Ausdruck bringen das sind
Potentiale das sind keine Probleme
sondern das sind Potenziale für den
Ausbildungsmarkt die wollen wir heben
und niemanden dabei aus dem Blick
verlieren
und zum dritten wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass Jugendliche und Auszubildende der
Jugendlichen und Ausbildungsplätze
besser zueinander finden das
matching-thema ist ja in vielen
berufsbildungsberichten tatsächlich
angesprochen worden ich glaube nur dass
das zahlenmäßige Ausmaß der unbesetzten
stellen und versorgten Bewerber auf der
anderen Seite mittlerweile dazu führt
dass wir eine richtig regelrechte
matching Offensive brauchen damit eben
mehr Jugendliche und Ausbildungsplätze
zueinander finden das heißt konkret
frühere Berufsorientierung Hubertus Heil
hat in dieser Woche vorgeschlagen ab der
fünften Klasse richtig so mehr Mobilität
Auszubildenden wohnen ausbauen das
Programm junges Wohnen von der
baumminister angesprochen worden richtig
so wir müssen die Eltern mitnehmen
müssen die Eltern mitnehmen ist richtig
denn am Küchentisch wird auch darüber
diskutiert was denn die beste
Zukunftsentscheidung von jungen Menschen
ist und deswegen brauchen wir sie auch
und müssen wir sie motivieren für
Ausbildung in Zukunft berufen und ja wir
müssen auch in den Regionen in denen das
Besondere Bedarfe gibt die Regionen und
die Sozialpartner ertüchtigen
Instrumente an die Seite zu stellen das
Matching in der Region zu verbessern und
Einstiegsqualifizierung ist ja
angesprochen worden assistierte
Ausbildung die noch viel besser
abgerufen werden muss weil nämlich das
zur Verfügung stehende Angebot gar nicht
angenommen wird das sind Instrumente aus
dem Werkzeugkasten der
Ausbildungsgarantie die dafür sorgen
dass wir vor Ort des Menschen verbessern
und deswegen ja Wertschätzung für
berufliche Bildung gerne müssen wir
immer zum Ausdruck bringen Wohlstand
Transformation Innovation alles nicht
ohne gut ausgebildete Fachkräfte aber es
geht ihm nicht nur um wahre Worte es
geht darum das Berufliche Bildung uns
auch als Wert sein muss damit
Jugendliche und ihre Eltern sich eben
überzeugt und zuversichtlich für eine
betriebliche Ausbildung entscheiden
können und damit Betriebe und
Auszubildende besser zueinander finden
vielen Dank
hiermit seinen Vorstellungen wie die
Ausbildung gestärkt werden kann und
es mehr Auszubildende wieder gibt die
auch ein Ausbildungsplatz finden Kathrin
Staffler nun für die cdu/csu heute
vermutlich gar keinen
Berufsbildungsbericht 2023 gebraucht
nämlich die Erkenntnis dass die duale
Ausbildung unter Druck geraten ist und
zwar nicht erst seit der
corona-pandemie sondern seit dem aber
noch sehr viel stärker wenn man jetzt
aber zu dieser Erkenntnis gelangt dann
muss man ja folgerichtig auch Maßnahmen
ergreifen um dem entgegen zu treten und
wenn man sich jetzt das Handeln anschaut
dass die Bundesregierung an den Tag legt
also ich sag's ganz ehrlich ich erkenne
da weder Enthusiasmus noch Motivation
überhaupt irgendwas für die berufliche
Bildung zu tun die Abwesenheit der
Ministerin spricht da ja auch ihre
eigene Sprache
dabei liegen aus meiner Sicht die
Handlungsoptionen ja ganz offen auf der
Hand und ich beschränke mich auf ein
paar wenige Beispiele auf auch aufgrund
der Kürze der Redezeit die dafür aber
ganz oft konkret abschreiben an der
Stelle sehr gerne gesehen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
erstes Beispiel die Förderung der
Bildungszentren im Handwerk da wird der
bekanntlich die überbetriebliche
lehrlingsunterweisung durchgeführt und
das auch noch sehr erfolgreich wenn man
sich zum Beispiel anschaut das
Innovationen in dem Handwerk ja häufig
genau über den Weg auch in die Betriebe
gelangen das Konzept muss aus unserer
Sicht also gestärkt werden deutlich
gestärkt werden wenn man die Ausbildung
im Handwerk innovativer und attraktiver
machen wollen
aktuell
hören wir aus dem BMWF aber das nicht
sichergestellt ist dass die Mittel für
die Förderung in dem ja überhaupt
ausreichen werden und die finden
mittelfristige Finanzplanung wird auch
eher als negativ eingeschätzt
das da wird zwar wohl eine Änderung der
bisherigen Förderpolitik geben und zwar
ist es diskutiert unter dem Begriff der
Exzellenzinitiative das dann aber nur
noch einige wenige leuchtturmzentrum
eine Förderung erhalten ist aus unserer
Sicht kontraproduktiv wir brauchen
dringend dringend auch in Zukunft die
Bildungszentren in der Fläche weil die
Handwerksbetriebe überall in Deutschland
sind und zwar auch im und gerade im
ländlichen Raum und das sollen sie auch
bleiben aus unserer Sicht
zweites Beispiel laut Koalitionsvertrag
soll des AFBG ausgebaut werden Umsetzung
auch da Fehlanzeige dabei muss man doch
gerade jetzt angesichts der Zahlen die
man heute gesehen haben jede Chance
ergreifen um eine gleichwertige
Förderung von Studenten und
fortbildungsteilnehmern herzustellen bei
den meisterprüfen war in den letzten
zehn Jahren pro Jahr ein Rückgang von
1,6 Prozent zu verzeichnen 2020 haben in
den Handwerksbetrieben
5.600 Meister gefehlt wenn man alle
offenen Stellen hätte besetzen wollen
und statt Anreize zu schaffen müssen wir
müssen angehende Handwerksmeister immer
noch 25% der Fortbildungskosten selber
tragen ganz anders als das im Studium
der Fall ist auch da braucht man
dringend Handlung
Beispiele und Maßnahmen wie wir die
Berufsbildung wieder attraktiver machen
können gibt es viele die Lage ist ernst
die Lage ist dringend und deswegen
wiederhole ich zum Schluss gerne mein
Angebot aus der letzten Woche unser Herz
schlägt für die berufliche Bildung und
wir sind bereit
und wir sind bereit dass wir die
Aufgaben die großen Aufgaben die vor uns
liegen gemeinsam mit Ihnen und
konstruktiv anpacken danke schön
soweit das Angebot von Katrin Staffler
natürliche war das Thema Ausbildung auch
schon in der vorherigen Legislatur hier
immer wieder Thema im Bundestag Kai
Gehring wird nun entsprechend erst der
Vorsitzende des Bildungsausschusses
Bildungsbericht habe im Jahr 2022
475.100 junge Menschen einen
Ausbildungsvertrag abgeschlossen
475.100 junge Menschen die eine sehr
gute Karriereentscheidung getroffen
haben die sich in den nächsten Jahren
von Auszubildenden zu Fachkräften
entwickeln werden und die unsere
Wirtschaft klimagerecht und digital
transformieren mit klugen Kopf und mit
geschickten Händen und diese jungen
Menschen bilden die wirtschaftliche
Basis unseres Landes
das gilt genauso für über 186.000 junge
Menschen die ihre Ausbildungen
Gesundheit sozial und Bildungswesen
angefangen haben das sind unter anderem
unsere zukünftigen Erzieherinnen und
Erzieher und Pflegekräfte die den
kehrbranchen den demografischen Wandel
gestalten helfen und als Ausschuss für
Bildung Forschung und Technik
Folgenabschätzung wünschen wir allen
Azubis auf ihrem Weg zum Abschluss viel
Erfolg
die Anzahl neuer Ausbildungsverträge ist
leicht gestiegen zugleich die Nachfrage
nach Ausbildung bei jungen Menschen
leicht gesunken wir brauchen aber alle
angesichts der fachkräftekrise wir
brauchen dringend mehr Meister und mehr
Master wir dürfen kein Potenzial
zurücklassen
gerade die 2,6 Millionen zwischen 20 und
34 Jahren die kein Berufsabschluss haben
brauchen Perspektiven das ist
tatsächlich eine gemeinschaftliche
Aufgabe eröffnen wir den zweite und
dritte Chancen auf Abschlüsse und auf
Anschlüsse bieten wir alle eine
qualitativ hochwertige Ausbildung
wir müssen gemeinschaftlich mit dem BMBF
mit den Tarifpartnern und Verbänden
tatsächlich ran ans Miss matching
Beispiele sind genannt ich meine damit
auch nicht zuletzt die über 140.000
Ausbildungsverträge die vorzeitig
aufgelöst wurden oftmals gerade wegen
falscher Erwartungen an den zukünftigen
Job und daher müssen wir Jugendliche in
unseren Schulen das ganze Berufsspektrum
kennenlernen lassen die
Berufsorientierung im Land muss endlich
besser werden nur wenn die
Berufsorientierung verbessert wird
verbessert sich auch das Matching
zwischen Jugendlichen und betrieben und
da sind bundländer da sind wir alle
miteinander gefordert
nur dann schaffen wir auch das was unser
gemeinsames Ziel sein sollte nämlich
mehr Wahlfreiheit und mehr
Durchlässigkeit für junge Menschen das
ist eine doppelte Aufgabe mehr
Arbeiterkindern den Weg auf den Campus
zu ebenen und mehr Akademiker Kinder für
berufliche Ausbildung begeistern und
auch das muss Berufsberatung und
Berufsorientierung schaffen gerade auch
an Gymnasien
Studium und berufliche Bildung sind
gleichwertig und die Koalition packt da
an das ist die Exzellenzinitiative
berufliche Bildung und für untermauern
das auch mit dem Programm für junges
Wohnen was erstmals Azubis ausdrücklich
mit einbezieht machen wir auf diesem Weg
weiter indem wir unter anderem das
aufstiegs-bafög Ausweiten die
Ausbildungsgarantie auslösen mehr Azubis
mittels erasmus+ ein Auslandsaufenthalt
und letzter Satz eine gute Lösung für
ein bundesweit vergünstigtes
azubi-ticket finden so machen wir die
berufliche Ausbildung für alle
attraktiver damit nicht nur die
berufliche Ausbildung Menschen eine
Perspektive haben
für die cdu/csu-fraktion erhält das Wort
Daniela Ludwig
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen gerne hätte ich auch die
Ministerin begrüßt sie ist anderweitig
verpflichtet schade bei diesem Thema
dass ihr ja angeblich so wichtig ist uns
ist es jedenfalls im Parlament wichtig
und ich möchte direkt sagen Herr
Staatssekretär sie haben ja am Ende so
fröhlich gesagt der Abwärtstrend ist
beendet also diesen Bericht entnehme ich
nicht dass der Abwärtstrend beendet ist
vielleicht haben Sie einen anderen
gelesen aber ich denke die Zahlen sind
nach wie vor
besorgniserregende Ausbildungsmarkt hat
das vor Krisen Niveau nach wie vor nicht
erreicht die Zahl der sozusagen
ungelernten wird immer noch mehr es
stehen sich immer tatsächlich noch mehr
Plätze und immer weniger werdende
Bewerber gegenüber das heißt in der Tat
lieber Herr Kollege das Thema matching
und alles darüber hinaus ist sicherlich
ein ganz ganz wichtiger Punkt um den wir
uns kümmern müssen und ich schließe mich
dem Angebot meiner geschätzten Kollegen
Staffler an dass wir hier wirklich
gemeinsam gucken müssen dass wir
vorwärts kommen und deswegen möchte ich
mich neben all den vielen wichtigen
Themen die schon angesprochen sind gar
nicht wiederholen aber eines schon noch
mein aller Deutlichkeit herausgreifen
das Thema Berufsorientierung ist schon
etwas dass wir uns noch deutlich stärker
anschauen müssen ich habe schon aus der
Praxis heraus
den deutlichen Eindruck dass dazu viel
generell und zu wenig individuell
gemacht wird zu wenig
schulartenspezifisch gemacht wird dass
alles über einen Kamm geschoren wird und
dass wir uns hier deutlich mehr Mühe
geben müssen insbesondere aufgrund der
prekären Situation in der die Betriebe
sind nämlich dass sie einfach zu wenig
potenzielle Fachkräfte finden dass wir
uns da nochmal stärker auf dieses Thema
stürzen müssen es gibt ein sehr sehr gab
ein sehr sehr gutes Programm des Bob
Berufsorientierungsprogramm nennt es
sich es hat sich speziell an
Schülerinnen und Schüler der siebten und
achten Klassen gewendet um Ihnen die
Möglichkeit zu geben zunächst an
Werkstatttagen Berufsfelder
kennenzulernen vorher ein Stück weit
theoretisch zu erfahren welche Angebote
gibt es im Speziellen im Handwerk des
Programm hat super funktioniert hat auch
davon gelebt dass das Handwerk sich
aktiv eingebracht hat und immer wieder
danach geschärft hat und gesagt hat wo
die Lücken sind es war kein rein
theoretisches
Berufsorientierungsprogramm sondern eben
sehr sehr stark praktisch orientiert in
dem bildungsberufszentren des Handwerks
und da kommt jetzt zu Einschnitten bei
den Förderrichtlinien da kommt es dazu
dass man es insbesondere den
Handwerkskammern vor Ort immer noch
schwerer macht an diesem Programm
festzuhalten das halten für den ganz
schweren Fehler und ich möchte sie
wirklich sehr sehr herzlich bitten
insbesondere um den Fachkräftemangel im
Handwerk nicht noch größer werden zu
lassen hier nachzuschärfen die Förderung
wieder anders aufzustellen dem Handwerk
die Hand zu reichen und ganz klar zu
sagen wir brauchen dieses
Berufsorientierungsprogramm
flächendeckend nicht nur in ausgewählten
Bildungszentren wir brauchen es
gemeinsam mit dem Handwerk wir brauchen
es insbesondere nicht außer betrieblich
sondern wir brauchen es mit den
Betrieben da gilt dringend
nachzuschaffen dafür stehen wir gerne
zur Verfügung vielen Dank
hier wieder ein Angebot aus der
Unionsfraktion und damit kommen wir hier
zur letzten Rednerin in dieser Debatte
das ist Carolin Wagner für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen überall vielen
Arbeitskräfte und Azubis das höre ich
oft wenn ich im Betrieben in meinem
Wahlkreis Regensburg unterwegs bin und
nicht nur bei mir zu Hause höre ich das
auch in der Berichterstattung über den
Ausbildungsmarkt ist zu lesen dass viele
tausende Ausbildungsplätze nicht besetzt
werden können dem gegenüber aber steht
eine brutale Zahl die wir heute schon
öfter gehört haben 2,6 Millionen das ist
die Zahl der jungen Menschen zwischen 30
zwischen 20 und 34 Jahren in Deutschland
ohne Berufsabschluss das sind fast 18
Prozent zuletzt ist diese Zahl um 2,3
Prozentpunkte angestiegen es ist eine
dramatische Zahl und die drohenden
Folgen für diese jungen Menschen auf
ihrem weiteren Lebensweg etwa das Risiko
für Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit sind es
ebenso
zehntausende Jugendliche verlassen ja
für Jahr die Schule ohne einen
Schulabschluss in der Tasche zu haben
auch das ist eine Zahl die wir als SPD
nicht AK zeptieren wollen weil damit die
Chancen auf einen guten Arbeitsplatz und
damit auf ein selbstbestimmtes Leben
rapide sinkt gerade hier
in der Unterstützung beim Schulabschluss
beim Übergang in einen Ausbildungsberuf
oder beim auffangen wenn eben der
Schulabschluss nicht gelungen ist fehlt
es an strukturierter Betreuung und
individuellen förderkonzepten besonders
grotesk finde ich dass uns ja für Jahr
zahlreiche Jugendliche einfach vom
bildungsausbildungs- und
arbeitsmarktradar komplett verschwinden
sie gehen raus aus der Schule finden
aber nirgendwo anders Eingang und dieser
Übergang muss besser gelingen wenn wir
es mit der Fachkräfte Offensive ernst
meinen und das tun wir als
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion deshalb
bringen wir als Ampel auch die
Ausbildungsplatz Garantie auf die Spur
und geben damit jedem jungen Menschen in
diesem Land das Versprechen dass für ihn
oder sie der Weg in eine berufliche
Zukunft offen steht und das allein sehr
geehrte heilbari ist schon so viel mehr
als in 16 Jahren Regierungsverantwortung
der Union gemacht wurde
möchte den Bundesarbeitsminister an
dieser Stelle danken
wir erneuern nämlich damit unser
Versprechen dass wir rund um die
Energiekosten gegeben haben wir lassen
niemanden im Stich eine ganz wichtige
Botschaft gerade auch für die vielen
jungen Menschen in diesem Land und
darüber hinaus gilt es noch mehr zu tun
eine bessere Zusammenarbeit zwischen
Schulen und Arbeitsagenturen durch den
Austausch von Daten etwa natürlich nur
nach vorheriger Zustimmung der
Betroffenen das würde aufsuchende
proaktive Angebote für diese Menschen
ermöglichen eine möglichst individuelle
Begleitung der Jugendlichen in der
schulabschlussphase aber auch in der
Ausbildung sind der Garant für ein
erfolgreiches Bestehen die
Ausbilderinnen und Ausbilder in den
Betrieben benötigen dafür auch die
entsprechende Zeit und dürfen nicht mit
zu viel Aufgaben überlastet werden
besonders dramatisch ist dass die Zahl
der ausbildenden Betriebe erneut
gesunken ist und liegt sie liegt nur
noch bei 19,1 Prozent in der Folge liegt
die Ausbildungsverantwortung bei immer
weniger betrieben und auch wenn sie
nicht Teil des Koalitionsvertrag s
geworden ist bleibt damit für mich die
Umlagefinanzierung in der Debatte um die
Ausbildungsplatz garantiert nicht nur
zeitgemäß sondern unbedingt erforderlich
gemäß
der nicht zahlt wird umgelegt vielen
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
und damit schließe ich die Aussprache
und heiße sie auch recht herzlich
willkommen und guten Tag von meiner
Seite auch den Besucherinnen und
Besuchern auf den Tribünen in der
fraktionell wird bei Top 4 die
Überweisung der Vorlage auf Drucksache
6800 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen so
Yvonne mag was hat jetzt hier die
Sitzungsleitung übernommen zum Ende
dieses Tagesordnungspunktes und damit
ruft sie auch gleich den neuen
Tagesordnungspunkt auf da geht es um das
Grundgesetz das feierte am 23 mai also
gerade gestern 74 Geburtstag das ist
doch recht besonders wenn man daran
denkt dass das ja eigentlich nur ein
Provisorium sein sollte und eben bis zum
heutigen Tag geht zunächst einmal für
die Westdeutschen Staaten und dann mit
der Wiedervereinigung auch für die
damals neuen
Länder wurde es 1990 zur Verfassung
behält aber den Namen
Grundgesetz und zum heutigen Tag gibt es
natürlich zum heutigen zum gestrigen Tag
gibt es natürlich auch Forderungen eine
der Debatten ist ja das Kinderrechte ins
Grundgesetz eingearbeitet werden sollen
auch in der Koalition ist das ein Thema
die Unionsfraktion hat hier ein Antrag
eingereicht zum Grundgesetz für die
Unionsfraktion spricht nun Andrea
Lindholz sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Bundesjustizminister dr Marco Buschmann
erklärte am 23 Mai letzten Jahres dass
wir uns doch in Deutschland zumindestens
auf einen Patriotismus sollten einigen
können und zwar den
Verfassungspatriotismus denn mit dem
Grundgesetz hätten wir eine Verfassung
für die wir dankbar und auf die wir
stolz sein können er gratulierte dem
Grundgesetz in einem anderthalb
minütigen Videos Statement zum
Geburtstag
eineinhalb Minuten werden übrigens in
der Tagesschau auch benötigt um die
Lottozahlen zu verlesen und wie sah
jetzt in diesem Jahr die feierliche
Würdigung des Fundamentes unserer
Demokratie und dem Garanten unserer
Grundrechte aus der gestrige Festakt zum
Tag des Grundgesetzes wurde erstmals
durch die Bundeszentrale für politische
Bildung in dem von Bertolt Brecht
gegründeten Berliner Theater organisiert
bundesinnenministerin Fezer hielt ein
Grußwort und Bundespräsident
Frank-Walter Steinmeier nahm an einem
bühnengespräch zum Thema unser
Engagement für eine vielfältige
Gesellschaft Teil liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren jeder
Staat braucht politisches Symbole und er
braucht Rituale die den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern
Identifikationsmöglichkeiten bieten und
auch ein
zusammengehörigkeitsgefühlstiften und es
hat sich bereits in den letzten Jahren
gezeigt dass die Formate zum 23 mai wie
etwa Kaffeetafeln im Schloss Bellevue
kaum öffentliches Interesse
hervorgerufen haben und damit diesem
planungsjubiläum auch nicht angemessen
sind wir wollen deshalb den Tag des
Grundgesetzes als Gedenktag mit einer
Großveranstaltung alle deutschen
Verfassungsorgane aufwerten wir wollen
mit einem Bundesprogramm Patriotismus
dazu beitragen dass die Berliner
Republik ihre gebührende Form der
Repräsentation unsere Staates findet und
wie dringend das notwendig ist das zeigt
auch kürzlich erst der Besuch von König
Charles dem dritten hier in Berlin die
Berliner Zeitung sie listete minusiös
alle Peinlichkeiten auf denn
protokoll-mäßig schien man hier bei uns
nicht nur überfordert zu sein sondern
präsentierte sich zudem so zumindestens
die Autoren wie ein Entwicklungsland das
meine Damen und Herren dürfen wir so
nicht weiter zulassen und mit unserem
Antrag wollen wir daher auch eine
weitere grundlegende Debatte anstoßen
wir wollen
wollen wir Deutsche wollen wir im 21
Jahrhundert uns selbst überhaupt noch
als Nation verstehen an einer Antwort
hierzu hat sich bereits 2010 der
damalige Vorsitzende der
Landtagsfraktion der Grünen in
Schleswig-Holstein versucht wir erinnern
uns es war Robert Habeck der mit seinem
in seinem Buch Patriotismus ein linkes
Plädoyer behauptete und zwar allen
Ernstes dass die Deutschlandfahnen der
Fußball-WM 2006 nicht etwas signalisiert
haben dass wir ein Volk sind sondern
dass wir Fans sind er bekannte darin
offen dass er mit Deutschland eigentlich
nichts anzufangen wisse und er ist es
auch bis heute nicht sein progressives
Weltbild gipfelte in der Aussage es sei
möglich eine Art von Patriotismus zu
entwickeln der letztendlich Deutschland
gar nicht brauche und er versucht habe
Ex damit den deutschen Linken den
Patriotismus schmackhaft zu machen und
die Politik des jetzigen bundeswir
tschaftsministers Robert Habeck die sind
leider in sich auch noch stimmig sie
gehen nämlich völlig an der Realität in
unserem Land vorbei
die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ist daher der
Auffassung dass Grundgesetz und
Patriotismus in der Zeitenwende starke
Potenziale zum Wohl von Staat und
Gesellschaft entfalten können wir wollen
dass der Reichstag als parlamentarisches
Zentrum Patriot patriotischer
Selbstvergewisserung gestärkt werden
hierher gehören Porträts bedeutender
Parlamentarier und Bilder der deutschen
Nationalgeschichte hin die auch zeigen
auf welchen Traditionen unsere heutige
Demokratie beruht das könnte auch sehr
gut sein für insbesondere die jungen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Grünen wie
wir gerade anlässlich eines geschichts-
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Schriftsteller
romöo jerry hat die Unterscheidung
zwischen Patriotismus und Nationalismus
es wird ja oft diskutiert ganz gut auf
dem Punkt gebracht Patriotismus das ist
die Liebe zu den Seinen und
Nationalismus das ist der Hass auf die
anderen und deswegen wollen wir mit
unserem Antrag Verfassung und
Patriotismus als verbindendes Band
stärken und wir wollen den Tag des
Grundgesetzes den 23 mai als Gedenktag
aufwerten und ich bitte Sie daher auch
um Unterstützung für unseren Antrag
Andrea Lindholz hat hier die Debatte
eröffnet zum Antrag der Unionsfraktion
für die SPD-Fraktion spricht nun ja
Kaiser
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren junggeblieben ist sie
unsere Verfassung auch in ihrem 75
lebensjahr überzeugt zu durch ihre
Unaufgeregtheit und ihre wenigstens
ursprünglich wunderbar präzise schlanke
Formen Eigentum verpflichtet Frauen und
Männer sind gleichberechtigt und einem
vorangestellt die Würde des Menschen ist
unantastbar der Mensch steht unserer nun
gesamtdeutschen Verfassung voran erst
dann danach folgt der Staat folgen die
Institutionen des Staates die Grund- und
Freiheitsrechte der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wurden gleich am Anfang
formuliert meine Damen und Herren was
hat das denn bitte mit Patriotismus zu
tun
Patriotismus das ist die Liebe zum
Vaterland aber es gibt viele Bürgerinnen
und Bürger dieses Landes die unsere
Verfassung schätzen und leben und
trotzdem ist Deutschland nicht ihr
Vaterland über
Verfassungspatriotismus darüber können
wir debattieren denn genau diesen
sollten wir jeden Tag jede Woche jedes
Jahr leben 24 7 das ist unsere
grundlegende als Sozialdemokratinnen und
Sozialdemokraten auch zu 160 Jahre SPD
ein Blick in die Protokolle
der Beratung des Parlamentarischen Rates
damals zeigt dass Ringen und streiten um
Formulierungen nach zwölf Jahren ein
esstiktatur um einzelne Punkte
allerdings einem konstruktiven Ton in an
der Sache orientierten Debatte und in
durchaus auch geistreichen Diskussionen
nicht diskreditierend wie wir es heute
leider allzu oft erleben Frau Lindholz
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren in dem
Antrag der Union kann ich 47 74 Jahre
nach der Verkündung des Grundgesetzes
von spiegelstrich 1 bis 3 K Punkt in dem
Antrag nur eines sehen es geht um
Polemik nur der Mensch steht nicht im
Vordergrund und das wäre so wichtig
der Jurist in und Sozialdemokratin
elisabeth Selbert verdank wir das klare
Bekenntnis zur Gleichberechtigung in
unserem Grundgesetz gerade mal vier
Frauen von insgesamt 65 Mitgliedern des
Parlamentarischen Rates durften das
Gesetz mitgestalten selber als Antrag
wurde mehrfach abgelehnt zu initiierte
sie eine öffentliche Protest der durch
wäschekörbeweise Post von Frauen aus der
ganzen Republik nach Bonn unterstützt
wurde zusammen mit Friederike Nadig SPD
Helene Weber CDU und Helene
wessel-zentrum Partei haben sie oder hat
sie Großes geschaffen ein Andenken an
diese vier Frauen sollte uns
gleichzeitig Ansporn sein die
Gleichberechtigung endlich und in allen
Bereichen unseres Lebens umzusetzen und
Realität werden zu lassen und da nützt
ein verbindungsband gar nichts da würden
endlich gleicher Lohn für gleiche Arbeit
helfen und mehr Frauen im
parlamentenverehrte Union lassen sie
mich zum Schluss frau Präsidentin noch
einen wichtigen Aspekt anmerken in der
nächsten Woche jetzt sich der 30
jahrestag des Brandanschlages in
Solingen am frühen Morgen des 29 mai
1993 sind im Brandanschlag fünf Menschen
zum Opfer gefallen sitzen weitere
Menschen wurden schwer verletzt dieser
Anschlag hatte einen rechtsradikalen
Hintergrund wie leider viele andere
Anschläge dieser fürchterlichen Art er
steht symbolisch für die fürchterlichen
ausländisch ausländerfeindlichen
Verbrechen in unserem Land damals wurde
übrigens auch das Asylrecht drei Tage
zuvor im Bundestag geändert es ist umso
wichtiger sich täglich für unser
Grundgesetz einzusetzen und unsere darin
benannten Werte mit Leben zu füllen da
dient es auf jeden Fall nicht ein
Bundesprogramm Patriotismus zu schnüren
und im gleichen Atemzug den
Alltagsrassismus zu bedienen und von
kleinen Paschas zu reden ich würde mich
schon darüber freuen wenn Sie die
Gesetzgebung wie die Reform des
staatsangehörigkeitsunterstützen würden
heute ist der 24 mai einer von 365
Feiertagen im Jahr für unser Grundgesetz
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort Dr
Christian Wirth
[Applaus]
Werte Kollegen eins vorab vieles im
vorliegenden Antrag der Union finden wir
gut unser Grundgesetz ist zweifellos
eine großartige Errungenschaft auf die
wir alle stolz sein können und der Weg
dorthin war schwer wie ein kurzer Blick
in die Geschichte zeigt bereits 1817
zogen hunderte von Burschenschafter von
vielen deutschen Universitäten auf die
Wartburg bei Eisenach unter dem
Einspruch ehrefreiheit Vaterland fordert
und sie ein Ende der deutschen
kleinstadtei und verfassungsrechtlich
garantierte Freiheitsrechte der jener
Prof Heinrich fast im Anschluss an das
war gut fest die Forderungen zusammen
von denen uns viele bekannt vorkommen
die Gleichheit vor dem Gesetz Sicherheit
der Person und des Eigentums Rede und
Pressefreiheit und einiges mehr die
Formulierungen von 1817 gegen teilweise
wortgleich in die paulskirtenversammlung
später in die Weimarer Verfassung und
1949 in unserer Grundgesetz über im
übrigen auch in der Verfassung der
Republik Österreich
auch die Schattenseite unsere Geschichte
haben das Grundgesetz geprägt blickt man
die Verfassung anderer Staaten so
beginnen sie meistens mit Nüchter
formulierten Bestimmungen zur Staatsform
Frankreich ist eine unteilbare
laizistische demokratische und soziale
Republik Österreich ist eine
demokratische Republik und ein
Bundesstaat bei uns ist es anders die
Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar
lautet Artikel 1 unseres Grundgesetzes
unsere Verfassung beginnt aus gutem
Grund mit einer Folge von abwehrrechten
des Bürgers gegenüber dem Staat der Tag
des Grundgesetzes ist sicherlich ein
Grund des zu feiern und vor allem zu
gedenken welche Intention die Verfasser
unseres Grundgesetzes mit ihren
Formulierungen im Sinn hatten nur als so
oft werden heutzutage Grundsätze
zeitgeistig um interpretiert von vielen
hier leider im Hause aber auch von
Behörden die ihren Namen nach vorgeben
diese Verfassung zu schützen
das Anliegen des unionsantrages ist gut
Patriotismus trägt wie Sie schreiben zum
Erhalt und zur Stabilisierung des
Gemeinwesens durch Identifikation der
Bürger mit ihrem Staat bei ein bisschen
mehr Mut hätte man von der Union noch
erwarten können Patriotismus wird
sicherlich nicht alleine durch unsere
rechts- und Verfassungsordnung erweckt
so wichtig und gut sie auch sein mögen
Rainer verfassungspatrouillonismus wird
unserer Kultur nicht gerecht es Bedarf
zusätzlich weiterer
Identifikationsmerkmale neben den
offenen Union aufgeführten deutschen
staatsymbolen wie unsere Farben schwarz
rot gold und die bliebter Deutschen sind
es doch emotionale Dinge die uns allen
unsere Kultur mit allen ihren Facetten
unsere gemeinsame Geschichte mit ihren
Licht und auch Schattenseiten und
natürlich unsere schöne deutsche Sprache
diese Punkte sind es doch vor allem die
uns zusammenschweißen und dieses sollten
auch stärker gepflegt werden leider
passiert auch das Gegenteil von der
Verhunzung der deutsche Sprache will ich
gar nicht anfangen ernsthafte Sorgen
macht mir beispielsweise Äußerungen der
FDP die unsere Sprache als
Wettbewerbsnachteil auf dem
internationalen Arbeitsmarkt ansieht
unsere Kultur wird auf irgendwelche
schuldigkeiten wie das Reservieren einer
Liege am Hotelpool mit einem Handtuch
reduziert bezogen auf unsere Geschichte
brauchen wir selbstverständlich eine
verhandlungsbewusste Erinnerung Kultur
aber eben auch in Bezug zum Positiven
wie es etwa der Antrag in Bezug auf die
Gründungsgeschichte der Bundesrepublik
fordert ein Teil unserer Geschichte auf
dem man patriotisch zurückblicken kann
wenn wir es schaffen einen positiven
Bezug zu diesem Land zu vermitteln dann
klappt es auch wunderbar mit der
Integration eben weil man stolz sein
kann ein Teil davon zu werden ein gutes
Beispiel sind die USA hierzu ein Tag des
Grundgesetzes ist ein gutes ein guter
Anfang ich wünsche mir noch mehr vielen
Dank Glückauf
Christian wird war das für die
afd-fraktion hier mit einiger Zustimmung
zum Antrag der Unionsfraktion in
nächster Redner ist Lukas Benner für die
Grünen Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer während meiner Studienzeit in
Bonn bin ich immer mal wieder am Museum
König vorbei spaziert in langen
Lernpausen und habe versucht mich in das
Jahr 1949 zurück zu versetzen am 23 mai
also gestern vor genau 74 Jahren
verkündete dort der Parlamentarische Rat
das Grundgesetz inmitten von Trümmern
inmitten einer Gesellschaft die für das
größte menschheitsverbrechende
Geschichte verantwortlich war
und dann ein Grundgesetz mit Weitblick
und Bescheidenheit in seiner Sprache
bestimmt schnörkellos präzise wie
glücklich können wir uns schätzen dieses
Grundgesetz zu haben diese unglaubliche
Erfolgsgeschichte
rechtsst Möglichkeit und die Wahrung von
Grundrechten sind aber keine
Selbstverständlichkeit das wird bei
einem Blick in die Welt deutlich in die
Ukraine wo Russland sein grausamen
Vernichtungskrieg fortsetzt nach Iran wo
das Regime erst vor wenigen Tagen wieder
weitere Demonstranten hingerichtet hat
in die USA wohnen Bundesstaat Florida
unter Gouverneur ronde Säntis
Schulunterricht über Homosexualität
verboten und somit essentielle
Freiheiten drastisch eingeschränkt
wurden und ich finde es unerträglich mit
welcher Gleichgültigkeit unsere
Gesellschaft inzwischen hingenommen hat
dass jedes Jahr tausende Menschen im
Mittelmeer trinken
das Grundgesetz wurde in den letzten 74
Jahren immer wieder an neue Realitäten
angepasst der Artikel 87a das
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr ist
der jüngste Ausdruck davon dass auch die
Gerichtsbarkeit einen entscheidenden
Antrag daran hat uns Verfassung
zeitgemäß auszulegen zeigen wohl wenige
Beschlüsse so deutlich wie Jena zum
Artikel 20A der unter dem Stichwort
Klima Beschluss bekannt geworden ist
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union mit einem gewissen Erstaunen habe
ich Ihren Antrag gelesen und zwar weil
ich den Antrag ganz seltsam verkrampft
finde ich weiß nicht was sie am
Wochenende mit ihrer grundsatzkommission
am Comer See alles gemacht haben aber
das Heimweh muss erschrecken groß sein
wenn man auf dem Weg nach Deutschland an
jeder Fahne an jeder Laterne eine Fahne
anbringen will sie wollen ein
Bundesprogramm Patriotismus auflegen den
Reichstag als Zentrum patria
patriotischer Selbstvergewisserung
stärken und weiter heißt es auch hier zu
Lande lebende Ausländer sollen von den
verbindenden und einladenden Potentialen
des Patriotismus angesprochen werden
meine Damen und Herren der helfen doch
keine Farmen Appelle und die
Nationalhymne sondern ein modernes
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht dass sie so
lange blockiert haben und dass wir als
Ampel endlich umsetzen wollen
Patriotismus per Decret so wie sie es in
ihrem Antrag vorschlagen das offenbart
ein herrliches ein autoritäres
Gesellschaftsverständnis dass mich mehr
als irritiert und deswegen leben wir in
Antrag ab
und für die Fraktion DIE LINKE erteile
ich das Wort Janine Wissler Janine
Wissler ist ja auch Parteivorsitzender
der Linken
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die cdu/csu will den 23 mai zum
Gedenktag machen um das Grundgesetz zu
würdigen nun ja jetzt war ja die Union
nicht immer schon geschlossen ein
Fanclub das Grundgesetzes wir wollen ja
mal nicht vergessen dass der Bayerische
Landtag mit seiner CSU-Mehrheit damals
als einziges Parlament gegen das
Grundgesetz gestimmt hat in ihrem
aber leider
nicht um das Grundgesetz und es geht
auch nicht um die Grundrechte darin was
sie fordern ist ein Bunde
spräsidentismus die stärker
e Symbole das regelmäßige Singen der
Nationalhymne und mehr öffentliche
Gelöbnisse der Bundeswehr abstruse
Forderungen und deutsch-tümerei die man
sonst in afd-anträgen liest auch
zweieinhalb Seiten meine Damen und
Herren kommen die Begriffe Patriotismus
Nation und national 32 mal vor sie
fordern mehr Patriotismus um der
Spaltung der Gesellschaft
entgegenzuwirken meine Damen und Herren
angesichts von steigenden
Lebensmittelpreisen von steigenden
Mieten Wissen Menschen nicht mehr wie
sie ihre Rechnungen bezahlen sollen das
spaltet die Gesellschaft das wenige
reicher und viele armer werden
der Union ist
[Applaus]
einen alle gemeinsam hinter schwarz rot
gold in Abgrenzung zu allen die nicht
dazu gehören können oder wollen wer mehr
Patriotismus und nationale
es gibt eine Zunahme rechter
antisemitischer und rassistischer
Straftat hatten vor einigen Jahren
demonstrierte pegida gegen Muslime und
geflüchtete und nur zur Erinnerung das P
stand für patriotisch oder um es mit den
Worten des Kängurus zu sagen
gesunder Patriotismus klingt für mich
ein bisschen wie gutartiger Tumor es ist
vielleicht nicht direkt lebensgefährlich
aber es ist immer noch ein Tumor
bemerkenswert bekloppt sind aber die
Ausführung zur Ostdeutschland in ihrem
Antrag Schwachstelle der
Wiedervereinigung sei das ostdeutsche
einen fehlenden Bezug zur eigenen Nation
hätten und deshalb fordern Sie jetzt
einen besonderen Einsatz für
patriotische Fragen in Ostdeutschland da
können sie der
AfA auch gleich selber aufhängen meine
Damen und Herren
national stolz wird an einigen Orten
sogar eher das Gegenteil das Problem ist
dass die Löhne und Renten auch nach 30
Jahren niedriger sind als in
Westdeutschland das Problem ist dass die
Treuhand ausgeplündert hat und das
Lebensleistung nicht anerkannt wurden
das Problem der Wiedervereinigung ist
doch nicht dass dazu wenig Fähnchen
geschwungen wurden und gesungen wurde
und wenn sie die Identifikation mit dem
deutschen Staat bei Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund stärken wollen
dann geben Sie doch endlich mal ihren
Widerstand gegen erleichterte
Einbürgerungen auf
meine Damen und Herren ihren Antrag kann
man nur ablehnen weil sie keine Lösung
auf die lenken ab von den Problemen und
sie sollten sich verdammt gut überlegen
an wen sie sich heranwanzen mit solchen
Anträgen vielen Dank
Janine Wissler hat hier die Abstimmung
des Antrags der Unionsfraktion
angekündigt den nun hören wir aber ist
immer die Meinung von Linda Teuteberg
die Mitglied der FDP-Fraktion ist
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Anmut sparet nicht noch Mühe
Leidenschaft nicht noch verstand dass
ein gutes Deutschland blühe wie ein
anderes gutes Land
und weil wir dieses Land verbessern
lieben und beschürmen wir es und das
liebste magst uns scheint so wie anderen
Völkern ihres liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Berthold Brecht der wusste
jedenfalls noch dass man Patriot sein
kann ohne andere auszugrenzen auch Sie
sollten ruhig mal drüber nachdenken
das ist eine Liebe zum diesem Land geben
kann die man genauso anderen Völkern
zugesteht und damit niemanden
herabsetzen will ich finde das sollte
uns auch leiten diese Debatte durchaus
ernst zu nehmen ein auch emotionale
hinwendungen zur Gemeinschaft zum Staat
zu einer liberalen Republik des
Grundgesetzes die ist durchaus wichtig
sie ist auch für eine
Einwanderungsgesellschaft übrigens nicht
minder wichtig da muss man nämlich auch
sagen selbst Hass ist kein
Identifikationsangebot auch nicht wenn
er in seiner verklemmten Version
daherkommt ein gestörtes Verhältnis zur
eigenen Nation zu haben sondern es geht
darum die deutsche Geschichte in aller
Vielfalt mit der Revolution von 1848
über die wir ja auch vor kurzem
gesprochen haben genauso wie mit ihren
dunklen Seiten in aller Verantwortung
anzunehmen und zu erinnern liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und diese Republik des Grundgesetzes die
wird nicht allein von dem gerichtlich
durchsetzbaren Regeln getragen sie lebt
auch von einer politischen Kultur die
rechtlich nicht erzwungen werden kann
sondern die wir mit Leben füllen müssen
und die im Alltag stattfinden muss das
meinte auch böckenförder mit seinem
berühmten dictum und gemein sind da alle
Symbole und Praktiken mit denen sich
auch ein Land und eine Gesellschaft
ihrer Werte versichert darüber lohnt die
Debatte die glaube ich müssen wir im
Ausschuss führen und deshalb werden wir
einer Überweisung ihres Antrages
zustimmen und dass das nicht so
selbstverständlich ist zeigen ja manche
Ereignisse der letzten Jahre wer etwa
mit dem Slogan und heilbar demonstriert
aber sagt wer mit Schwarz-Rot-Gold zur
Demonstration kommt ist unerwünscht er
hat nicht ganz begriffen dass diese
Flagge zu unserem Grundgesetz gehört und
deshalb lohnt die Debatte
ein ernst gemeinter
Verfassungspatriotismus der ist
allerdings anspruchsvoller als es
scheint er erfordert die Bereitschaft
zur inhaltlichen Auseinandersetzung bei
vielen strittigen politischen Themen
berufen sich nämlich Vertreter
verschiedener Meinungen gleichermaßen
auf die Grundrechte bei der Ehe für alle
zum Beispiel die einen auf den Schutz
von Ehe und Familie und die anderen auf
die Gleichheit aller Menschen und beides
hat seine Berechtigung es muss gerungen
werden und immer wieder um die
zeitgemäße Deutung des Grundgesetzes
gerungen werden und das sei übrigens
auch all denjenigen gesagt sie meinen
mit der mit der Verweis auf eine
Bestimmung des Grundgesetzes sei ihre
Meinung schon die allein richtige und
Sie könnten Ihre Meinung mit Gewalt
durchsetzen Artikel 20A des
Grundgesetzes der gehört zum Grundgesetz
er ist aber mit anderen Anliegen und
Grundrechten abzuwägen das gilt auch für
die sogenannte letzte Generation die
meint unser Grundgesetz beschädigen zu
können ich finde es schade
dass gestern hier die Grundgesetz Tafeln
bewacht werden mussten durch Polizei das
war in früheren Jahren dieser
Bundesrepublik nicht so weil man für
seine politische Meinung auch nicht
symbolisch unsere Verfassung besudelt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
es lohnt sich auch über die
Verfassungswirklichkeit zu debattieren
dafür werden wir dann in den weiteren
Debatten Gelegenheit haben dieses
Grundgesetz ist gerade in seiner
Klarheit und Schnörkellosigkeit gut es
betont die Rolle von Parlamenten und
Parteien auch etwas was heute nicht von
allen geachtet und für
selbstverständlich gesehen wird es setzt
übrigens die Freiheit ganz hoch und es
sieht vor dass die Freiheit
eingeschränkt werden kann aber dass das
immer gerechtfertigt werden muss wir
fallen Demokraten wir finden auch das
gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhalt und auch
eine emotionale Beziehung zum eigenen
Land und zu dieser wunderbaren Liberalen
Verfassung wichtig ist und deshalb lohnt
die Debatte in einem einzigen Punkt kann
ich Ihnen aber gleich eine Absage
erteilen für eine allgemeine
Dienstpflicht sind wir nicht zu haben
unser Grundgesetz gibt uns den Auftrag
ohne eine allgemeine Dienstpflicht den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt zu
organisieren und da sollte man auch
nicht schnell mit so Allgemeinplätzen
kommen wie Freiheit ist nicht grenzenlos
die Mütter und Väter des grundge setzes
haben diese Wertentscheidung zugunsten
der freien Persönlichkeitsentfaltung und
Lebensgestaltung gerade im Angesicht von
materieller Not von Wiederaufbau und der
direkten Kriegserfahrung getroffen sie
haben die Notwendigkeit einer
Wehrpflicht zur Landesverteidigung als
einzige Möglichkeit einer Dienstpflicht
vorgesehen und das sollte uns zu denken
geben dass nicht heute auf Kosten der
jungen Generationen als billige
profilierungsmöglichkeit vorzusehen
vielen Dank
lindert heute Berg war das nächster
Redner ist Philipp Amthor er ist der
fachsprecher seiner Fraktion für
Staatsorganisation und
Staatsmodernisierung
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von dem sehr gelungenen Beitrag
von Kollegin Teuteberg mal abgesehen es
ist doch eigentlich schon traurig dass
es uns hier in dieser Debatte nicht
wirklich gelingt sachlich darüber zu
diskutieren wie wir unser
verfassungsjubiläum besser angehen
könnten sachlich darüber zu diskutieren
wie wir den Patriotismus aus der Mitte
unserer Gesellschaft stärken denn ich
finde unser Grundgesetz hat Angesicht
seines gestrigen geburtstags mehr
verdient als beißreflexe von links und
rechts liebe Kollegen und Kollegen ich
sag das ausdrücklich wir reichen mit
diesem Antrag konstruktiv die Hand und
ich hoffe dass sie diese Hand auch
aufnehmen denn ich finde es ist objektiv
schon bedrückend eigentlich wenn man
sich vor Augen führt wie wenig feierlich
wie trostlos und wie ohne größere
Debatte das gestrige verfassungsjubiläum
begangen wurde wir finden es müsste doch
ein parteiübergreifendes Anliegen sein
dass sich das spätestens zum nächsten
Jahr zum 75 Jubiläum der Verkündung des
Grundgesetzes ändert da braucht es
gemeinschaftliche Anstrengungen aus dem
gesamten Parlament liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir haben Vorschläge dazu
gemacht lieber Herr Kollege erlauben sie
eine Zwischenfrage aus der Fraktion DIE
LINKE gerne
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin und vielen
Dank Herr amthuer dass sie die
Zwischenfrage zulassen bei so viel
patriotischen Gefühlen können wir
natürlich sicher ganz viele profunde
Kenntnisse auch über Deutschland wo die
deutsche Geschichte voraussetzen kurze
Frage wissen Sie genau was am 30 januar
1933 war
ja sie spielen jetzt an auf einen
geschichtsquiz wozu der Kollegin Emilia
fester jetzt schon einiges gesagt wurde
ich sag ihm meinen Rede Manuskript
enthält hier keine bismarckpunkten wenn
sie vielleicht nicht nur einen
Ausschnitt in ihrer Linken Twitter
Bubble gesehen haben sondern den
gesamten Beitrag haben sie gesehen dass
ich in diesem geschichtsquiz die Macht
Ergreifung der Nationalsozialisten
benannt habe und dieses geschichts bis
mit voller Punktzahl abgeschlossen habe
ich glaube aber übrigens das ist in
diesem Land dringende Probleme gibt als
Geschichtskenntnisse und Geschichte und
das ist unser Stichwort denn in diesem
Land gibt es natürlich auch noch
drängende Probleme und diese Probleme
und vielleicht auch Lösungsvorschläge
werden Ihnen gleich die Kollegen von der
Tag erläutern morgen sind wir ab 8:45
Uhr natürlich wieder live aus dem
Bundestag Lisabeth 49 die Bundesrepublik
sei früher dran gewissen irgendwann 48
vielleicht das ist die Peinlichkeit
gucken Sie sich das lieber in Gänze an
sie hier so eine schlechten Versuche
machen Frau Kollege so aber
es ist tatsächlich so dass wir finden
das ist ein parteiübergreifend ernst zu
nehmen des Anliegen wir haben Vorschläge
gemacht Tag des Grundgesetzes als
nationaler Gedenktag eine Rede zur Lage
der Nationen und ein Bundesprogramm
Patriotismus denn wir finden nicht nur
für ein verfassungsjubiläum sondern
ganzjährig braucht es ein Bekenntnis zu
schwarz rot gold und ich sage das gerade
weil hier Ostdeutschland angesprochen
wurde die Wiedervereinigung die schwarz
rot goldenen Fahnen dieser schwarz rot
goldene Glücksmoment der Freiheit Mut
der ostdeutschen das ist eines der
größten patriotischen Glücksmomente den
wir in unserer Geschichte erlebt haben
und darauf sind wir auch stolz liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und es ist
nicht das Problem der ostdeutschen
sondern es ist ein Problem dass hier
Teile der Gesellschaft in Ausgrenzung
gleich hinter jeder Deutschlandfahne in
Ostdeutschland Nationalismus sehen dem
treten wir klar entgegen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir wollen
stolz sein auf unser Land und ich finde
es enttäuschend dass es hier nicht
gelingt klar zu sein dass wir den
Patriotismus doch gerade nicht
denjenigen überlassen dürfen die
Patriotismus und Nationalismus nicht zu
unterscheiden wissen wir müssen ihn aus
der Mitte der Gesellschaft und aus der
Mitte des Parlaments für die Mitte des
Parlaments und für die Mitte der
Gesellschaft verteidigen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und ich sage
deutlich in Richtung der AFD sie sind
ganz sicher nicht die Verteidiger des
Patriotismus denn ich sage Ihnen
Patriotismus setzt voraus dass man ein
positives Bild hat von der Gesellschaft
und von dem Staat dass man staatliche
Institutionen unterstützt zu Ihnen steht
und sie nicht delegitimiert und ich sage
Ihnen deutscher patriotismus ist nur
denkbar in einer klaren Abgrenzung zum
Nationalsozialismus der ihm kein
Vogelschiss der Geschichte war Liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und ich sag
ihnen auch ihre Kumpels die dann
irgendwie im höchsten unpatriotischen
Maße in Botschaften von Diktatoren
feiern die unser Land mit Nuklearwaffen
bedrohen das ist unparteiotisch liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und man muss
sich das noch mal vor Augen führen ihr
afd-sprecher hat einmal den Satz geprägt
die schlechter als Deutschland geht
desto besser für die AFD und
patriotischer geht es nicht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und es zeigt
die afd-anhänger die verwechseln
Vaterlands Liebe oft damit dass sie
eigentlich nur für eine kleine schräge
Gruppe reden und nicht für die ganze
Republik mein Patriotismus beinhaltet
auch einen Schutz derjenigen Meinungen
die diametral mit der Union z.B nicht
übereinstimmen das ist das Vermächtnis
unseres Grundgesetzes liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich sage Ihnen aber auch
es ist unsere gesamte gesellschaftliche
Verantwortung uns nicht im Diktum
anzuschließen dass beispielsweise die
Grüne Jugend prägt diese
Zwischenfrage aus der Fraktion ja
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin vielen Dank
auch Herr Amthor für das Zulassen der
Zwischenfrage sie haben gerade so
positiv von der schwarz-rot-goldenen
Fahne gesprochen wie kann es da sein
dass sie CDU 16 Jahre einer Kanzlerin
gedient hat die einen größer die Fahne
aus der Hand gerissen hat und
weggeschmissen hat wie kann es sein sie
wollen den Zusammenhalt der Gesellschaft
fördern
laut einer leibniz-studie für
europäische Wirtschaftsforschung
zwischen 2006 ist die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland um sechs Plätze abgerutscht
im internationalen Vergleich von 21
Nationen ist das der Zusammenhalt den
Sie sich wünschen für diese Gesellschaft
Herr am Tor das frage ich Sie also Herr
Kollege ich finde das ist schon
reichlich klein dass sie beim Thema
Patriotismus an nichts anderes denken
als diese Szene und es freut mich ja
dass sie sich so sehr um das Wohlergehen
von Deutschland fahren bei Wahlsiegen
der CDU Sorgen ich kann Ihnen sagen
woran das lag das lag an einer
Eigenschaft die Angela Merkel ausgemacht
hat nämlich nicht zu Hochmut und
übermorgendem feiern da ging es nicht um
die Deutschlandfahne sondern da ging es
darum dass sie diesen Wahlsieg den sie
verdient aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft
herum hat nicht übermorgen feiern wollte
das hat nichts damit zu tun dass man
etwas gegen Deutschland hat sondern das
hat damit zu tun dass Angela Merkel
natürlich ein selbstbewussten
vernünftigen Patriotismus immer an den
Tag gelegt hat und ich will ihnen eines
sagen diese Frau hat Dinge für
Deutschland erreicht davon können Sie
alle nur jahrelang Träumen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen denn der
Zusammenhalt der Gesellschaft der ist
auch wichtig und da sage ich aber die
letzte Gedanken den letzten Gedanken an
dieser Stelle auch noch mal in Richtung
der Ampel es muss schon auch darum gehen
dass wir klar sind dass wir nicht
Patriotismus und Nationalismus aus
unserer Sicht unnötig vermengen denn es
ist schon richtig wir müssen sagen der
patri unsismus Nationalismus
Rechtsextremismus gleich setzt der
verengt unnötig richtige
meinungskorredore die es braucht denn
Patriotismus schwarz rot gold das steht
für uns nicht für Diskriminierung nicht
für Ausgrenzung es steht für einigkeit
und Recht und Freiheit
und in diesem Sinne sagen wir ja zu
Deutschland und wünschen uns dass Sie
diese konstruktive Diskussion aufnehmen
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
und zu einer kurzinterventionelle ich
das Wort Petra Sitte
danke Frau Präsidentin dass sich das
noch sagen kann und an Herrn Amthor
richten kann also wir wollen das
Grundgesetz demokratisch leben sie
wollen es offenkundig eher patriotisch
Leben 16 Jahre lang haben wir hier im
Bundestag immer wieder lassen Sie mich
da einfach mal ausreden haben wir hier
immer wieder darum kämpfen müssen dass
das Programm Demokratie leben vernünftig
ausgestattet wird 16 Jahre lang haben
sie versucht mit ihren Innenministern
genau dieses Programm mit ihrer
Bundesregierung immer wieder einzukürzen
dort beginnt für mich die Pflege des
Grundgesetzes das Leben des
Grundgesetzes nicht mit einem
Patriotismus der hier sozusagen mit nur
Überschrift daherkommt
sie haben die Möglichkeit zu antworten
[Applaus]
Frau Kollegin ich finde das ist genau
das Problem dass ich beschrieben habe es
bringt uns doch nicht sondern macht das
Geschäft dieser Truppe wenn wir einen
Widerspruch erzeugen zwischen Demokratie
und Patriotismus wir stehen für ein
Patriotismus ein der unsere
demokratischen Werte und die Werte
unserer Verfassung hochhält und da gibt
es den Widerspruch den sie konstruiert
haben ganz sicher nicht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und ich will
Ihnen auch sagen wenn sie Demokratie
leben ansprechen in absoluter Klarheit
wir haben uns über viele Jahre auch in
der cdu/csu geführten Bundesregierung
natürlich eingesetzt für politische
Bildung für demokratiebildung aber da
muss auch klar sein politische Bildung
kann man nicht so definieren wie sie es
gerne hätten den teilweise fehlende
Abgrenzung zu Antifa Linksextremismus
und Co politische Bildung braucht einen
360 Grad blicken Extremismus darauf
haben wir immer wert gelegt und dabei
werden wir auch klar weiter Flagge
zeigen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
[Applaus]
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
hell gelehnt
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Verfassungs Patriotismus ohne
nationalpatrizismus ist keineswegs
fragwürdig zutiefst fragwürdig und
elitem ist aber
Nationalismus ohne Verfassungs
Artan
fatal ist mir das lumpenpackt das um die
Herzen zu rühren den Patriotismus trägt
zur schaue mit allen seinen Geschwüren
Heine ein Wintermärchen und recht hatte
er und deshalb ist es in der Tat auch
wichtig und völlig berechtigt heute auch
dank dieses Antrages über
verfassungspaketismus zu sprechen mir
scheint aber der Ansatz der Union zu
sein dass sie irgendein
emotionalen kampflösen will man löst
aber einen vermeintlichen Kampf nicht
durch neuen Krampf
und das Bundesbahnen
und im übrigen war aller Berechtigung
der Debatte über einen Gedenktag ist es
denke ich wichtiger das Grundgesetz
tagtäglich zu feiern und auch zu fordern
sie sprechen
von
häufigerer Beflaggung vom singenden
Nationalhymne sie wollen auch wie es dem
Antrag entnehme die politische Bildung
künftig für wünschenswerten Patriotismus
in Dienst
mein Bild unser Bild von Schwarz und
Gold ist glaube ich ein anderes
nächste Woche hat sich zum 30 Mal der
Brandanschlag von Solingen und die AFD
lacht was zeigt dass Faschisten in
diesem Haus sitzen die auch noch
offensichtlich vaterisieren mit den
Mördern von Solingen
dort verlor
Mensch zwei Kinder zwei Enkel und eine
Nichte
und sie sagte dann im Prozess
sie als
Opfer die so viele verloren hat wir sind
alle Brüder
und es ist nicht möglich so macht die
deutlich durch Verbrennen und durch
kaputt machen das zu verhindern und zwei
Jahre nach dem Brandanschlag wurde sie
deutsche Staatsangehörige
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
für mich Ausdruck von Verfassungs
Patriotismus und Ausdruck unseres
Grundgesetzes sie hat mit dieser gerade
zu übermenschlichen Geste die aber
zutiefst Menschlichkeit und würde das
was unser Grundgesetz und das was auch
die letzte Möglichkeit des Stolzes in
diesem Land nach der Schule ausmacht das
hat sie ausgedrückt viel mehr als jede
Form eines Bundesprogramms von
Patriotismus warum also wenn Sie
verfassungspatronismus wollen warum
unterstützen sie nicht Menschen in ihrer
selbst Ermächtigung in ihrer
Emanzipation anstatt sie zu belehren
Stichwort Bürgergeld Debatte und warum
ermöglichen sie sich endlich auch mit
ihrem stimmen dass diejenigen die dieses
Land bis zur Erschöpfung mit aufgebaut
haben die doppelte Staatsangehörigkeit
endlich wie selbstständig bekommen
können warum
warum fordern Sie diese Ritualen Symbole
ein sprechen aber nicht darüber dass
trotz dieses Grundgesetzes durch § 175
bis 1994 systematisch auch in diesem
Land Homosexuelle diskriminiert worden
nein nicht ein Raum der dicht beflagt
ist mit schwarz rot gold und durchflutet
ist von Nationalhymnen die im übrigen
sie als Umsetzung des Klangs im Sinne
der Freiheit unserer Nation bezeichnen
aber dafür vergessen dass zu dieser
Nation immer jüdische Deutsche gehören
wir tragen müssen das Hoffmann von
Fallersleben Zeit seines Lebens als
Verfasser des Deutschlandliedes
antisemitisch geschrieben hat das ist
Teil der Wahrheit und gehört auch zu
dieser Nationalhymne ob Sie sagen wollen
oder nicht nein wir wollen keinen
dichten national Befragten Raum auch
nicht ein Hündinnen durchfluteten
sondern der Raum von schwarz rot gold
der Verfassung der Würde des Menschen
ist der den sie auftun Mensch und Heine
nichts anderes vielen Dank
fürs 90 die Grünen hat das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen der Tag des Grundgesetzes
ist Anlass zum Feiern das Grundgesetz
ist das Fundament für unser
Zusammenleben und unsere Demokratie es
ist der politische Kompass und steht für
Freiheit Gleichheit würde Frieden und
für Gerechtigkeit und zwar für alle
Menschen in Deutschland die Würde des
Menschen ist unantastbar dieser Satz
kann nicht oft genug wiederholt werden
die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar
das Grundgesetz zeichnet sich bis heute
darin aus dass wir mit unseren
gesellschaftlichen
Entwicklungsschritt hält Verfassung
dürfen nicht da sein das Grundgesetz
darf nicht da sein es muss so lebendig
sein wie unsere Demokratie und wie
unsere vielfältige Gesellschaft da ist
es doch sehr passend dass der 23 mai
nicht nur Tag des Grundgesetzes ist
sondern zugleich auch Tag der Vielfalt
an diesem Tag gilt es beides zu
verbinden unsere vielfältige
Gesellschaft zu feiern und durch das
Grundgesetz zu schützen denn Deutschland
ist eine Gesellschaft der vielen
und deshalb liebe Union ist es wichtig
Vielfalt als verbindendes Band oder
Glied zu stärken das Grundgesetz muss so
ausgestaltet sein dass es vor
diskriminierungs schützt und
Gleichberechtigung und Diversität stärkt
und dennoch
der Begriff Rasse steht immer noch im
Grundgesetz obwohl der Begriff
historisch schwer belastet ist und
wissenschaftlich längst bewiesen dass es
keine menschlichen Rassen gibt
der Artikel 3 sagt niemand darf wegen
seiner Rasse benachteiligt oder
bevorzugt werden diese Formulierung
führt zu einem Widerspruch Betroffene
sind gezwungen sich im Falle
rassistischer Diskriminierung auf diese
rassistische Terminologie zu berufen in
der Debatte geht es dabei mit nicht nur
um eine sprachliche Feinheit die
Verwendung dieses Begriffes irritierend
veraltet und für viele Betroffene
verletzend
wir brauchen einen Perspektivwechsel
Liebe Union Rassismus lässt sich nicht
glaubwürdig bekämpfen wenn der Begriff
Rasse beibehalten wird
doch das ist nicht alles alle die das
Grundgesetz lesen sollen sich auch darin
wiederfinden damit das geschieht müssen
wir den Artikel 3 und das Verbot der
Diskriminierung aufgrund von sexueller
Identität ergänzen und wir müssen die
Kinderrechte endlich verankern
der Tag des Grundgesetzes ist ein Anlass
zum Feiern er mahnt uns aber auch zu
Veränderungen und Entwicklung das
Grundgesetz darf nicht erstarren wir
dürfen nicht erstarren vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und der nächste Redner ist Matthias
Helferich
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
grundsätzlich erfreut es mich liebe
Union dass sie sich vorsichtig an den
Patriotismus heranwagen auch ich bin der
festen Überzeugung Herr Amthor dass man
die Vaterlandsliebe nicht den Rändern
überlassen darf auffällig ist jedoch
dass ich an keiner Stelle in ihrem
Antrag das Wort Volk findet sie sprechen
immer zu von Gemeinschaft Gesellschaft
und Menschen doch was ist eigentlich
eine Verfassung sie ist der ordnungsraum
den sich ein Volk gibt und dieses Volk
er wächst wenn es nicht staatlich
verfasst ist mit den Worten des
Staatsrecht das Deborah ich zitiere aus
einer geschichtlich gewachsenen
substanziellen Gemeinsamkeit einer
Gruppe von Menschen sie findet ihren
Grund in der subjektiv unverfügbaren
Vergangenheit aus gemeinsamer Geschichte
schicksalssprache Kultur wächst so dann
solidarische Verbundenheit spätestens
seit ihrem willkommensbot haben sie im
eigenen Volk den Kampf angesagt und
überziehen all jene in diesem Land mit
staatlicher Repression die sich dem
Erhalt des gewachsenen Volkes
verschrieben haben ihr Verfassungsschutz
schwächt dabei selbst wie kein anderer
in unserem Land unsere freiheitliche
Verfassung ein Patriotismus der sich
ausschließlich in einem abstrakten
verfassungswerk erschöpft das und die
letzte Redner Debatte ist für die
SPD-Fraktion Simulators
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren gestern haben
wir den Tag des Grundgesetzes gefeiert
er ist ein nationaler Gedenktag und
erinnert an die Grundlagen unserer
Demokratie das Grundgesetz selbst ist
ein Erfolgsmodell es ist aber nicht ohne
historischen Hintergrund denkbar die
Lehren aus der Weimarer Republik die
Notwendigkeit einer wehrhaften
Demokratie der Antifaschismus und die
Präambel die eine Vereinigung der beiden
deutschen Staaten immer fest im Blick
hatte belegen dies deutlich das
Grundgesetz hat sich im
Vereinigungsprozess durchgesetzt gegen
den Verfassungsentwurf des Runden
Tisches in der DDR und es bleibt in
Arbeit künstliche Intelligenz und
Klimawandel verändern unsere
Gesellschaft so stark dass wir das
Grundgesetz stetig weiterentwickeln
müssen dafür gibt es viele kluge
Vorschläge
dieses Grundgesetz meine Damen und
Herren kann nicht oft genug gefeiert
werden das haben wir ja schon einige
Male gehört am besten jeden Tag die
Geschichte unseres Landes ist aber nicht
nur in unsere Verfassung eingeschrieben
die nicht umsonst Grundgesetz heißt nein
sie zeigt sich auch in unserer
Nationalhymne die erste Strophe ist aus
gutem Grund verboten die Flagge weckt
nicht nur bei mir ambivalente Gefühle
seitdem sie kurz nach der Wende von
rechtsextrem bei Überfällen auf
Asylbewerber missbraucht wurde bis heute
schauen unsere Nachbarländer aber auch
Nachkommen der Verfolgten des
Naziregimes misstrauisch auf deutschen
Patriotismus
vor dem Hintergrund dass unser
politisches System täglich von rechts in
Frage gestellt wird ist das sicher nicht
unbegründet unsere Geschichte ist
gebrochen sie lässt sich nicht zu
kleistern mit patriotischen Gefühlen
meine erfahrung ist wenn man für etwas
brennt dann verteidigt man es aus ganzem
eigenem Antrieb ganz ohne
Bundestagsbeschluss
fragen Sie doch mal die Ostdeutschen wir
erinnern uns genau an die fahnenabfälle
zum ersten Mal mussten wir die Flagge
vom Balkon hängen aber das hat nicht
jeden von der DDR überzeugt so meine
Damen und Herren läuft das nicht
verstehen Sie mich nicht falsch jeder
soll singen und Flagge zeigen so viel
sie oder er mag solange das freiwillig
ist und mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbar
ist aber viel wichtiger ist es doch dass
wir für unser Grundgesetz und für unsere
Demokratie werden und das wäre
Verfassungsfeinde wirksam bekämpfen wir
alle zusammen auf dem Boden des
Grundgesetzes vielen Dank
und damit schließe ich die Aussprache in
der fraktionell wird die Überweisung der
Vorlage auf der Drucksache 69 03 an die
in der Tagesordnung aufgeführten
Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen ich sehe keine
weiteren überweisungsvorschläge dann
verfahren wir
so und ich rufe nun auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt 6a und 6b die erste
Beratung ist von der Bundesregierung
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf so bekämpfe
von Lieferengpässen bei patentfreien
Arzneimitteln und zu Verbesserung der
Versorgung mit
kinderarztneimitteln sowie der Beratung
des Antrags der Fraktion Die Linke mit
dem Titel Engpässe bei Arzneimitteln
wirksam bekämpfen für die Aussprache ist
hier eine Dauer von 39 Minuten
vereinbart ich bitte Sie entsprechend
die Plätze einzunehmen
und ich
eröffne die Aussprache
und ich erteile das Wort für die
Bundesregierung den Bundesminister für
Gesundheit dr Karl Lauterbach
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Kollegen und Kollegen wir beraten heute
erneut ein wichtiges Gesetz in der
Gesundheitsversorgung ein Gesetz was
sich wie folgt zusammenfassen lässt das
Problem ist schon lange bekannt aber wir
haben zu lange gewartet um eine Lösung
herbeizuführen wir sind konfrontiert mit
Lieferengpässen für mittlerweile mehr
als 450 Arzneimittel und dieser
Arzneimittel sind nicht nur Arzneimittel
wo es nicht darauf ankommt ob ich dieser
sozialmittel bekomme oder eine
Alternative sondern sind auch oft
Arzneimittel für die ist keine
gleichwertige Alternative gibt es können
sogar Arzneimittel sein die die
Krebsbehandlung betreffen oder andere
schwere chronische Erkrankungen dass er
nicht akzeptabler Zustand den wir viel
zu lange haben gewähren lassen hier gibt
es im wesentlichen drei Gründe die man
unterteilen kann zum einen wir haben in
der Nachfolge der Pandemie haben wir
einen also ausgesprochen schweren Befall
und Kindern aber Erwachsenen mit also
Infektionskrankheiten
sehen müssen die nachgeholt werden das
hat also die Antibiotika
die Antibiotika Versorgung
fast unmöglich gemacht weil in der
Pandemie ist weniger produziert worden
es gab weniger Vorrat und dann ist mehr
abverhandelt worden abgebaut worden und
daher haben wir dort an Engpass der mit
der Pandemie zusammen mit wir haben aber
darüber hinaus auch in der Pandemie
Lieferketten verloren die nicht da sind
und zum dritten wir haben ein System
Problem viele generische Arzneimittel
sind in Deutschland durch die
Rabattverträge und andere
preismotoren die waren Platz haben so
billig im Markt dass sie wenn ein
Engpass kommt in Deutschland zuerst
nicht mehr verfügbar sind war dort wo
der Preis der niedrigste ist dort wird
man zuerst nicht mehr beliefert das ist
das Problem wir wollen dieses Problem in
drei Stufen angehen die wichtigste Stufe
ist die langfristige Stufe wir müssen
einen Teil der Produktion wieder nach
Europa zurückholen es wird langfristig
nicht möglich sein weil wichtigen
Generika
allein auflieferungen aus Asien oder aus
anderen Ländern also angewiesen zu sein
das heißt eine Rückführung der
Produktion nach Europa sondern ganz
wichtiges Ziel damit beginnen wir bei
den Antibiotika
und das ist die ursächliche Therapie
damit beginnen wir bei den Antibiotika
dort werden dann die Ausschabung die es
gibt so verknüpft dass es eine
europäisches losgeht muss und ein
ausseroperisches los wenn das dann
eingespielt ist wenn wir das Ausdehnen
für andere Bereich das kann über den
Verordnungsweg geschehen und wir planen
das dann auch bei den onkologika zum
Beispiel anzuführen so dass wir einen
rollierendes System bekommen zum zweiten
wir brauchen eine bessere Früherkennung
und da werden wir mit dem B fahren
zusammen die Früherkennung noch
verstärken wir werden auf die
Arzneimittelfirmen verpflichten uns
präziser und früher drohende
Lieferengpässe mitzuteilen so dass wir
entsprechende Gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen
können und zum dritten das ist sehr
bedeutsam wir werden einfach die
Lagerhaltung verbessern drei Monate
Lagerhaltung ist für die Maßen
Arzneimittel die hier angesprochen
werden ist das eine Lagerhaltung mit der
man einen Lieferengpass auch langfristig
umgehen kann weil in der Regel die
Lieferengpässe nicht über eine längere
Strecke gehen und wenn es dann
tatsächlich zusammengreift wir sehen den
Lieferengpass früh wir holen die aus so
Produktion zurück nach Europa und wir
haben eine lange Lagerhaltung auch
rollierend dann ist das System einfach
besser die Ökonomisierung haben wir auch
in diesem Bereich zu stark nach vorne
gebracht wir haben die Ökonomie Schraube
überdreht wenn man so will unser
Rabattverträge haben uns geholfen die
Preise zu halten das ist auch richtig
aber die Rabattverträge dürfen nicht so
funktionieren dass es einfach unmöglich
ist in Europa noch zu produzieren das
ist falsch daher werden wir auch die Art
und Weise wie Rabattverträge
funktionieren die werden nur noch einmal
überprüfen hier ist in unserem Entwurf
vorgesehen dass zum Beispiel die
Zuzahlungsbefreiung schon erreicht
werden kann wenn also der also
Festbetrag nur 20% unterschritten wird
das ist eine Richtung oder seine
Bewegung die richtige Richtung insgesamt
aus einem sehr wichtiges Gesetz wir
werden insbesondere bei Kindern
Sofortmaßnahmen ergreifen so dass bei
den Kindern tatsächlich die Festbeträge
und auch die Rabattverträge ausgesetzt
sind ein Gesetz was lange überfällig ist
lange überfällig ist und ich bin dankbar
dass wir es jetzt beraten können ich
freue mich auf eine gute Beratung und
danke Ihnen für die Unterstützung aber
auch für heute für die vorzügliche
Aufmerksamkeit
und für die Unionsfraktion hat das Wort
dr Georg kippels
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Minister Lauterbach mein
verehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja
das Problem der Lieferengpässe ist nicht
vollständig neu gestern stand der Zeiger
beim b-farm auf 493 in der Tat eine
beängstigende Zahl die sich in den
vergangenen Jahren aufgebaut hat ein
kurzer Blick zurück seit 2013 war die
engpassmeldung bei 42 2017 bei 108 und
2019 nahm die steigungsrate zu wir waren
bei 355 ja die Regelung ist überfällig
aber fährt der Minister Lauterbach sie
sind uns hier die Erklärung schuldig
geblieben warum denn erst jetzt im Mai
2023 denn schon
im Spätsommer des letzten Jahres haben
alle Fachleute insbesondere aus der
Wissenschaft aufgrund der medizinischen
Entwicklungen aus der Pandemie heraus
ganz deutlich angekündigt dass mit einem
sehr harten Herbst im Hinblick auf
Infektionserkrankungen gerade auch bei
Jugendlichen gerechnet werden muss und
dringend empfohlen wurde diesbezüglich
vorausschauend tätig zu werden geschehen
ist nichts wir haben seitens der CDU
CSU-Fraktion hartnäckig darum geworden
einen pharmakipfel
einzuberufen mit dem dann unter
Austausch der fachkundigen tatsächlich
ein Lösungskonzept entwickelt wird
werden könnte weil entgegen ihrer
persönlichen Meinung oder der Meinung
des Hauses allein nur das Drehen an der
rabattschraube diesen hochkomplexen
Produktionsprozess nicht wird lösen
können
vom Einkaufen des Wirkstoffs bis
letztendlich der Herstellung des
Arzneimittels Vergehen sechs bis acht
Monate und insofern müssen diese
Vorlaufzeiten nicht nur ökonomisch
sondern auch produktionstechnisch
berücksichtigt werden also insofern sind
wir leider erneut und das geht eindeutig
in die ihrer fahr liegt in Ihrer
Verantwortung hinter der Zeit und wir
müssen jetzt alle Kräfte bündeln um die
richtigen Konzepte zu lösen leider auch
ein weiterer Fehlschlag das
gkv-finanzstabilisierungsgesetz im
letzten Herbst ein falsches Signal in
Richtung der forschenden Pharmaindustrie
wo deutlich wurde dass Innovationskraft
in Deutschland nicht belohnt würden das
muss als Gesamtkonzept betrachtet und
bewertet werden und wenn wir uns auf die
Suche
nach Lösungsansätzen begeben dann muss
ich in ihrem Vortrag eben feststellen wo
sind denn die Apotheker wo sind die
Kämpferinnen und Kämpfer an der Theke
zwischen den Herstellern und den
Patienten und Patienten die mit aller
Kraft versuchen den nach Medikamenten
Fragenden erkrankten oder chronisch
Erkrankten eine Lösung zu bieten und die
von morgens bis abends damit beschäftigt
sind entsprechende Ersatzbeschaffungen
zu generieren oder durch entsprechende
andere Ausgabeformate den Bedarf zu
befriedigen 50 Cent
wollen sie ihnen zugestehen und ich kann
an dieser Stelle nur dringend empfehlen
mal einen Blick in den
bundesratsbeschluss vom 12.5 zu werfen
da steht unter Buchstabe g auf Seite 16
Frau präsidente nicht statt dem mir zu
zitieren die geplante
Aufwandsentschädigung für Apotheken in
Höhe von 50 € zuzüglich Umsatzsteuer
deckt die zusätzlichen Kosten der
Apotheken nicht der Bundesrat forderte
einen weiteren Gesetzgebungsverfahren
diesen Betrag Fakten und evidenzbasiert
anzuheben um den zusätzlichen
Arbeitsaufwand für Apotheken realistisch
zu kompensieren diesem Arbeitsauftrag
ist nichts hinzuzufügen der nur durch
den wirklich unermüdlichen und geradezu
heroischen Einsatz der Apothekerinnen
Apotheker funktioniert das System der
Versorgung jetzt noch im Interesse
unserer Menschen draußen in unserer
Bundesrepublik und deshalb kann ich
Ihnen nur dringend empfehlen nehmen Sie
sich den Beschluss des Bundesrates zu
Herzen fragen Sie diejenigen die von
morgens bis abends mit
Produktionskonzepten und
Produktionsabläufen beschäftigt sind und
dann kann aus einem solchen Versuch
eines Gesetzes vielleicht noch ein gutes
Gesetz werden finanziell für die
Aufmerksamkeit
und verbindest 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort dr Paula piechotta
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
ZuschauerInnen niemand hier verspricht
es unmögliche also was man wirklich
diesen Ministerium mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf nicht vorwerfen kann ist
dass es besonders priertauglich oder
besonders viele Versprechungen hier
machen würde das ist nicht das Gute
Pillen aus Deutschland ab jetzt ist
alles sorglos gesetzt das ist das Alb
VVG und genauso Behörden Deutsch und
genauso spröde und genauso kompliziert
wie der Sachverhalt ist ist auch dieses
Gesetz und das ist okay so die
veränderte weltpolitische Lage aber auch
die Lehren aus der corona-pandemie was
die Arzneimittel Lieferengpässe angehen
die müssen hier alle mitverarbeitet
werden das ist eine Norma Kraftakt der
auch in der letzten Legislatur nicht
vorgedacht wurde von der Vorgänger
Regierung und das muss alles noch
imprimiert werden in dem
Gesundheitswesen was ohnehin schon enorm
komplex ist und das alles auch noch vor
dem Hintergrund dass er parallel die
nächst höhere Ebene die Europäische
Kommission an ihrem eigenen legislativen
Paket für die Arzneimittelsicherheit
Arbeit das sind enorm komplexe
Voraussetzungen und deswegen sind die
Debatten die wir jetzt zu diesem Thema
führen auch so besonders komplex auch
mit den Akteuren im Gesundheitswesen und
Herr kippels sie haben vielleicht viel
mit Apothekerin und Apothekern
gesprochen das haben wir auch gemacht
aber es gibt noch eine ganze Zahl
weitere Akteure und von denen kommt dann
teilweise oft der Satz und der Einwand
wie kann es eigentlich sein dass wir
jetzt in der Zeitenwende realisieren das
wichtige Standortbedingungen in Europa
nicht nur im Bereich Arzneimittel
sondern zum Beispiel auch bei der
Halbleiterproduktion oder bei der
Chip-Produktion geschaffen werden müssen
aber in allen diesen Bereichen arbeiten
wir mit Steuergeldern mit großen
europäischen Programmen aber im Bereich
Arzneimittel sonst plötzlich die
Sozialversicherungen richten das ist ein
berechtigter Einwand und ich glaube an
der Stelle müssen wir auch so ehrlich
sein man wird diese
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe
Zeitenwende und die risking von China
wird man nicht alleine lösen mit den
Mitteln der GHV was die GKV aber leisten
kann was die GKV aber leisten kann was
wir gemeinsam gemeinsam mit Ihnen
hoffentlich in den nächsten Wochen
konstruktiv beraten in vertraulicher
Atmosphäre und immer mit den Patienten
im Mittelpunkt ist die Frage wo gibt es
tatsächlich in unserer GKV diese
Fehlanreize die ist vielleicht
wahrscheinlicher machen das unsichere
Lieferketten entstehen wo gibt es
tatsächlich auch Regelungen die so
gestrickt sind dass sie es besonders
schwer machen für versorgende Apotheken
oder Praxen im lieferengpassfall
tatsächlich Patienten zu versorgen und
ja wo können wir auch relativ Aufwands
und regulationsarmen zum Beispiel bei
der Bevorratung tatsächlich Abhilfe
schaffen immer in dem Bewusstsein die
GKV kann nicht alles regeln und wenn man
alles an internationalen Arzneimittel
Sicherheitsproblemen und liefern Engpass
Problem über die GKV lösen wollen würde
man würde sich verheben und diesem
Vorwurf sollte sich hier niemand
schuldig machen meine Damen und Herren
im Zentrum der parlamentarischen
Beratung wird es jetzt aber auch wichtig
sein ich habe gesagt es ist ein sehr
komplexes es ist ein sehr komplexes
System und dass wir da eingreifen die
arzneimittelvergütung in der GKV
deswegen wird es auch unglaublich
wichtig sein zu schauen welche komplexen
Folgewirkungen hat das eventuell was wir
da an Eingriffen machen und deswegen
werden wir auch darüber reden müssen
gibt es hier vielleicht Mitnahmeeffekte
die entstehen wo wir mehr Geld
ausschütten ohne das Versorgung besser
wird an welcher Stelle können wir noch
stärker digitale Lösungen einbinden
damit mehr Versorgungsengpässe nicht
mehr Aufwand für die versorgenden
bedeuten und natürlich auch wie schaffen
wir es dass wir uns nicht mit neuen
vergütungspauschalen in den
Lieferengpässen einrichten und häuslich
gemütlich machen sondern wie wir
gemeinsam Anreize schaffen dass wir mit
vereinten Kräften diese Lieferengpässe
mittel und langfristig tatsächlich
komplett überwinden das wird wichtig
sein und bei diesem Beratung wird für
uns im Mittelpunkt stehen ich habe schon
gesagt nicht derjenige Akteur der im
lautesten schreit und auch nicht der
Akteur die der die großformatigsten
Briefe an alle Abgeordneten schreibt
sondern im Zentrum unserer Überlegung
steht der Patient und ich hoffe das gilt
für Sie alle ich danke Ihnen für die
Aufmerksamkeit und freue mich auch
verantwortungsbewusste Beratungen die
nächsten Wochen
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
Jörg Schneider
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren Lieferengpässe für
Medikamenten in der Zahl ja ein
dreistelligen Bereichen die gibt es nun
schon seit vier fünf Jahren
dass die Regierung nun endlich ein
Gesetz dazu vorlegt nun besser spät als
nie ihrem hochgesetzten Ziel die Beamte
die Produktion von Arzneimitteln aus
Asien wieder zurück zu verlagern nach
Europa oder vielleicht sogar nach
Deutschland demnähren Sie sich hier aber
nur mit Triple Schritten
wir haben hier tatsächlich jetzt
Verbesserungen was beispielsweise die
Ausschreibungsbedingungen betrifft aber
die Welt hat sich noch weiter gedreht
wir haben erheblich höhere Zinsen als
noch vor einem Jahr und das ist ein
Investitionshemmnis ob dort tatsächlich
und Unternehmen bereit sein werden von
diesem Hintergrund tatsächlich ihre
Produktion nach Europa oder sogar nach
Deutschland zurück zu verlagern da bin
ich einfach skeptisch und erlauben Sie
mir bitte noch den Hinweis erhalten ist
vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher und
günstiger als neue Aufbau die
Österreicher haben es geschafft das
zumindest die letzte westeuropäische
finanzfabrik in Österreich weiter
produziert vielleicht tun sie sich da
mal ein paar Inspirationen wie man das
macht ich glaube
abwanderungsideen wie sie von BASF
entwickelt werden die sollten ihnen
eigentlich Motivation und Warnung dafür
genug sein meine Damen und Herren
Thema Warnung ist ein gutes Stichwort
sie wollen dann frühwarensystem bei
medikamentenknappheit installieren
wie muss mir das jetzt vorstellen wenn
dieses Frühjahr Warensystem anschlägt
gibt es dann Hamsterkäufe gibt es dann
über Bevorratung genau das ist nämlich
das Problem was entstehen kann und das
können sie eigentlich nur stoppen indem
sie irgendwelche
kontingentierungsmechanismen an so ein
privaten System anhängen die sind aber
nicht vorgesehen darüber hinaus wollen
Sie dieses Frühwarnsystem bei der
Bundesanstalt beim Bundesamt für
Arzneimittel und Medizinprodukte
ansiedeln die sind aber in einer solchen
Notsituation jetzt schon damit sehr gut
ausgelastet neue Medikamente zuzulassen
die eben halt die Knappen alten
Medikamente ersetzen sollen sie schaffen
hier eine Doppelbelastung auch das halte
ich nicht so geschickt
für die Apotheken da haben sie auch
einiges überlegt die
Krankenhausapotheken sollen ihre
Lagerbestände deutlich erhöhen
das ist jetzt natürlich ein regionaler
Bestand wenn ich jetzt tatsächlich eine
regionalen Engpass habe muss ich unter
Umständen Umlagerungen anstoßen ob das
an der Ebene mit diesen über mit diesen
erhöhten Lagerbeständen tatsächlich so
geschickt ist das weiß ich nicht und wir
haben natürlich ein weiteres Problem
wenn wir regional erhöhte Lagerbestände
haben dann laufen wir auch Gefahr in
Überlagerung hineinzugehen das heißt
Medikamente müssen vernichtet werden das
kostet nicht nur diese
Krankenhausapotheken viel Geld sondern
es kann natürlich in einer
Engpasssituation die ganze Situation
auch noch verschlimmern
für die Apotheker wollen sie es etwas
einfacher gestalten zukünftig
wenn ein Verschreibungspflicht ein
verschriebenes Medikament nicht
vorhanden ist dieses durch ein
verfügbares zu ersetzen
das ist eine gute Idee ich habe mir das
mal in Apotheken angeguckt das ist
Moment tatsächlich ein sehr sehr
komplizierter Prozess und wenn sie den
einfacher machen wollen dann ist es
sicherlich gut so nur das rein
technische dieses Prozesses ist ja nicht
alles stellen Sie sich vor das sind
ältere Menschen die haben sich jahrelang
an ein bestimmtes Medikament gewöhnt
selbst wenn sie den jetzt ein Wirkstoff
gleich ist ein dosierungsgleiches
Medikament geben besteht trotzdem
Beratungsbedarf da muss Vertrauen
geschaffen werden jetzt mögen sie sagen
na ja ich habe noch nie von der Apotheke
eine lange Schlange gesehen irgendwie
kriegen die Apotheker das während ihrer
Arbeitszeit doch irgendwie hin und das
ist eben halt nur bedingt richtig da
entsteht ein hoher Beratungsbedarf die
Apotheker können dadurch Tätigkeiten
administrative Tätigkeiten eben halt
nicht mehr während der Öffnungszeiten
erledigen das heißt Sie müssen diese
Arbeiten dann in ihre Freizeit in den
Abend hinein verlegen das heißt entsteht
hier nicht nur eine höhere Intensität
der Arbeitsbelastung für Apotheker
sondern tatsächlich auch eine Mehrarbeit
und ob die 50 Cent die jetzt hier im
Gesetz stehen dafür eine faire
Entlohnung sind da habe ich doch meine
Zweifel meine Damen und Herren lassen
mich zum Schluss kommen das Gesetz hat
einige gute Ansätze aber ich denke mir
wir sollten da schon noch ein paar
Punkte ändern ein paar Anregungen habe
ich gegeben ich bin gespannt was von
ihnen an anderen jungsanträgen vorgelegt
wird so wie sie das Gesetz jetzt
aussieht ist es für meine Fraktion nicht
zustimmungsfähig ich danke
für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort Lars
lindemann
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Deutschland war mal die
Apotheke der Welt und wir müssen leider
alle miteinander ansehen seit Jahren
steigt die Anzahl von Lieferengpässen
und das ganze hat sich in den letzten
drei Jahren unter der Pandemie aber eben
auch unter den Folgen dessen was der
Ukraine Krieg uns beschert durch Abriss
von Lieferketten und anderen mehr einem
traurigen Höhepunkt entgegen bewegt im
Winter 22 23 haben wir erlebt dass Herr
Kollege Lauterbach hat das schon
ausgeführt ein hohes Infektionsgeschehen
vor allem bei Kindern und Jugendlichen
wir haben aber auch gesehen dass durch
Ausfällen auf der Welt
Lieferketten abgerissen sind und an
anderer Stelle dadurch Engpässe
entstanden sind in Deutschland aber wir
haben auch
gesehen dass zum Beispiel am Beispiel
Tamoxifen kann man das gut sehen das ist
in Deutschland ein Krebs Medikament
nicht mehr gab aber den anderen
europäischen Ländern gab es das noch und
das führt dann eben zu der Frage nach
den Rahmenbedingungen in Deutschland und
mit Blick auf unser
Gesetzgebungsvorhaben kann man denke ich
dabei jetzt drei Dinge feststellen erste
Feststellung nur wenige Lösungen werden
kurzfristig wirksam sein das müssen wir
uns einfach eingestehen die Probleme
sind langfristig entstanden und wir
werden sie auch nur über einen längeren
Zeitraum Finanz haben für unsere
Entscheidung dann hierbei ist mir ganz
persönlich wichtig dass wir mehr als nur
diesen 180 Grad Blick bekommen gehen wir
im Moment haben weil wir schauen im
Moment stark darauf was in Deutschland
schon mal auf dem Markt war an
Substanzen oder Präparaten und die jetzt
eben wird entweder nicht lieferbar sind
oder dazu
Versorgungsengpässen führen wir müssen
auch schauen was durch unsere
regulatorik die wir schaffen den
deutschen Markt überhaupt nicht mehr
erreicht weil Unternehmen nicht mehr
bereit sind bestimmte Produkte in
Deutschland und das gehört eben auch zu
einer vollständigen
Informationsgrundlage und deswegen
sollten wir im Zusammenhang mit diesen
Fragestellungen auch darauf achten
zweitens
in Zeiten engerer finanzieller
Spielräume kann es natürlich nur darum
gehen dass man denjenigen von denen wir
Lösungen erwarten mehr Freiheiten gibt
mehr Beinfreiheit das heißt mehr
Flexibilisierung mehr
Entbürokratisierung
die Apotheker sind angesprochen worden
sie haben Großartiges geleistet in der
Pandemie und es ist wir haben es ja
schon einmal verlängert all diejenigen
Erleichterungen die geschaffen worden
sind im Rahmen der saß kurz zwei
Bekämpfung sollen natürlich weiter
versteht nicht werden wir stellen uns
als Fraktion dann noch ein ganz
erheblichen Schritt mehr vor wir wollen
aber auch Dinge nicht mehr sehen wie zum
Beispiel eine Null retaxation bei den
Apothekern es kann nicht sein dass
Apotheker Arzneimittel abgeben dabei
Fehler passieren und am Ende vollständig
retaxiert wird das kann sich allenfalls
auf die honoraranteile richten und nicht
auf das Arzneimittel was an den
Patienten ja wohl abgegeben worden ist
wir werden auch auf die Preisgestaltung
gucken müssen bei der Preisgestaltung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen kann es
nach meinem Dafürhalten nicht sein dass
wir die allseits bekannten Problemlagen
das eben gerade bei der Preisfindung in
Deutschland
langfristige Rahmenbedingungen
mitgestaltet werden wir bei dem bleiben
jetzt im amlok steht und was wir in den
Leitplanken zum Beispiel auch verabredet
haben das muss noch mal auf den
Prüfstand wir werden uns damit nochmal
beschäftigen müssen auch was das Thema
amlog an sich angeht und es kann auch
nicht sein wenn es um Fragen des
kombinationsrabattes geht dass der GKV
Spitzenverband das sage ich ja auch ganz
deutlich einseitig solche Dinge für sich
regelt es war guter Grund als wir in der
Legislatur zwei neun bis 13 das Amok
eingeführt haben dass wir gesagt haben
wir wollen Verhandlungen zwischen den
Beteiligten das ist unserer
Marktwirtschaft immanent und dieses
Prinzip wollen wir weiter durchgehalten
sehen grundsätzlich schauen wir auf die
Effektivität der Maßnahmen und dabei
freuen wir uns auf eine gute Beratung
mit ihnen allen hin zu stabilen
Rahmenbedingungen und wieder Apotheken
der Welt werden zu können vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat das Wort
Katrin Vogler
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Minister die Menschen in
Deutschland verlassen sich zu Recht
darauf dass wenn sie krank werden sie
gute und sichere Arzneimittel verordnet
bekommen die sie unkompliziert in der
Apotheke beziehen können aber immer
öfter wird das Vertrauen schwer auf die
Probe gestellt Lieferengpässe bei
Arzneimitteln sind nicht neu und noch
keine Bundesregierung hat dagegen eine
wirksame und nebenwirkungsarme Medizin
gefunden inzwischen arbeiten viele
Apothekerinnen einen Tag in der Woche
nur noch dafür Ersatz für fehlende
Medikamente zu finden und deswegen ist
ein Gesetz gegen Lieferengpässe absolut
überfällig doch dieses Gesetz dass die
Bundesregierung vorgelegt hat wird der
Risiken Herausforderung nicht gerecht
es sieht zwar eine
bevorratungspflicht für die Industrie
vor aber nur für Medikamente mit
Rabattverträgen was fehlt sind aber
Instrumente dieser auch durchzusetzen
und längst verpflichtet das
Arzneimittelgesetz die Unternehmen eine
angemessene und kontinuierliche
Bereitstellung der in Verkehr gebrachten
Arzneimittel sicherzustellen sie wollen
also etwas regeln Herr Lauterbach das
schon geltende Rechtslage ist ohne es
wirklich durchsetzen zu können so bleibt
auch diese neue Pflicht zahnlos und wir
kritisieren ja schon lange
dass die Rabattverträge deren
ideologische Grundlagen im Wesentlichen
auch sie mitgelegt haben die
Arzneimittelversorgung gefährden sie
verstärken die Konzentrationsprozesse
und damit die Abhängigkeit von einzelnen
Lieferanten und das hat die
Bundesregierung zwar erkannt trotzdem
schafft sie die Rabattverträge nur für
Kinder Medikamente ab als ob nicht auch
Erwachsene zuverlässige Medizin brauchen
ja Vorräte sollen sich auch die
Krankenhausapotheken anlegen wenn die
Industrie ausreichend Vorräte aller
wichtigen Medikamente bereithalten
müsste dann wäre das doch völlig unnötig
offenbar trauen sie selbst ihrem eigenen
Gesetz nicht zu dass es wird die
Apotheken
wir sollen jetzt dafür vergütet werden
patient:innen bei Lieferschwierigkeiten
mit anderen Mitteln zu versorgen mit 50
Cent pro ausgetauschtem Medikament das
deckt den Arbeitsaufwand in der Apotheke
nicht annähernd ab dafür kriegen sie
aller höchstens 90 Sekunden
Arbeitszeit einer
apothekenmitarbeiterin in der aller
niedrigsten Gehaltsstufe naja gut
immerhin zeigt die Bundesregierung einen
guten Willen nur von gutem Willen kann
keine Apothekerin ihre Beschäftigten
bezahlen und die Linke
DIE LINKE fordert die komplette
Ersetzung der Rabattverträge durch eine
Festbetragsregelung und eine 5-monatige
vorratspflicht für wichtige Arzneimittel
durch die Unternehmen Unternehmen die im
Sicherstellungsauftrag nicht nachkommen
müssen sagen zu mir werden wir brauchen
ein lieferengpass-gesetz mit bis und
keinen zahnlosen Tiger
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
die Kollegin Martina stammt Fiebig
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
wir haben an dieser Stelle bereits im
Januar über das Thema Arzneimittel
Lieferengpässe diskutiert und auslöser
für diese Diskussion war ein Antrag der
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus der
Unionsfraktion und Herr Dr kippels wenn
ich richtig zugehört habe dann war ja
dann sogar ihr Antrag zu spät wenn man
es denn letztes Jahr schon gewusst hätte
was alles auf uns zukommt
und leider enthielt dieser Antrag auch
nur wenig sinnvolle Lösungsansätze und
ich hatte damals schon angemahnt wir
brauchen keine beschaffungsgipfel die
hatten wir übrigens schon vor Jahren was
ist denn wirklich dabei rausgekommen und
andere Gesprächsrunde bayerischer
brauchen wir nicht sondern echte
Lösungen der bestehenden Probleme
und diesem Aufruf liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen kommt die Ampel heute mit dem
vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf nun nach und
anstatt zu reden handeln wir den Fakt
ist und es ist wahr zur Zeit gibt es
eine bedenklich hohe Anzahl an
Arzneimitteln die in der Apotheke nicht
erhältlich sind und die Gründe dafür
sind vielfältig
sie reichen von lieferkettenabressen
über den Ausfall von Produktionsstätten
bis hin zu langfristigen Trends auf dem
globalen Arzneimittelmarkt die eine
Konzentration auf wenige Hersteller
begünstigen und gerade weil das Thema so
komplex ist gibt es auch nicht die eine
Lösung für alle Probleme
aus diesem Grund haben wir uns an einen
ganzen Strauß von Maßnahmen überlegt die
jeweils unterschiedliche Aspekte des
Problems angehen und insgesamt und so
hoffen wir alle zu einer Lösung des
Problems beitragen die Maßnahmen der
strecken sich im mäßigen Wesentlichen
auf die fünf Bereiche Bevorratung
Erstattung
versorgungssteuerung Meldepflichten und
engpass-management in der Apotheke die
neuen bevorratungspflichten für die
Industrie und für die
Krankenhausapotheken geben uns in
Zukunft hoffentlich den Spielraum um die
auftretenden Lieferengpässe zu umgehen
und weil es einen Puffer gibt führen
Produktionsprobleme nicht mehr sofort zu
Lieferengpässen in der Apotheke
durch die Erhöhung der Preise bei den
kinderarztwahlmitteln und einigen
anderen Wirkstoffen sorgen wir dafür
dass der ökonomische Druck reduziert
wird und nicht zu einer weiteren
Verringerung der herstelleranzahl kommt
und durch die Aufwertung des Beirats für
lieferengresse beim Bundesinstitut für
Arzneimittel und Medizinprodukte
schaffen wir zudem die Möglichkeit auch
untergesetzlich schnell auf bestimmte
Veränderungen im Markt zu reagieren im
Rahmen der Ausschreibung für
Rabattverträge sollten wir für die
Einführung von eu-losen dafür dass der
Produktionsstandort Europa gestärkt wird
die Krankenkassen
müssen zukünftig mindestens die Hälfte
der ausgeschriebenen Rabattvertrag als
mal aus dem europäischen Wirtschaftsraum
beziehen und diese Maßnahme ist wichtig
denn sie ist ein starkes Signal an die
europäischen Hersteller und damit zeigen
wir Deutschland positive positioniert
sich als langfristiger Partner auf von
der europäischen Arzneimittelindustrie
auch und das wissen wir auch wenn es
teurer wird
ein wichtiger Baustein dieses Gesetzes
ist die Verschärfung der Ausweitung der
Meldepflichten durch die Hersteller und
dieser Punkt ist mir persönlich wichtig
weil ich davon überzeugt bin dass wir
die Lage nur dann beherrschen können
wenn wir genügend gute Daten für ein
Frühwarnsystem haben und schlussendlich
werden wir mit diesem Gesetz den
Apothekern unter die Arme greifen ja wir
tun es und dafür werden wir die
bestehenden Regelungen flexibilisieren
und unnötige unbürokratische Schritte
abbauen
aber wir dürfen beide Diskussionen eins
nicht vergessen
Standortpolitik ist immer noch
Wirtschaftspolitik und kann nicht von
der GKV geleistet werden vielen Dank für
die Aufmerksamkeit
für die Union Fraktionen hat das Wort
Dietrich Wohnstadt
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrter Herr Minister liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen
meine Herren stellen sich vor ihr Kind
ist krank es hat Fieber aber in der
Apotheke gibt es weder Fiebersaft noch
Zäpfchen auch der Kinderarzt kann ihnen
nicht helfen was also tun in die
Notaufnahme welche total überfüllt sein
wird in der Hoffnung dort Medikamente
für das fiebernde Kind zu erhalten meine
Damen und Herren das ist leider aktuell
die Realität diese Realität in der
Versorgung wird irritierender Weise noch
dadurch angereichert dass der der sich
bemüht durchaus fehlende Medikamente im
Ausland erwerben kann
einige Bundesländer haben es den Bund
vorgemacht geschaffen nun auch dringend
benötigte Medikamente auf diesem Weg
Herr Minister wäre es nicht ihre Aufgabe
gewesen hier im Vorfeld Lösungen zu
finden die aktuelle Situation meine
Damen und Herren braucht neue Lösungen
alte Werte und unter anderem Umständen
errichtete Mechanismen wie zum Beispiel
Rabattverträge tragen heute nicht mehr
die von Ihnen angesprochene
Überprüfungen Herr Minister ist mehr als
überfällig die wir selbst ernannte
fortschrittkoalition schreiten sie fort
handeln Sie jetzt
meine Damen und Herren schon längere
Zeit haben wir erhebliche Probleme mit
Lieferengpässen bei Medikamenten erst
die corona-krise denn der noch immer
andauernde Krieg in der Ukraine führen
uns deutlich vor Augen wie
unvorhergesehene Ereignisse zu starken
Lieferengpässen und damit auch zu
Engpässen in der Versorgung führen wir
sind bei der Produktion von Medikamenten
mittlerweile in einem viel zu hohem Maß
abhängig vom Ausland im Jahr 20 also
2020 wurden über 60% der Wirkstoffe für
Arzneimittel in Asien hergestellt
richtigerweise wird schon lange von
vielen Seiten gefordert dass die
Produktion zurück nach Europa zurück
nach Deutschland muss ich schließe mich
dieser Forderungen nachdrücklich an Herr
Minister hier müssen entsprechende
Anreize gesetzt werden und nicht nur
wohlfeile Worte gefunden werden
meine Damen und Herren weiter möchte ich
auf die Präqualifizierung im
hilfsmittelbereich eingehen seit 2011
mussten sich alle hilfsmittelerbringer
inklusive der Apotheken präqualifizieren
der vorliegende Entwurf streicht dieses
Verfahren für die Apotheken aber Studium
und die Regelungen der Apotheken
Betriebsordnung ersetzen keine
Präqualifizierung die hier gefundene
Begründung ist nicht sachgerecht denn
für alle anderen beispielsweise
Sanitätshäuser bleibt die Regelung
richtigerweise bestehen sehr geehrter
Minister nicht nur dass sie hier mit
viele Berufsgruppen ihre ebenfalls sehr
gute Ausbildung absprechen nein mit
dieser Regelung wird ein fairer
Wettbewerb zerstört und die
Versorgungsqualität gefährdet die
Zulassung durch die Präqualifizierung
wurde auf den Prinzipien der
Unabhängigkeit und der
Rechtsverbindlichkeit durch Überwachung
eingeführt die Verwaltung liegt beim
spitzenverbund als hohe Aufgabe dies ist
ein gutes System welches sich bewährt
hat wir begrüßen dass sie die liefer ung
besser angehen aber in der Umsetzung
sind noch viele Punkte ungeklärt und
ungelöst in dieser Form müssen wir das
Gesetz ablegen herzlichen Dank
und verbindet 90 die Grünen hat das Wort
Johannes Wagner
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen in den letzten Wochen war
ich viel unterwegs in Krankenhäusern
Kinderarztpraxen und Apotheken und
überall habe ich mit teilweise besorten
teilweise aber auch frustrierten
Mitarbeitenden das Gesundheitswesens
gesprochen
aber das war nicht die herausfordernden
Gespräche
am herausfordernden waren die Gespräche
mit Eltern die eigentlichen Antibiotikum
für ihre Kinder gebraucht hätten
Antibiotikum ist aber nicht verfügbar
war und die Eltern daher weite Fahrten
oder auch ein Antibiotikum in Kauf
nehmen mussten
wie ist das möglich ein so
fortschrittliches Land kann seine
eigenen Kinder nicht versorgen wie kann
das sein wurde ich gefragt
die Antworten sind vielschichtig das
haben wir gerade gehört und ich bin froh
Herr Minister dass sie mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf ist auch konkrete Lösungen
liefern
wir haben es noch nicht geschafft die
Globalisierung in geeignete Bahnen zu
lenken
die Globalisierung die so wesentlich zu
unserem Wohlstand beigetragen hat
die Vorteile haben wir gerne genutzt die
Nachteile und die Risiken aber
unterschätzt
wer immer nur das Billigste setzt und
sich ja noch abhängig macht von nur
einem Lieferanten egal ob bei
Medikamentenherstellung Schutzausrüstung
oder auch Energielieferungen wer sich so
abhängig macht es hat am Ende eben doch
einen sehr hohen Preis
und das sollten wir in Zukunft immer
bedenken die Lösung heißt nicht die
Globalisierung zurückzudrehen sondern
eine vorausschauende wertebasierte
Wirtschaftspolitik die sich breit
aufstellt das sind die unseren Kindern
schuldig vielen Dank
für unsere Fraktion hat
das Stefan pilsinger
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
bald steht wieder die Ferienzeit an und
Millionen von Deutschen machen sich auf
den Weg in Ihren wohlverdienten Urlaub
und wenn man dann mit vielen Eltern
spricht die gerade in
Urlaubsvorbereitungen sind dann erzählen
sie einem dieses Jahr dann nehme ich mir
nicht die Spezialitäten aus Italien
Österreich oder woanders mit oder die
Souvenirs sondern dieses Jahr nehme ich
mir mit Privatrezept einige Arzneimittel
für meine Kinder mit weil es in
Deutschland einfach nicht mehr genug
Medikamente in gewissen Bereichen die
fiebersäften und antibiotika-säften gibt
und wenn man damit den Herstellern
spricht ich weiß ja die Grünen machen
dass sie aus Prinzip nicht dann sagen
die einem ja wir können leider aufgrund
von den niedrigen Preisen
in Deutschland gewisse Arzneimittel
nicht mehr schicken und deswegen sage
ich Ihnen ja wir müssen endlich was
dafür tun damit in Deutschland wieder
als Nährmittel im breitenbereich gerade
für Kinder auch vorhanden sind aber
Herr Minister Lauterbach sie scheinen
aus Corona leider zu wenig gelernt zu
haben denn eigentlich müsste es ja auch
klar sein dass wir wieder mehr
Medikamente gerade in Deutschland
produzieren sollten und wir erinnern uns
an Corona als die coronen nach dem
Lockdown in China die coronazahlen dort
massiv gestiegen sind da wurden auch
fiebersenken Arzneimittel in Deutschland
kurzzeitig knapp weil 70 Prozent zum
Beispiel der Antibiotika Produktion in
China
bewerkstelligt wird und deswegen ist es
meine feste Überzeugung dass wir mehr
Produktion von Arzneimitteln aus dem
Ausland zurück nach Deutschland
nach nach Deutschland bekommen müssen
und dafür müssen wir auch Geld in die
Hand nehmen und Herr Minister sie haben
ja doch viele Projekte sie sagen auf den
Weg gebracht aber wir könnten auch Geld
aus unnötigen Projekten wie zum Beispiel
der Cannabis Legalisierung oder ihren
geliebten Kiosken abziehen und in die
Arzneimittelproduktion tun ich glaube
dort wäre es besser aufgehoben und wir
brauchen deswegen einen sehr schnellen
Dialog mit den Herstellern um
kurzfristig die Apotheken wieder mit
wichtigen Arzneimitteln zu versorgen und
langfristig die Investitionsbedingungen
in Deutschland so zu setzen dass wieder
als Nährmittel in Europa produziert
werden können Herr Minister kommen Sie
doch endlich mal raus aus ihrem
elfenbeintum reden Sie mit dem
Betroffenen und sorgen Sie dafür dass
die Probleme endlich gelöst werden reine
ankündigen die bringen uns auf Dauer
nicht vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und die letzte Rednerin der letzte
Redner in der Debatte ist für die
SPD-Fraktion Entschuldigung Türkei gut
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich muss jetzt
kurz Anknüpfen an die letzten
Redebeitrag also zum einen das Projekt
der Cannabis Legalisierung und auch dass
der gesundheitskiuske unnötige Projekte
zu nennen da hat man sich halt leider
offensichtlich mit den Projekten
überhaupt nicht beschäftigt aber ganz
unabhängig aber ganz unabhängig davon
der Kollege pilsinger in keines dieser
Projekte ist bisher Geld geflossen dass
der Minister da reingepackt hätte also
insofern können Sie ganz beruhigt sein
dass spielt hier überhaupt keine Rolle
ich will aber jetzt zum Gesetz als
solche zurückkommen weil es ist wichtig
dass wir hier ein vernünftiges Gesetz
vorgelegt bekommen haben bei dem ich
überhaupt nicht bestreiten will dass wir
es noch verbessern können das ist
Aufgabe des Partner machen aber erlauben
sie eine Zwischenfrage des Kollegen
pilsinger aber bitte Kollege
können wir darüber
klein ich bitte um Ruhe der Kollege
pilsinger stellt jetzt seine Frage dann
können wir auch stellen oder Debatte
fortfahren ja Herr Kollege heidenblut
sie haben sich als Regierung als
ampelfraktion zum Ziel gesetzt den
Schwarzmarkt auszutrocknen und jetzt
haben sie nach dem ersten verfehlten
Eckpunkten erneut Eckpunkte vorgelegt
und da frage ich sie wir haben doch zwei
Sachen in Deutschland nicht billige
Energie und günstige klimatische
Bedingungen um cannabisiert züchten zu
können wie wollen sie schaffen dass ihre
Kiffer Clubs am Ende billigeres Cannabis
produzieren als der Dealer und
malcodiumsack die ist wird viel teurer
sein und deswegen ist der ganzes Gesetz
einfach Muts erklären Sie mir mal wie
das Cannabis günstiger sein kann
also zunächst mal kann ich Ihnen sagen
dass wir es gar nicht schaffen wollen
dass die CSC Cannabis produzieren ist
schon deren Aufgabe selbst wie das
Anbauen wie das machen und sie haben es
ja gerade selbst gesagt Geld haben wir
da offensichtlich nicht reingesteckt ist
auch nicht die Absicht wenn Sie diesen
wenn Sie die Säule einzeln die Eckpunkte
gesehen haben dass wir da Geld
reinstecken werden ich bin aber ganz
zuversichtlich wenn sie sich mal mit der
Szene beschäftigen und wenn sie mal
versuchen aus dem Turm der Ablehnung und
all diese diesen Mauern die sie sich da
fröhlich gebaut haben herauszukommen und
mal ernsthaft sich dieses Problem und
ich gebe die Antwort glaube ich nicht
sie und mal ernsthaft sich dieses
Problems anzunehmen dann werden Sie
erfahren dass die Menschen durchaus die
die sich auf den Weg machen wollen zum
Beispiel solche CSC dann zu machen gute
Möglichkeiten sehen das in einer Weise
Art und Weise zu tun dass wir es mit
einem vernünftigen einer vernünftigen
Art von Cannabis zu tun haben und auf
der anderen Seite auch mit einer die
durchaus dem Schwarzmarkt entgegenwirkt
also das ist nun wirklich nicht das
trotzdem hat allerdings mit dem Thema
hier trotzdem herzlichen Dank dass Sie
mir die Möglichkeit geben dazu was zu
sagen nun wirklich so gar nichts zu tun
aber vielen herzlichen Dank
Herr konnte ich das doch mal klar machen
ich komme zurück zu dem Thema um das es
geht und ich will noch mal den Punkt
aufgreifen dass dieses Gesetz wirklich
in hervorragender Form alle drei
Bereiche aufgreift und anpackt in denen
wir dringend etwas tun müssen über zwei
davon ist schon viel gesagt worden einer
ist mir persönlich noch ein wenig zu
kurz gekommen der Kollege Lindemann hat
ihn aber schon angesprochen das ist der
Bereich der Apothekerin und Apotheker
die haben wirklich da kann ich Ihnen nur
Recht geben Hervorragendes geleistet die
kämpfen sozusagen am Ende der
Lieferkette darum dass die Lieferung
noch bei den Patientinnen und Patienten
ankommt und wenn es die Lieferung ist
das etwas Vergleichbares oder etwas
hilft im Zweifel übrigens sogar etwas
selbst hergestelltes dann die notlindert
und das muss anerkannt werden ich finde
gut dass wir im Gesetz aufgreifen dass
wir die Regeln die in Corona den
Apothekerin Apothekern Beinfreiheit
gegeben haben dass wir die haben und
fortsetzen können da müssen wir
vielleicht noch mal drauf gucken ob das
nicht auch verbesserungsfähig ist ich
finde es wichtig dass wir uns die Frage
der retaxisation anschauen in
Zusammenhang mit diesen austauschregeln
darf da den Apothekerin Apotheker gar
nichts drohen das muss ich sehr deutlich
sagen und die Null retaxation ist
allerdings etwas was nicht mehr
sozusagen hergehört da müssen noch
wegkommen von
und wir brauchen
um das ergänzend zu sagen aus meiner
Sicht übrigens auch eine Bagatellgrenze
weil es ist manchmal wirklich absurd
welche Briefe geschrieben werden für
dann am Ende 30 Cent ritaxation auch das
ist nicht wirklich passt nicht in die
heutige Zeit das beschäftigt mehr als es
nützt also da gibt es Punkte mit denen
wir uns deutlich beschäftigen müssen und
zur Präqualifizierung die hier gerade so
massiv angegriffen wurde also deren
Überlegung ob wir da nicht auch was tun
müssen also es ist ja nun auch nicht nur
eine Frage die das Ministerium berührt
sondern auch die Länder und
interessanterweise übrigens auch
cdu-länder sehr deutlich die an der
Stelle gerne mal drauf gucken weil das
finde ich müssen wir auch durchaus tun
macht Sinn ein Punkt möchte ich noch zum
Schluss Ansprechen der hat auch was mit
lieferen Engpässen zu tun ich hatte das
schon bei meiner ersten Rede bei den
lieferengpassfragen angesprochen und
daher pilsinger die Überleitung zu
Cannabis schon gemacht hat muss er jetzt
wieder ganz hart sein es geht um
Cannabis als Medizin und da wäre es mir
wirklich sehr wichtig dass wir dieses
Gesetz auch nutzen dem freundlichen
Hinweis des Vorsitzenden des GBA zu
Folge folgen und dafür zu sorgen dass
wir noch was verbessern über das hinaus
was mit der Richtlinie geschehen ist und
dass wir bei Cannabis als Medizin
endlich aus dem genehmungsvorbehalt
rauskommt und vielleicht auch an der
austherapie das wäre ein wichtiger
Schritt bedanke mich für die
Aufmerksamkeit
und damit schließe ich die Aussprache
und
interfraktionell wird die Überweisung
der Vorlagen auf den Drucksachen 68 71
und 68 99 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere überweisungsvorschläge
dass es nicht der Fall dann verfahren
wir wie vorgeschlagen vielen Dank ich
rufe nun auf den Tagesordnungspunkt
Nummer 7 die Beratung des Antrags der
Fraktion der AFD mit dem Titel Städte
und Gemeinden vor Wohnungsnot schützen
Vetorecht bei zwangszuweisungen von
Flüchtlingen für die Aussprache ist hier
eine Dauer von 39 Minuten vorgesehen
und ich bitte Sie die Plätze
entsprechend einzunehmen
und
dann öffne ich die Aussprache und ich
erteile das Wort für die afd-fraktion
hat
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren